Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, wie geht's dir?
Nicht so gut.
Bist du etwa wieder Bahn gefahren?
Ja, zu viel.
Was ist passiert in der Bahn?
In der Bahn, wenn man mal drin sitzt, dann geht es ja meist einigermaßen. Aber viele, viele Verspätungen habe ich in diesem Monat wieder erleben müssen. Und dann steht man so draußen auf dem Gleis, hatte sich dann auch vorgenommen, diesmal nehme ich keinen Mantel mehr mit, denn es ist ja Sommer und dann fängt man an zu frieren. Oder plötzlich wird man dann noch mal schnell nass, während man zum Bahnhof läuft. Und irgendwie bin ich jetzt gesundheitlich etwas angeschlagen und deswegen haben wir uns ja heute entschieden, auch digital nur aufzuzeichnen, was ich sehr bedauere. Erstmal, weil es immer schön ist dich zu treffen und weil ich jetzt natürlich nicht an das Schnitzel komme, heute Nachmittag. Aber so ist es nun mal, das Bahnfahren ist wirklich in diesem Monat katastrophal gewesen. Ich habe verrückte Dinge erlebt, auch dann tragische Dinge. Ich reise ja allein und muss dann nur sehen, dass ich pünktlich zu einem Vortrag komme. Aber man sieht dann auch Leute, die nicht alleine reisen, wie z.B. vor mir dann eine Mutter mit einem kleinen Kind, mit einem Säugling. dieser Säugling muss gestillt werden und der schreit schon die ganze Zeit. Sie kommt aber überhaupt nicht mehr in den Zug rein, weil der Zug so überbucht ist, sodass man ihr sagt, ja, sie muss jetzt nochmal an ganz anderes Gleis rennen. Ich dann auch, weil ich auch nicht mehr in den Zug reinkam. Und dann versucht man es dort dann. Und dann sah ich dann, wie sie dann Platz fand und auch stillen konnte. Aber das sind Dinge, die einfach nicht in einem modernen Land sein dürfen. Und es macht einen schon sehr traurig. Denn manchmal funktioniert es ja. Und dann denkt man, ja, eigentlich könnte Bahnfahren ja so toll sein. Und dann ist es aber wieder nicht möglich. Ganz verrückt. Aber jetzt erzähle ich dir eine Anekdote, die ein bisschen klingt wie eine Anekdote aus dem Paulaner Garten, also wie ausgedacht. Aber sie ist wirklich so geschehen in Würzburg, auf dem Bahnhof morgens stand ich da und der Zug kam auch pünktlich. Das war gar nicht das Problem. Ich stand da und Würzburg hat jetzt eine digitale Wagenstandsanzeige. Das heißt, man kann oben genau sehen, wo welcher Wagen hält.
Ja, der aber von vielen gar nicht so gesehen wird. Also ich würde sagen, dass Habeck da doch einer der wenigen ist, der das auch so klar erkennt und auch in der eigenen Partei so klar erkennt. Ich hatte eine Podiumsdiskussion in Oldenburg. Das war so ein klimakongress. Da war Rebecca Harms. Die war auch bei den Grünen im Europaparlament. Ich weiß nicht, wird jetzt so um die 70 sein. Und das war interessant, dass sie gar nicht auf irgendeinen MMT-Argument angeg- Also das hat sie überhaupt nicht interessiert. Sie hat immer nur gesagt, ja, dass das auch mit der Bahn nicht so weiter läuft, dass wir so wenig Züge haben. Das liegt ja an den Umweltverbänden. Die hätten da auch viel blockiert. Solche wirklich CSU-Argumente kamen dann da. Und als dann doch sehr viel Kapitalismus-Kritik seitens des Publikums artikuliert wurde, hat sie dann gesagt, ja, also sie könnte das auch gar nicht verstehen, warum hier so viele gegen den Kapitalismus sind. Eigentlich ging es uns doch allen noch gut. Wir hätten eine soziale Marktwirtschaft, wo ich denke, na ja klar, mit 10.000 Netto ist der Kapitalismus ein super System, würde ich auch eher mal so sagen. Aber ist vielleicht auch nicht so repräsentativ, was man als EU-Politikerin verdient. Also ganz interessant, dass da überhaupt nicht mal weiter gedacht wurde und man da total im kleinen Kleid verharrte. Also ich hatte eigentlich versucht, sie mit Argumenten auf meine Seite zu ziehen, dass sie sagte, ja, jetzt können wir ja doch mal Geld ausgeben. Aber das war überhaupt nicht da. Und dann sagte sie, ja, im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern steht die Bahn ja auch noch gut da. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, im Vergleich zu welchen Ländern. Und dann meinte sie, ja, in der Schweiz sei das schon besser. Aber die geben ja auch mehr Geld für die Bahn aus. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, sehen Sie, vielleicht gibt es ja einen Zusammenhang zwischen investitionen und Pünktlichkeit. Und das ist so abstrus zu erleben. Und dann hat man eine grünen Politikerin. Da war ich jetzt noch nicht mit dem CSU Agrar-Lobbyisten auf der Bühne.
Ja, es ist einfach folgt. So du willst uns Kissinger spielen, sehe ich hier.
Ja, hast du da wo es geguckt?
Ein bisschen, wenig.
Es war nicht besonders erhellend. Sie sagen ja eigentlich jedes Jahr dasselbe nur, kommt jetzt noch ganz oft Ukraine vor. Auch von der Leyen hat eigentlich noch mal das gesagt, was sie immer so erzählt dann. Und dass das jetzt noch mal die große Chance für Europa sei. deswegen habe ich mich auf zwei alte konzentriert. Und zwar habe ich mir die Rede von Kissinger und von George Soros angesehen. Und wir hören jetzt erst mal Kissinger mit 99 Jahren zugeschaltet. Ich gebe zu, man kann ihn sehr schwer verstehen. Ja, das war eine Aussage, die für einen Skandal gesorgt hat. Ja, er geht dann noch sehr viel weiter und er sagt, dass das für Europa dann gefährlich werden kann und generell gefährlich für den Weltfrieden. Die Ausführungen sind nicht so klar. Nachvollziehbar ist es auch eine bisweilen abenteuerliche, sprunghafte Argumentation, wenn man überhaupt diese einzelnen Satzfetzen da so wahrnehmen kann. Jedenfalls, was er uns eigentlich mitteilen wollte, ist, dass wir versuchen sollten und die Ukraine versuchen sollte, an den zu dem Status zurückzukommen, der vor dem Krieg herrschte. Also nicht zu glauben, dass man jetzt wieder mehr Land gewinnen kann von Russland, sondern dass man eigentlich jetzt zu dem Punkt zurückkommen kann, wie im Februar daraufhin hat Zelensky Kissinger vorgeworfen, er verwechsel wohl die aktuelle Zeit mit 1938 und der Appeasement-Politik. Nun, man kann das aus Zelenskys Position natürlich verstehen, dass er da entsprechend los schießt und nicht gleich sagt, ja, so machen wir es, denn das wäre ja verhandlungsstrategisch eher dumm, das zu tun. Aber dass das zum Teil hier medial auch so skandalisiert wurde, fand ich erstaunlich. Es gab dann wenige Artikel, die sich auch für diese Kissinger-Position ausgesprochen haben. interessanterweise in der Welt, die ja sonst immer doch sehr stark den Rhein-Selenski-Kurs unterstützen. Aber da war einfach auch dann zu lesen, na ja, ein Diktatfriede wird wohl nicht möglich sein. Dafür ist Russland zu stark. Und es gab ja dann zwei Wochen vorher im Editorial Board der New York times auch etwas zu lesen, was in der deutschen Medienlandschaft ganz eigenartig rezipiert wurde.
Wurde es aufgegriffen? Ich hab nichts gesehen.
Es wurde aufgegriffen und ich habe zum Beispiel den Titel gelesen, plötzlich vertritt die New York times die Wagenknecht-Position. Und das fand ich wieder sowas von national beschränkt gedacht. Also dass man immer nur guckt, ach ja, hat das irgendwann in ihren vielen Auftritten auch mal Sarah Wagenknecht so ausgedrückt? Ah ja, dann ist das eine Wagenknecht-Position, als sei damit irgendetwas ausgesagt.
Und wir wissen ja, die Wagenknecht-Argumentation ist ja eigentlich die AfD-Argumentation. Genau. Denn Wagenknecht wurde ja da konfrontiert. Wir haben nur noch wenige Sekunden Zeit für das Interview, aber wie unterscheidet sich ihre Position von der AfD?
Ja, das ist alles so...
Und dann hat sie zehn Sekunden Zeit gehabt.
Ja, das ist wirklich so hirnrissig. Und das ist einfach ein sehr interessanter Text, der da erschienen ist. Und es ist ja keineswegs so, dass die New York times zimperlich ist bei diesem Krieg und auch mit Erforderungen nach Waffenlieferung und all das. Aber hier sagt man doch, wir müssen da aufpassen. Und dass das vom Editorial Board dann veröffentlicht wird, ist natürlich auch nochmal ganz klar an das liberaldemokratische Amerika gewendet. Und ich habe mal so ein paar Absätze daraus mitgebracht. Das heißt, da April Heinz, die Direktorin des Nationalen nachrichtendienstes, warnte kürzlich vor dem Streitkräfteausschuss des Senats, dass die nächsten Monate unbeständig sein könnten. Der Konflikt zwischen der Ukraine und Russland könnte, Zitat, eine unvorhersehbare und potenziell eskalierende Richtung einschlagen, sagte sie, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Russland mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen droht, steigt. Das ist also erstmal das, was sie feststellen. Und jetzt muss man sich fragen, was will man eigentlich mit Amerika, wenn man sich da engagiert. Und man kann nicht einfach die Kriegsziele immer so verschieben. Letztlich liegt es nicht in Amerikas interesse, heißt es dann im Editorial Board, sich in einen totalen Krieg mit Russland zu stürzen, auch wenn ein Verhandlungsfrieden der Ukraine einige harte Entscheidungen abverlangen könnte. Und die Ziele und die Strategie der USA in diesem Krieg sind schwieriger zu erkennen, da sich die Parameter der Mission geändert zu haben scheinen. Versuchen die Vereinigten Staaten beispielsweise zur Beendigung dieses Konflikts beizutragen, und zwar durch eine Regelung, die eine souveräne Ukraine und eine Art von Beziehung zwischen den Vereinigten Staaten und Russland ermöglicht? Oder versuchen die Vereinigten Staaten jetzt Russland dauerhaft zu schwächen? Hat sich das Ziel der Regierung darauf verlagert, Vladimir Putin zu destabilisieren oder ihn zu stürzen? Beabsichtigen die Vereinigten Staaten, Vladimir Putin als Kriegsverbrecher zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen? Oder besteht das Ziel darin, einen größeren Krieg zu vermeiden? Das wäre mal zu klären, sagen die.
Genau. Wenn Harald Wälzer bei Anne Will sitzt und vorwirft nach 40 Minuten Diskussion, dass wir ja die Kriegsziele in Deutschland noch gar nicht geklärt haben, wird ihm immer gleich wieder vorgeworfen, ach, hier, der spielt ja das Spiel Russlands und so weiter. Das ist ja unglaublich, was er da sagt. Aber das greifen die im Grunde auf. Es ist nicht unbedeutend, dass es eben, man sagt immer so, die New York times schreibt, aber in dem Fall war es halt wirklich die New York times. Also das Board der Chefredakteure da, die das einfach formulieren.
Genau, es gibt da nicht noch mal einen Namen, der dafür steht. Das hat dann nicht Herausgeber XY gesagt, sondern es ist einfach das Editorial Board gibt, das jetzt hier kund.
Das machen die immer mal wieder so, auch vor Wahlen zum Beispiel, um dann einfach zu einer politischen Richtung, Wahlempfehlung und so weiter. Und man muss es auch aus dieser amerikanischen Richtung sehen. Amerika ist eben für uns alle irgendwie der Fallback. Wenn Amerika das nicht mitmachen würde, würden wir das in Europa alles nicht machen, was wir gerade machen. Wir würden niemals über Panzerlieferungen in die Ukraine nachdenken. Und aus dieser amerikanischen Sicht, und das hat heute morgen im Podcast sicherheitshalber, also in der heutigen Ausgabe vom 31. Mai, Janka Oertel. Sie haben mit Janka Oertel, die sich da ein bisschen auskennt, zum Thema China gesprochen. Und da war eine Frage von den Vieren, wenn jetzt Putin sich entscheidet, aus taktischen Gründen Atomwaffen einzusetzen, auf ukrainischem Gebiet, um da irgendwas so zu zerstören, das ist halt und so weiter. Wie würde sich China dazu verhalten? Und dann hat sie nicht ausgeschlossen, dass dann die chinesen einfach sagen, wer sich so in die Ecke drängen lässt, also Putin hat ja nun wirklich viel gesagt und auch viel angedeutet und viel vorher gewarnt. Und dann kam es halt dazu, dass China das sofort normalisieren würde, könnte. Also es war so eins der beiden Szenarien. Und das ist da eben nicht zu diesem großen Schreckmoment, oh jetzt müssen wir uns aber hier mal und so weiter gut mit unseren eigentlichen wichtigen Wirtschaftspartnern Amerika und so weiter stellen. Da habe ich auch so gedacht, ey so langsam ist es doch an der Zeit, sich über Kriegsziele zu verständigen, dass Sie Lenski jetzt mit so Kommunikationen kommt, wie wir wollen natürlich als Kriegsziel auch die Krim zurück. Und dann Kissinger kommt und sagt, naja Status Quo der Vorkriegszeit, und damit ist erst mal nur Februar 2022 gemeint, die Krim gehört zu Russland und der Donbass ist umkämpft. Also es wird wahnsinnig schwer, hier diesen Krieg wieder zu beenden. Das haben wir ja mit Alexander Kluge gehört. Ins Stolpern zu springen ist schon schwer, aber eine Lösung zu finden, bei der alle sagen, das könnte neuer Status Quo sein, ist natürlich am Ende Putins Schuld. Es war eine Entscheidung, das jetzt alles aufzumischen, aber jetzt wird es wahnsinnig kompliziert.
Es wird wahnsinnig kompliziert und Wolfgang Ischinger hat das ja auch betont, dass dann irgendwann beide Seiten auch so geschwächt und abgenutzt sind, dass sie dann in anderer Weise nochmal miteinander sprechen. Auch das ist eine Möglichkeit, aber die bedeutet natürlich auch nochmal viele Tote und einen sehr langen Zeitraum, in dem wir noch mit diesem Krieg zu tun haben. Du hast es jetzt angesprochen, Amerika spielt natürlich eine wichtige Rolle auch für unser Engagement. Und was ist eigentlich, fragt das Editorial Board, wenn der Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung nicht mehr so da ist für die Ukraine. Wir hatten jetzt Zelensky auch sehr präsent bei amerikanischen Großveranstaltungen. Und dann heißt es hier, das Leid der Ukraine hat die Amerikaner aufgerüttelt. Aber die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung für einen Krieg, der weit weg von den US-Küsten stattfindet, wird nicht ewig da andauern. Die Inflation ist für die amerikanischen Wähler ein viel größeres Problem als die Ukraine. Das klingt jetzt ungeheuer hart. Aber wir wissen ja, wie Außenpolitik auch in den USA wahrgenommen wird. Andere Länder, wann die mal in den Nachrichten auftauchen. Und natürlich kann das sehr schnell gehen. Es heißt dann noch, ein entscheidender militärischer Sieg der Ukraine über Russland, bei dem die Ukraine das gesamte Gebiet, das Russland seit 2014 erobert hat, zurückgehält, ist kein realistisches Ziel. Obwohl Russlands Planung und Kampfhandlungen überraschend schlampig waren, bleibt Russland zu stark. Und Putin hat zu viel persönliches prestige in die Inversion investiert, um einen Rückzieher zu machen. deswegen versuchen sie auch beiden ein bisschen zu Maßregeln. Also, der hat ja gesagt, dass Putin nicht an der Macht bleiben kann. Oder auch der Verteidigungsminister hat gesagt, Russland muss geschwächt werden. Nancy Pelosi hat gesagt, sie will die Ukraine unterstützen, bis der Sieg erhungen ist. Und da sagen die vom Editorial Board, das mögen mitreißende Unterstützungsbekundungen sein, aber sie bringen die Verhandlungen nicht weiter. Letztendlich sind es die Ukrainer, die die schwierigen Entscheidungen treffen müssen. Klar, die Ukraine als souveränes Land, wir können auch das nicht diktieren. Sie sind diejenigen, die gegen die russische aggression kämpfen, sterben und ihre Häuser verlieren. Und sie sind es, die entscheiden müssen, wie ein Ende des krieges aussehen könnte. Doch während der Krieg weitergeht, sollten Biden Präsident Wladimir Zelensky und seinen Leuten klar machen, dass es eine Grenze gibt, wie weit die Vereinigten Staaten und die NATO gehen werden, um Russland zu konfrontieren. Und Grenzen für die Waffen, das Geld und die politische Unterstützung, die müssen sie artikulieren. Und sie gestehen dann auch, die Konfrontation mit dieser Realität mag schmerzhaft sein, aber sie ist keine beschwichtigung. Das ist die Pflicht der Regierungen, nicht einen illusorischen Sieg hinterher zu jagen. Und das findet in deutschen Talkshows ja sehr stark statt, dass man dieser Illusion dahinter herjagt. Und man ist damit immer auf einer tollen Seite und kann sich damit brüsten. Aber das ist leider der Sachzwang des krieges, dass der Idealismus als erstes stirbt dort. Und das ist ganz, ganz traurig zu sehen. Und ich bin ja nun auch jemand, der weit davon entfernt ist, Kissinger zu unterstützen. Zumal Kissinger ja auch schon jede Position mal vertreten hat. Also man kann gar nicht sagen, man ist für die Kissinger-Position. Jedenfalls blickt Kissinger noch mal ein bisschen zurück, auf die lange geschichte von Europa und Russland. Das ist die große Angst, die Kissinger hat, dass diese Allianz zu China sich verstärkt, wenn Europa Russland aufgeben muss. Und hier kann man auch wieder betonen, Herr Putin tut natürlich alles dafür, dass man in dieser Weise reagieren muss. Aber wenn diese lange Tradition, die auch spannungsreich war, zwischen Russland und Europa nicht mehr besteht, wenn das also wirklich abgekoppelt wird, dann wird sicherlich die Allianz zwischen China und Russland stärker. Und das wiederum ist dann für den gesamten westen ein riesenproblem.
So und George Soros, wie alt ist der eigentlich?
Er ist 91 und deswegen können wir ihn auch ein bisschen klarer noch verstehen. Und er beginnt seinen Vortrag mal folgendermaßen. Er meint das aber gar nicht so lustig, auch wenn das Publikum da lacht. Er greift das später wieder und wieder auf, das Ende der Zivilisation. Und er macht das nicht nur deutlicher mit Blick auf den dritten Weltkrieg, sondern auch mit Blick auf den Klimawandel. Und da würde ich sagen, spricht er eigentlich den richtigen Punkt ab, dass man das mal vom kompletten Ende her sieht. Jetzt wissen wir natürlich selbst, dass George Soros kein Kind von Traurigkeit ist. Und wenn man sich ansieht, wo er in all den Jahrzehnten investiert war, in welchen sehr viel Dreck verursachtenden Unternehmen, dann ist das ja eine gewisse Ironie, dass er da spricht. Aber wir können ja auch hier einfach das Argument als Argument nehmen. Was da in die Schlagzeilen geriet, war, was George Soros über Merkel sagt.
Du, largely to the mercantilist policy pursued by former Chancellor Angela Merkel. She had made special deals with Russia for the supply of gas and made China Germany's largest export market. That made Germany the best performing country in Europe. But now there is a heavy price to pay.
Ja.
Und was haben wir dazu noch ergänzend gelesen? In Kampf der Nation über das Verhältnis mit Frankreich und so weiter. Es ist wirklich schlimm. Und wir bräuchten eigentlich hier so eine, nicht so sehr ein Buch vielleicht, sondern so eine Art Wikipedia, wo alles mal miteinander verlinkt ist und wir dann uns durch so eine Bilanz einfach klicken. Es ist ganz schlimm, was wir jetzt über diese Merkel-Zeit abzuarbeiten haben. Und das wird auch länger als 15 Jahre dauern, so wie Merkel sich da gesondert hat einfach auf dieser.
Ich glaube, die Debatte muss nur eine sein, die nicht so verläuft, wie wir das jetzt häufig in Artikeln, Kolumnen lesen können, dass man sagt, ah ja, das sind Putin-Freunde gewesen. Und wir haben euch schon immer gewarnt, aber jetzt hat Putin das gemacht, weil wir auch nicht wissen, was, wenn man auf die Warnungen früher gehört hätte, Putin heute tun würde. Also das sind Fragen, die man so nicht stellen kann und bei denen man auch immer sagen kann, der Konflikt ist so lange nicht da, solange er nicht da ist. Also eine Beziehung funktioniert, solange sie funktioniert. Man kann auch nicht sagen, nach 20 Jahren Beziehung, wenn dann jemand fremdgegangen ist und dann kann man nicht sagen, dann habe ich die 20 Jahre mich geirrt. Dann führt das zu allem nichts. Ich glaube, deshalb muss die Debatte viel mehr sein. Warum eigentlich hat man wirtschaftlich eine solche Dummheit angestellt? Denn erstmal würde ja jeder Mensch lernen, der ein bisschen Geld auf dem Konto hat, diversifizieren, sich unabhängig machen von nur einer Sache. Genau. Das bedeutet es ja bei Energie natürlich zuallererst, weil das ist was am entscheidenden ist. Merken wir auch, wenn Energiepreise steigen und steigt, alles an Preisen. Denn natürlich ist Energie überall vonnöten. Und dass man da so blauäugig sein kann, das ist also ökonomisch nicht nachvollziehbar. Ökonomisch genauso wenig nachvollziehbar, dass man nicht all die Innovationen hervorgebracht hat, die man doch eh brauchen musste. Das war doch klar. Also dass der Klimawandel nicht 25 erledigt sein wird, war ja klar, sondern er wird sich mehr oder weniger verstärkt haben. Insofern sind diese Zukunftstechnologien ja alle schon beschrieben gewesen. Man hätte es nur aufgreifen müssen. Und das ist eigentlich das große Versagen von Merkel. Gar nicht so sehr diese diplomatischen Versuche, die es dann gab und manches war meinetwegen auch blauäugig rückblickend betrachtet. Aber das kann man auf vieles immer nur rückblickend betrachtet. Wir machen natürlich lauter solche Deals in der Hoffnung, dass dafür die den anderen nicht einen draufgeben. Und wenn sie es dann aber doch machen, dann haben wir uns dann geirrt. Aber dann kann man nicht sagen, wir haben diesen Fehler schon immer gemacht. Und das ist jetzt vor allem amüsant, wenn das so von CDU-Seite oder so artikuliert wird, dass man das Merkel alles in die Schuhe schieben muss. Naja, die CDU hat versucht, jedes solar-förderungsgesetz zu verhindern. Die CDU hat immer versucht, die Autoindustrie zu stärken. Sie hat all das, was wir heute als Problem diagnostizieren, das hat sie immer, immer forciert. deswegen ist es natürlich vollkommen blöd, sie nicht so zu tun, als hätte da irgendwie Merkel eine besondere Nähe zu Putin gehabt. Nö, die hat einfach auch die Parteilinie immer erfüllt.
Genau, wir reden ja gleich über Antipolitik und die steckt da eben auch so ein bisschen drin. Wir hatten nach nur fünf Jahren, sechs Jahren, rot-grün damals die weltgrößten, also wirklich Weltmarktführer Solar, Energie und Windkraft. 15 Jahre später hängen wir nicht nur von Russland aber als Energielieferant, sondern eben auch von diesen fossilen Brennstoffen. Es ist ja erst mal, es ist ja auf zwei Ebenen, ja, wir hängen davon fossilen Brennstoffen ab. David Williams hat in seinem jüngsten Podcast, den hab ich auch durch Zufall heute Morgen gehört, nochmal betont, wie krass das eigentlich in England gerade ist. Da ist ja wirklich alles da nieder und die Tory-Regierung stützt sich so auf die letzten beiden Industrie-Sektoren, die man irgendwie mit Ach und Graf aufrecht erhält. Und Deutschland hat es richtig gemacht, wir sind divers aufgestellt, ja, wir florieren hier irgendwie. Und das stimmt aber nicht, wenn man sich das anschaut, wie die Bilanz jetzt aussieht. Wir hängen von der Autoindustrie ab. Alle Nachwuchskräfte wollen immer noch in die Autoindustrie. Das ist natürlich seit 2015, seitdem dieses Skandal so ein bisschen anders. Aber jetzt kriegt ja VW das so ein bisschen hin mit der ganzen Elektrifizierung und so weiter. Aber es ist natürlich auch keine Lösung fürs Klima, dass trotzdem alle weiter Auto fahren. Also wir haben die wichtigsten Arbeitgeber und die wichtigsten Innovationstreiber mit Forschungsbudget, 10 Milliarden Euro und so weiter, größer als die DFG, ist immer noch VW, aber eben VW. Und wenn man dann den zweiten großen Sektor Chemie uns irgendwie anschauen, ja, aber da liegen halt wirklich diese Rohre für die Energielieferung direkt nach Russland. Also da kann man gar nicht umsatteln. Wenn da irgendwas passiert, sei es mit dem Gas, sei es mit Russland als Quelle, fällt dieser ganze Sektor einfach in sich zusammen. Und dann haben wir halt so eine Problemwaage wie jetzt gerade, Inflation, 7, irgendwas Prozent, das höchste seit 50 Jahren, seit damals sonntags nicht mehr Auto gefahren wurde, aber es sind eben 50 Prozent plus bei den Energiekosten. Und da tanzt uns dann wirklich die Industrie einfach auf der Nase rum. Wir haben ja wahrscheinlich alle gestern diese Grafik bei Twitter gesehen, wie sich der Benzinpreis vom Ölpreis entkoppelt hat. Wir haben ja keine Mangelknappheit an Öl, es wurde gefördert wie blöde. Nur wir haben einfach eine Industrie, die auch während in Frankreich einfach der Benzinpreis gedeckt wird, hofft man in Deutschland wieder, dass die Preisnachlässe, die in den Tankstellen gewährt werden, auch an die Kunden weitergegeben werden. Und das ist eine Zurückhaltung und Unterlassung von Seiten der Politik. Aufgrund immer noch dieser Tradition, dass es eben 15 Jahre Merkel waren und so viel gesetze gar nicht gerade neu geschrieben werden können, damit man das mal ordentlich regelt. Aber es ist wirklich traurig, ist gerade so ein Subthema hier, stelle ich fest, in der Mai-Ausgabe, dass wir hier diese Merkel-Bilanz jetzt wirklich mal einfordern. Irgendwer muss ich jetzt mal hinsetzen und das mal aufschreiben alles.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich will das ökonomisch einfach mal durchdacht haben. Nicht jetzt, sie hätte da schon wissen können, dass das ist alles vollkommener Mumpitz. Wir wissen es, dass Russland da einmarschiert ist, war dann doch überraschend. Also man kann natürlich sagen, wir haben es schon immer gewusst. Da gibt es dann so Leute wie Marie-Louise Beck, die sagt dann, ich habe schon 2009 das gesagt, aber fest steht auch, 13 Jahre hat das dann nicht gemacht. Und wenn der Chef der Sicherheitskonferenz sagt, wir haben das ein paar Tage vorher nicht gewusst, dass das passiert, dann muss man das mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen. Und es hätte auch sein können, dass Putin das nächstes Jahr machte, hat es jetzt gemacht. Und es hätte aber sein können, dass er es nächstes Jahr machen will und dann nicht mehr gelebt hat. Und dann hätte er es nicht machen können. Also diese Fragen stellen sich nicht. Also das ist dann so, wie hätte ich das Fremdgehen verhindern können, indem ich nie geheiratet hätte oder so. Also das ist Unsinn.
Genau, also der Hinweis auf Heusgen ist ganz wichtig. Heusgen hat im deutschen Fernsehen gesagt, ich habe das drei Tage vorher nicht geahnt. Und wenn das der wichtigste Merkel-Berater, der mit Putin selbst verhandelt hat, mit Obama und mit allen, und er jetzt die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz leitet, drei Tage vorher nicht einschätzen kann, was da passiert und dann davon überrascht ist, sollten wir alle überrascht sein. Und deswegen ist die wichtige politische Frage jetzt auch, warum haben wir 2022 nicht 30 Gigawatt Windstrom in der Nordsee? Und es ist nicht die Frage, warum hängen wir immer noch so von Putin ab? diese Frage müssen wir jetzt gerade klären und lösen. Aber diese andere Frage, warum haben wir da so eine krasse Unterlassung gehabt? Obwohl doch Windkraft, und es sind ja nun mal echt die deutschen Unternehmen, Siemens mit einer 10 Megawatt Turbine. Ja, da fangen die Unternehmen an, den Windpark zu planen. Und bis dann die Turbine eingesetzt wird, kann Siemens vermelden, wir haben noch ein paar Ideen gehabt, die ist jetzt doppelt so effektiv. So sind ja die Entwicklungszyklen da gerade. Und warum haben wir das nicht genutzt? Das ist die Frage.
Ja, das muss beantwortet werden. Ja, noch einmal Soros, sein Ausblick, worum es ihm geht.
Er fragt sich, ein 91-Jähriger, was kümmert er sich um die Zukunft? Vielleicht hat er wirklich Angst, das selber noch zu erleben. dieses Jahr sind ja, die UN hat es ja gerade vermeldet, die Zahl der Flüchtlinge über 100 Millionen gesprungen und Ursula von der Leyen warnt davor, wenn die 20 Millionen Tonnen Getreide, die in der Ukraine festhängt, zerstört werden oder nicht ordentlich geliefert werden oder in einem Zustand sind, in dem man es nicht mehr gebrauchen kann, dann nützt uns der Wohlstand, den wir haben, gar nichts. Dann können wir für dieses Geld genau nichts an Problemlösung kaufen. Ich sehe hier gerade, Deutschlandfunk twittert jetzt gerade, die Zahl der Arbeitslosen in Deutschland ist im Mai weiter gesunken. Ja, das kann man natürlich im Tweet so melden, aber Klammer auf, wenn eine Million Menschen in Rente gehen und unter 700.000 nachwachsen, ist das der natürliche Taulauf der Dinge und er sollte uns echt besorgen. Und dass wir hier so multiple Probleme haben und das Sauros sagt eben, wir müssen den Krieg nicht, also der Krieg, was für ein kleines Problem, können wir das nicht einfach mal, wir haben doch hier noch ein großes, dass wir hier ein Problem nicht lösen können, ein drängendes, weil wir ein überbordendes Problem haben, das ist auch in der Alten Republik Thema. Der 123. Ärztetag 2020 war zum Thema Hitze, weil die Hausärzte nämlich gesagt haben, seit Jahrzehnten kommen hier Leute zu mir und sagen, sie sind einfach wahnsinnig erschöpft, sie können nicht arbeiten. Und ich weiß dann nicht, was schreibe ich denn auf die Krankschreibung? Und dann haben irgendwelche Hausärzte angefangen, Hitzeerschöpfung drauf zu schreiben. Hitzeerschöpfung gibt es aber in keinem Diagnose-Katalog. Also die schreiben halt einfach Hitzeerschöpfung drauf. Ich schreib sie jetzt krank wegen Hitzeerschöpfung. Das gibt es aber gar nicht. Also kann man auch bei der Krankenkasse nicht so richtig geltend machen. Dann haben sich die Ärzte gedacht, ja, dann müssen wir das jetzt mal zum Thema machen. 123. Erzeltag, Mai 2020, kümmert sich um Hitze. Was passiert? Es ist Corona, der erste Tag fällt aus. Und so sammeln sich so langsam die Probleme auf. Und nur weil wir sie nicht behandeln, glauben wir, so richtig da sind sie ja nicht und so. Und jetzt kommt aber alles auf einmal. Wir haben Corona gerade überstanden. Jetzt kommen diese komischen Affenpocken. Jetzt haben wir ein Ärztemangel zum Beispiel, ein grundsätzliches Nachwuchsproblem. Wir haben ein investitions- und Innovationsstau beim Thema Klima. Und reden aber die ganze Zeit über den Krieg. Und das Puzzle passt so nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Also es ist wirklich dramatisch. Und umso dramatischer ist, wenn wir dann feststellen, dass es Antipolitik gibt. diesen Begriff kennen wir ja schon aus z. The End of the End of History, wo ja die Antipolitik als der Feind dargestellt wird. Also es gibt Postpolitik, Mason, Postdemokratie und so weiter. diese Argumentationen kennen wir ja alle. Das Verschwinden der Politik ist auch so ein Buchtitel. Aber wir haben es eben auch mit handfester Antipolitik zu tun. Uns ist das auch schon mal begegnet inhaltlich, als wir über die Republikaner im Senat sprachen, die die Anhörung von Big Tech gestört haben. Während David Cicillin als Redelsführer der Demokraten, die jetzt echt mal eine ordentliche Aufarbeitung der ganzen Misslagen machen wollen, diese Anhörung hatten mit den großen Chefs da aus dem Silicon Valley, kamen die Republikaner immer mit. Ja, also sehen sie jetzt meine Free Speech hier oder was? Erreiche ich meine Wähler gar nicht mehr und so? Und da haben sie es halt einfach boykottiert. Also die wollten einfach, dass da keine Politik stattfindet. So und das haben wir jetzt natürlich auf zwei Ebenen in Amerika in ganz bedrohlicher Weise. Und ich will das mal hier verkoppeln mit diesem Krieg und den moralischen Argumenten, denn wir fragen uns ja gerade, ist Putin eigentlich so schlimm wie Hitler? Ist jetzt von mir sehr plakativ gefragt, aber diese Frage steht ja irgendwie im Raum.
Ja, das wird ja immer wieder so gemacht, wo ich auch sagen würde, also wir hatten jetzt auch eine jahrzehntelange Debatte darüber, dass man nicht diese Nazi-Vergleiche inflationär werden lässt. Wir haben auch eine Einzigartigkeit der Verbrechen gegen die Juden. Und deswegen bin ich doch überrascht, dass dann auch von liberaler, linksliberaler Seite ständig solche Vergleiche bemüht werden, wo ich sagen würde, wir müssen da mal sehr vorsichtig sein, dass wir nicht anfangen, unsere eigene geschichte zu relativieren, um am Ende ganz gut dann noch dazustehen, dass wir auch nur eine von vielen gewesen sind, die unrecht getan haben. So geht es nun mal nicht.
Genau, die Singularität des Holocaust sollte man ohnehin nicht so leicht infrage stellen. Also der Hitler-Vergleich verbietet sich. Aber du hast uns ja eben schon George W. Bush vorgestellt. Und dann ist auch die Frage, ist Putin vielleicht so schlimm wie George W. Bush? So und jetzt hab ich mich aber erinnert, damals im Sozialkunderunterricht hat uns unser Lehrer gefragt, und jetzt klammern wir den Holocaust mal aus und nehmen nur den Nationalsozialismus mal kurz begrifflich in den Blick. Was unterscheidet den Nationalsozialismus zum Beispiel von der Politik der bundesrepublik? Und dann war eine der Antworten und zwei sind wichtig. Die erste war, Nationalsozialismus, also nationalsozialistische Politik ist sozialistische Politik, aber nicht für alle. Sie unterscheidet klar zwischen, das sind die Mütter, die von uns die Kreuze serviert bekommen und das sind die Mütter, deren Kinder wir töten. Es gibt also nicht diesen universalistischen Anspruch. Und das zweite ist, dass so nationalsozialistische Politik bis unter die Bettdecke regiert. Und nicht einfach so, wir kümmern uns noch um, dass die Straße ordentlich funktioniert und der Nahverkehr, aber der rest ist uns egal. Nein, bis unter die Bettdecke wird rein regiert. Und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was hier in Amerika passiert. Denn wir haben eine Abtreibungsdebatte, dadurch, dass der Supreme Court, und das ist auch wieder so eine geschichte, wo man sich fragt, wie kann es denn zu so einem Leak kommen? Wollten sie von Seiten des Gerichts, dass ihr Urteil schon vorher mal andiskutiert wird, um so die Betriebstemperatur langsam zu erhöhen, um dann das Urteil auch tatsächlich in die Bücher zu schreiben? Also es ist ja ganz verrückt, wie dieses Ray vs. Wade Argument von vor 50 Jahren, das nämlich Abtreibung in die Privatsphäre einklammert, wo man nicht reinregiert als Politik, ermöglicht. Und das soll jetzt aufgehoben werden. Und relativ viele bundesstaaten in Amerika stehen jetzt schon bereit. Hier im 538 Podcast sind sie die Liste mal so ein bisschen durchgegangen und sagen, also wenn die Richter das Urteil, das bisher, weil die Politik nicht handelt, und sie haben es jetzt wieder versucht, ein bundeseinheitliches gesetz zu machen, die Welt kam nicht zustande, weil Joe Manchin wieder mal boykottiert hat. Wie so vieles schon boykottiert wurde jetzt aus der aktuellen Präsidentenagenda. Dann stehen relativ viele bundesstaaten bereit und sagen, dann gelten ab dem Moment unsere kleinregionalen gesetze.
Und dann noch eine Kategorie. Das ist sehr kompliziert, aber das ist nur ein Vorblick auf das, was wir in einigen Monaten machen werden, wenn das passiert. Wo die Städtekonstitutionen Abortionen verhindern. Kansas ist ein wirklich interessantes Beispiel dafür. Das ist ein Staat, in dem Verbrecher sehr anti-Abortionen sind. Sie wollen wirklich viele abortionen-bestimmungen in den Platz setzen. Aber der Städtekommission hat gesagt, dass Abortionen unter der Städtekonstitutionen verhindert werden. Es wird in ein paar Monaten ein Vot geben, das eine Städtekommission verhindern würde, das in der Kansas-Konstitutionen verändern würde. Aber ich denke, der Zentrum für Reproduktivrechte schätzt, dass es etwa zehn oder elf Staaten sind, in denen Abortionen zu irgendeinem extent unter der Städtekonstitutionen verhindert werden. Ein anderes Staat, das in diese Kategorie fallen wird, ist Florida. Man kann sehen, dass es einige Staaten gibt, in denen das Ergebnis ziemlich schnell und klar ist. Und dann gibt es eine mittlere Kategorie.
Mit dem Namen Scott Galloway. Blickt hier mal im Pivot Podcast in die laufende Debatte in Amerika rein und betont da mal, in welche Richtung es geht.
Und es gibt all kinds of things um Abortionen und Mörder in einigen Staaten zu machen. Nicht erlauben, mein Bruder, Dr. Jeffrey Swisher, ging nicht nur um ektopische Verbrechen. Inzwischen sehen Telemedizin-Provider und Gruppen.
Und Televisa, dass eine Verbrechenung nicht auf dem Tisch ist. Also, nicht zu glauben, dass das nicht weiter zu einem Kaskaden oder Wasserfall zurück zu, wiederum, die Rechte der Menschen, die von der Farbe und von der Frau und von der Frau, von der Menschen, die nicht viel finanzielle Flexibilität haben, das könnte nicht sein.
Als das Weltmeister realisiert, dass es ein progressive Nation ist, um sich in die Prosperität zu investieren, um die Rechte der Menschen nicht wegzunehmen, gehen wir in den anderen Weg.
Du wachst jetzt einfach auf und fragst dich, ist das meine Amerika?
Ja, ich weiß, du hast gesagt, dass du das gesagt hast.
Also wenn die Eskalation sogar in die Verhütung hinein möchte, dann ist das einfach zu viel Politik?
So frage ich mich doch, wer wird denn damit erreicht? Also wir haben natürlich bei Republikanern immer solche Tiraden gegen die Gender studies. Nun wird das bei der Wählerschaft immer akklamiert werden, weil von denen natürlich niemand Gender studies studiert und die sagen, das ist alles komisch und gut, dass die das mal verbieten wollen. Aber hier, wo es um Abtreibung geht und dann sogar um Verhütung, ist ja nun jeder mehr oder weniger betroffen, beziehungsweise muss ich ja da auf eine Seite schlagen plötzlich und könnte ja auch vorher eine Haltung haben, die rein privatistisch ist, zu sagen, für mich würde jetzt eine Abtreibung nicht in Frage kommen, aber generell bin ich für das gesetz so wie es ist oder dergleichen. Und jetzt plötzlich aber gibt es diese starke Politisierung und die damit dann herangehende Positionierung. So frage ich mich, welcher Wähler ist damit zu erreichen, beziehungsweise gibt es dafür wirklich eine republikanische Mehrheit für solche radikalen gesetze? Und was sagt das dann über Amerika aus?
Ja, es ist ganz verrückt, aber analog gibt es das auch in Deutschland so ein bisschen. Ich wohne hier in der Gegend mit relativ vielen hausbesitzern, die in ihren Gärten sitzen und natürlich so miteinander darüber reden, dass sie sagen, klar, kann ich für mein Haus, wenn ich das verkaufe, 800.000 Euro verlangen? Ich habe ja da auch voll viel reingesteckt, weil sie mal zum Baumarkt gefahren sind und die Küche irgendwie selbst gefliest haben oder so. Und das Gegenargument ist natürlich immer, naja, also dein Haus ist so viel wert, weil Frankfurt einfach eine supergeile Stadt ist. Warum ist Frankfurt eine supergeile Stadt? Weil hier sehr viele junge Menschen herziehen, die dann sozusagen ihr eigenes Zutun, nämlich sie haben die Stadt einfach zu einer coolen Stadt gemacht, selber noch bezahlen müssen, weil die alteingesessenen, die damals hier wohnten, als Frankfurt noch keine coole Stadt war, einfach mal die Entscheidung getroffen haben, Eigentum zu erwerben und dann ist es einfach zehnmal so viel wert. Und diese Menschen sind auch dann nicht davon abzubringen, für ihr eigenes kleines Haus eine halbe Million zu wollen, obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht so viel wert ist, wenn man ihnen sagt, naja, aber guck mal, du hast jetzt eine 15-jährige Tochter, die kommt in drei Jahren zu dir und sagt, Papa, ich brauch mal eine Bürgschaft für eine Mietung, denn ich will in Stuttgart studieren und ich brauche aber 1200 Euro im Monat. Und dann sagen die, ja, das ist dann schon blöd. Aber deswegen verzichte ich doch noch nicht auf meine 500.000 Euro hier. Also es hängt halt einfach alles so miteinander zusammen, dass man von seinem eigenen kleinen besitzstand materiell oder ideell nicht abrücken möchte.
Und du meinst, das geht auch auf so ein Thema wie Abtreibung oder Fötung, dass sie sagen, naja, ich hab ja Kinder und damit ist ja für mich alles so gelaufen, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Und deswegen sollen jetzt aber auch alle, den Lebensentwurf von mir teilen. Und da werde ich auch zur Not die entsprechende Partei wählen, die das so durchsetzt.
Das ist eine ideelle besitzstandswahrung, die ihnen von den Politikern, die sie mögen und unterstützen, da die ganze Zeit reingedrückt wird. Und das ist in Amerika eben besonders paradox, weil wir auf der einen Seite gerade diese harte Schutz des ungeborenen Lebensdiskussion haben. Und auf der anderen Seite genau das Gegenteil bei dem Schutz des geborenen Lebens. Wir hatten jetzt wieder den Fall, dass in einer amerikanischen Grundschule einfach jemand reinrennt mit einer Maschinenpistole, Gewehr und da einfach aufminitioniert einen ganzen Klassenverband einfach tot schießt. So, 19 Tote. Und jetzt wird das natürlich in Amerika diskutiert. Und so hart die Republikaner bis unter die Bettdecke von 16-Jährigen, die über die Nutzung eines Kondoms rein regieren wollen, so sehr halten sie sich eben zurück, wenn es darum geht, die Waffenfreiheit zu verteidigen. Und es ist wirklich bezeichnend wie David Axelrod und Mike Murphy. Also der eine Obamas Wahlkampf Chef und der andere Pendant dazu auf republikanischer Seite auch seit Jahrzehnten in diesem business. Also die wissen, wie man eine politische Kampagne so organisiert, dass jemand wie Obama der erste schwarze Präsident wird und so. Wie die darüber reden, was jetzt eigentlich zu tun ist. Sie erwarten von der Politik nichts mehr.
Und ich sah ein Bild dieses Morgen auf TV von einem zehnjährigen, vor dem er getötet wurde, holte sein Ehrensport mit einem großen Lächeln auf seinem gesicht. Und es ist einfach, es verbreitet dein Herz. Aber Gibbs und Murphy, du weißt, die Antwort zu dem, was Senator Murphy gefragt hat, die hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass sie nichts tun werden.
Na gut, ich bin zu müde mit Worten.
Er ist der Worte müde, der Morde und der Worte, aber es wird wahrscheinlich keine Politik darauf reagieren können. Und dann haben sie die einzige Idee, die ihnen noch kommt, ist dann diese. Ja, also da reagieren sie auf Chris Murphy, der stand im Senat als Demokraten und fragte, what are we doing? Warum sind wir hier? Das war dann auch... Ich habe auch so eine Frage. Sollte der amerikanische Senat eine Schweigeminute machen? Und dann hat mal einer der Antworten, ne, Schweigeminuten kann man überall machen, aber nicht im amerikanischen Senat. Denn dann muss man in dem Moment, wenn so eine Tragödie passiert, auf das ganze Schweigen der anderen, die nämlich also Schweigen mit Handlungsunvermögen darstellen, sagen, ne, ihr könnt ja entscheiden. Ihr als Politiker könnt ja entscheiden. Und ihr solltet jetzt nicht schweigen, sondern ihr müsst jetzt diese Entscheidung treffen. Aber es ist wirklich crazy. Also welchen Rat können die super ausgebildeten, super erfahrenen Politikstrategen Joe Biden jetzt noch geben?
Das ist so, wie die Biden-Staff ihn in der politischen Position in die Flanke haben.
Hier ist, wie du diesen Voten verlierst.
Du lässt Schumer nicht nur den National Turn-Up-Day als presseverlust-voten ausbreiten.
Du hast eine sechs-Weilige Zeitung, du machst ein paar Sitzungen.
Der Präsident der USA sagt, wir werden in fünf Wochen einen Voten haben, oder wann immer der Zeitpunkt ist.
Und ich frage 1 Million Eltern.
Joe Biden ist die letzte Person, die das tun kann.
Ja, also Sie sehen schon, Joe Biden wird wahrscheinlich der Letzte sein, der es überhaupt noch regeln kann. Und er wird es aber alleine nicht schaffen. Die Demokraten müssen jetzt ein gesetz schreiben, sagen, in fünf Wochen stimmen wir ab. Und dann müssen eine Million Eltern mobilisiert werden, die vor dem Senat einfach stehen und sagen, ihr unterschreibt jetzt dieses gesetz. Hier werden keine weiteren Kinder erschossen. Das ist das Einzige, was denen noch einfällt dazu. Innerhalb der politischen Institution erwarten sie da nichts mehr. Es muss jetzt von außen da rein gepresst werden.
Und das wird nicht passieren. Es gab zwar ein paar proteste natürlich, aber das war ja dann vergleichsweise wenig zu dem, was man sonst schon erlebt hat. Und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, als wäre das jetzt anders. Ich habe eher noch den Eindruck, dass sich das Ganze, was die Antipolitik anbelangt, verschärft, also sonst haben ja dann Republikaner sich noch zögerlicher ausgedrückt. Also sie haben dann so ihr Zaudern und ihr Hadern signalisiert und auch ihre Traurigkeit inszeniert, die bei den Opfern ist und so weiter. Aber jetzt sieht man ja, dass die Republikaner schon am Tag eins auf Angriff gefahren sind und gesagt haben, ja, was brauchen wir auch? Gender studies, wir brauchen mal bewaffnete Leute vor den Schulen oder solche Argumentation. Gab es ja dann von US-Senatoren, von Republikanern. Und ich glaube, dass da überhaupt nicht die Stimmung für da ist, dass sich das ändert. Und ich weiß auch tatsächlich nicht, ob es dann eine Mehrheitsstimmung dafür wirklich gibt, dass man diese schärferen waffengesetze hat. Also das ist ja doch etwas mental so unterschiedliches zu Deutschland oder zu anderen europäischen Ländern, dass man einen so großen Wert auf diese Idee der Selbstverteidigung legt, was in der Tradition selbstverständlich begründet ist. Das ist die geschichte Amerikas auch. Aber ich glaube, da kann man sich eigentlich jede Illusion abschminken.
Genau, diese eine Million Menschen werden sich so nicht organisieren. Und sie gehen an dem Podcast nochmal kurz durch, was droht. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch das Szenario.
The world will move on. We will be outraged about something else in five days, unless there's some level of continued outrage on this.
Ja, wird's nicht geben. Also schon in fünf Tagen ist wieder irgendwas mit Putin oder so. Und dann ist dieses Thema auch wieder vorbei. Ich sehe gerade, ich habe hier noch 14 Sekunden von Chris Murphy. Also er steht im Plenarsaal der Senatoren, der Demokraten.
Tage nachdem ein Schütze in einen Supermarkt ging, um afro-amerikanische Kunden niederzuschießen, haben wir ein neues Sandy Hook.
Was machen wir?
Ja, was machen wir? Gar nichts machen sie. Also dieser Spruch konnte noch mal so aufgegriffen werden. Geht jetzt in die geschichtsbücher ein, aber es ist einfach in Amerika, da ist jetzt faschistische Antipolitik. Ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie wenig wir das... Und es ist auch grad nicht Trump, sondern das droht ja erst wieder, dass jetzt wieder ein republikanischer, es kann ja auch desentes sein oder so, republikanischer Präsident kommt und dann...
Und das sollten wir uns als Europäer auch vergegenwärtigen. Momentan haben wir ganz kurz diese sehr starke Allianz und wir haben diese starke Nähe zu Biden und America is back, sagte Ursula von der Leyen. Nur die Frage ist, wie lange? Und wenn wir uns jetzt ansehen, dass wir solche verrückten Abtreibungen, zum Teil verhütungsgesetze bei den USA haben, also wo Freiheiten beschnitten werden, wo es zugleich bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände gibt, wenn man auf die Waffen blickt, das sind ja ungeheure Zahlen von todesopfern durch diese Waffen, die da einfach im Umlauf sind, dann muss natürlich auch sich Europa die Frage stellen, inwieweit ist Amerika für uns für die nächsten 10, 15 Jahre, und darum muss es ja immer gehen, ein verlässlicher Partner? Reicht das so aus? Wird es auch so bleiben? Kann es auch sein, dass das jetzt nochmal so eine Angstblüte ist der NATO, also so ein kurzes Aufblühen, man nimmt nochmal ein paar auf, und dann hat man vielleicht einen republikanischen Präsidenten, der das anders sieht und sagt, wir machen ein eigenes Bündnis mit weiß ich nicht wem, Wir brauchen eigentlich die NATO nicht mehr in dieser Weise. Dann muss Europa alleine dastehen. Das ist eine ganz heikle Konfliktsituation, die jetzt auch daran können wir uns gewöhnen, dauerhaft bleiben wird. Also man kann fast so weit gehen wie der Klimawandel ist ein Dauerthema und der Konflikt beziehungsweise auch der Krieg ist jetzt ein Dauerthema für Jahre. Also es kann sein, dass es dazu Waffenstillstand kommt, vielleicht auch schon in ein, zwei Monaten zwischen Russland und der Ukraine. Aber dieser Krieg, das wird in gewisser Weise jetzt strukturbildend sein für das gesamte Jahrzehnt und darüber hinaus. Und da werden sich vielleicht auch noch Allianzen ergeben, die Europa da eingeht, mit denen wir jetzt noch gar nicht rechnen. Denn ob Amerika zuverlässiger Partner bleibt, das steht sehr an den Sternen. Und wenn da auch keine Bevölkerungsmehrheit mehr hinter dem Ganzen steht und auch sagt, was brauchen wir Europa, genauso wie die jetzt sagen, Abtreibung, nee, wollen wir gar nicht, dann ist das die Frage, wo wir dann eigentlich stehen. Und dann ist auch ganz klar, dass Europa das alleine nicht leisten kann. Also vielleicht ist auch gerade dieses Engagement, das Europa zeigt, das im Übrigen ja auch Deutschland zeigt, es geht jetzt nicht um die Frage, wie oft kann Scholz irgendwo hinreisen, sondern es gibt ja dieses Engagement. Vielleicht ist das auch schon in der Hinterhand die Vorbereitung darauf, dass Europa versucht, auf eigenen Füßen zu stehen, wenn Amerika mal ausfallen sollte, dass man dann jetzt noch ein paar NATO-Partner mehr hat, dass man dann größer als Europa dasteht. Das könnte auch eine Überlegung sein.
Genau, diese Gewichtsverlagerung ist ja nicht schlecht. Und dass Olaf Scholz jetzt gerade in Afrika ist oder war, fand ich auch nicht schlecht, denn das ist nun mal auch durch den demografischen Druck das wichtigste Projekt für alle europäischen Staaten. Es gab ja diesen einen Vorschlag, ich weiß nicht mehr von wem, Miller, glaube ich, der dieses Buch über dieses afrikanische Jahrhundert und die möglichen Migrationsbewegungen geschrieben hat, der meinte, es sollte sich im Grunde jetzt jedes europäische Land ein Partnerland in Afrika aussuchen und das durchpämpern auf allen Ebenen. Viele besuche, kulturelle Verschränkungen, Wirtschaftshilfe und so weiter. Ja, aber eben nicht so dieses Flächendeckende, sondern so richtig, so jeder nimmt ein und dann ist es aber Anti-Kolonialismus, sondern eine echte Partnerschaft.
Wir müssen über Hunger sprechen. Ich wollte das im letzten Monat schon tun. Das Thema ist natürlich aktuell nach wie vor aktueller geworden und ich hab auch tatsächlich jetzt Clips dabei. Aus den vergangenen Monaten, also das gesamte Jahr ist schon geprägt von Hunger und schon davor. Und es ist ganz erschreckend, wenn man diese einzelnen Berichte sich anhört, da gibt es unglaublich viel gutes wiederum im Deutschlandfunk, in den öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern zu hören. Wir hören jetzt mal hier einen Beitrag, der ist noch vom Januar über Guatemala.
Die Pandemie wird eines tages vorbei sein. In Tekpan hat es viele Covid-Tote gegeben. Aber die Auswirkungen des wirtschaftlichen Einbruchs werden noch lange andauern. Viele Familien haben ihre Arbeit verloren. Das wird die Entwicklung der Kinder über Jahre beeinflussen.
Sie werden Erwachsene mit kleinen Körpern sein, die unter chronischer Unterernährung leiden.
Es ist unglaublich, allein das schon jetzt zu hören, dass also da jetzt schon klar ist, die Folgen werden jetzt über Jahre, Jahrzehnte sichtbar sein, weil einfach dort kleine Erwachsene irgendwann sein werden, mit zu kleinen Körpern, weil sie unterernährt sind. Guatemala. Dann blicken wir jetzt nach Nordkentia, auch einen Beitrag aus dem Januar.
Vor Entereyan Lenkhegens Hütte spielen drei ihrer Kinder. An deren Zukunft kann die Hirtin noch gar nicht denken. Ihr machen schon die nächsten Monate große Sorgen. Meine Kinder bekommen nicht genug zu essen. Gerade der Kleinste bräuchte Milch. Die bekam er früher immer von ihren Tieren. Doch die verbleibenden Zwölf werden noch lange unterwegs sein, auf der Suche nach Gras. Die Dürre am Horn von Afrika soll bis Mitte nächsten jahres andauern.
Wir sprechen hier von Krisen, die schon vor, ich betone vor dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine da waren. Denn was man jetzt so erleben kann, ist im politischen Diskurs von Stack Zimmermann bis Cem Özdemir, ja die Russen, die nehmen uns jetzt noch den Weizen ab. Da stimmt zwar alles, aber das Problem Hunger war vorher schon ganz, ganz groß da. Es wurde nur nicht groß thematisiert. Also man findet natürlich dazu Beiträge. Man kann danach suchen im Internet. Aber das war nicht die große Debatte. Da haben wir nicht gesagt, unsere Werte sehen auch so aus, dass wir andere Menschen nicht verhungern lassen, sondern wir wussten von diesen Krisen. Das war jetzt ein Beitrag. Kenia, Januar und jetzt hören wir einfach fünf Monate später wieder ein Beitrag. SWR, Bettina Rühl über Kenia.
Eine Helferin legt dem kleinen Lopeto Ebeno das Maßband um den Oberarm. Es zeigt rot. Der Zweijährige ist schwer untererniert. Seine Mutter ist besorgt, aber nicht überrascht. Das liegt an der Dürre. Alle unsere Ziegen sind tot. Wir haben keine Milch und nichts zu essen. Ihren sieben anderen Kindern gehe es nicht besser, sagt die Mutter. Aber die seien älter als fünf Jahre. deshalb hat sie die anderen gar nicht erst mitgebracht. Das Ernährungsprogramm richtet sich nur an Kinder unter fünf Jahren.
Wir gehen jetzt mal kommentarlos weiter nach Somalia.
Ein Trauerzug hat sich aufgemacht im Flüchtlingscamp. In der Mitte ein Mann, der einen zusammengerollten Teppich in blau und orange trägt. Von den Seiten lässt sich erkennen, dass darin ein kleiner Mensch liegt. Die Gruppe stoppt an einem frisch in der trockenen Erde ausgehobenen Loch. Hier wird Ubach beerdigt. Sie wurde vier Jahre alt. Ich habe schon zwei Kinder verloren, ein Jung und ein Mädchen, sagt ihre Mutter Juhara Ali der Deutschen Welle. Sie sind an der gleichen Krankheit gestorben. Wir haben keine Medizin für sie bekommen. Die Kinder hatten eine angeborene Krankheit. Aber sie hatten vor allem nichts zu essen. Mehr als 4.000 Familien sind in den vergangenen Monaten in einem Lager untergekommen. Sie alle flohen vor der verheerenden Dürre in Somalia. Seit zwei Jahren hat es hier nicht mehr richtig geregnet.
So humanitär und sanitär ist das Zustand Europa 1850 ungefähr.
Ja, wir haben jetzt schon gehört, es hat da nicht geregnet, seit zwei Jahren nicht. Das heißt, das Problem ist schon lange da. Das ist auch der westlichen Politik bekannt. Aber wir machen da nichts. Und das ist auch nicht jetzt eine Frage von einem aktuellen Krieg, sondern wir haben da die ganze Zeit weg gesehen und machen da nichts. Da gibt es mal ein paar kleine Hilfen. Aber wir sehen ja, wie beschränkt dann diese Hilfen sind. Wir hören nochmal einen Beitrag aus Somalia.
Außerdem gebe es weniger Hilfsbereitschaft für Somalia, weil alles sich auf die Unterstützung der Ukraine konzentriere. Wir sind nicht auf dem Radar. Das ist unfair. Wir haben tiefes Mitgefühl mit den Leuten in der Ukraine. Die haben das nicht verdient. Aber die Menschen hier haben das auch nicht verdient. Viele Hilfsorganisationen schätzen die Lage inzwischen als bedrohlicher ein, als im Jahr 2011. Damals starben in Somalia etwa eine Viertelmillion Menschen an Hunger, weil die internationale Gemeinschaft viel zu spät reagierte. Aus Nairobi Antje Diekans.
Was war denn 2011, wieso hat sie das jetzt so hervorwogen?
2011 war schon mal eine große Krise. Also man kann ja eigentlich feststellen, dass sich auch das immer mehr verschlechtert hat. Also es ist ja keineswegs so, dass man einen Punkt hat, wo es besser wird. Das ist ja oft wird es so gesagt, dass er auch so was was Steven Pinker immer deutlich macht. Uns geht es allen immer besser. Das stimmt aber nicht, wenn man auf den Hunger blickt. Also es gibt immer mehr Hunger wieder in der Welt, obwohl wir erst weniger Hunger hatten. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, das immer zu definieren, aber man kann sagen, dass 800 Millionen Menschen auf der Welt an Hunger leiden bzw. von Hunger bedroht sind. Also das kann von tatsächlich kurz vorm Verhunger stehen, dann heißt es bis zu nicht wissen, ob man morgen noch genügend zu essen hat. Jedenfalls ist diese Bedrohung, Hunger zu erleiden, für 800 Millionen Menschen akut. David Beasley, der beim World Food Program ist, der äußert sich hier mal zu Afghanistan.
Das ist natürlich arabischer Frühling, ausgelöst auch durch Missernten und so weiter.
Stimmt. Wir hören jetzt in den süddeutschen Podcast rein. Da ist Martin Frick vom World Food Program in Berlin zu Gast. Und der macht noch mal deutlich, das Problem Hunger war schon lange da.
Herr Frick, wie viele Menschen auf der ganzen Welt leiden denn gerade unter Hunger?
Wenn ich das jetzt beantworte aus der Perspektive, des World Food Program, also wie viele sind jetzt ganz akut auf Hilfe angewiesen, dann waren das vor zwei Jahren 126 Millionen. Im Januar waren wir bereits bei 276 Millionen. Und jetzt ist der Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine dazugekommen. Wir können das schlecht schätzen, aber es kann sein, dass wir jetzt über 330 Millionen Menschen haben, die nun ganz akut von Hunger bedroht sind.
Also da ist noch mal ein großes Päckchen dazugekommen. Und er bringt dann auch mal eine kleine Analyse, was zum Beispiel passiert, wenn russischer Dünger fehlt.
Russland ist weltweit der größte Exporteur von Kunstdünger. Und wenn das weiter eingeschränkt wird, können wir Einbrüche in der Produktion in diesem Jahr sehen. Wir sehen zum Beispiel auch, dass in der Ukraine, wo gerade jetzt zum Beispiel Sonnenblumen ausgesät werden müssten, für das Sonnenblumenöl, das nicht stattfindet. Denn viele, die in der Landwirtschaft normalerweise arbeiten würden, kämpfen, verteidigen ihr Land. Und dazu kommt noch Infrastrukturschäden, die langfristige Folgen haben werden. Wenn die Schwarzmeerhäfen tatsächlich zerstört oder stark beeinträchtigt sind, wird das ja auch nicht über Nacht wieder repariert werden. Und Exporte nur per Zug sind natürlich ein Bruchteil dessen, was sie mit Schiffen exportieren können.
Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich, wenn man sich das überlegt. All diese Kalkulationen fallen natürlich mit in das Überlegen, wie die russische Regierung gerade handelt. Also da einfach in der Südukraine die helfen zu blockieren, dann die Ausfuhr zu boykottieren und dann aber auch umzulenken. Es gibt ja diese Videos, zumindest war im Nachrichten so welche zu sehen, wieder kilometerlang einfach die LKWs dastehen. Die einen werden über den Landweg in Richtung EU geleitet, stehen aber da erst mal 19 Tage im Stau wegen Bürokratie usw. Und die anderen werden einfach auf Befehl der russischen Regierung auf die Krim gebracht, um sozusagen auf sicherem Gebiet den Weizen da zu stehlen. Und dann auch mit der klaren Kommunikation, die einfach sagt, das ist eine erpressung, die da abläuft. Wenn die westlichen Sanktionen bleiben, bleibt das Getreide auf der Krim. Und das mit diesem ganzen Blick auf Afrika kombiniert mit dieser Propaganda, von der wir hier gar nichts hören in Europa. Das finde ich ganz gefährlich irgendwie dafür, dass hier echt so ein Countdown läuft für diese Zeit, wo dieses Getreide dann eigentlich verwendet werden sollte.
Und wir haben die afrikanischen Länder ja schon einmal enttäuscht mit Blick auf die Impfstoffe. Die Impfstoffe haben wir nicht liefern wollen, hätten das können, machen dann so lange Deals. Und dann werden die das irgendwann auch bekommen. Und die werden jetzt ein zweites Mal enttäuscht. Und dann ist die Frage, wer dann noch so auf unserer Seite stehen wird und wie viel Verständnis da ist. Und wenn jemand Hunger hat, hat er Hunger. Da ist auch nicht mehr zu sagen, so gaukmäßig, ja man kann auch mal ein bisschen frieren für die Freiheit. Nee, man kann nicht mal ein bisschen hungern für die Freiheit. Das ist nicht verkaufbar und schon gar nicht in diesen Ländern. Arte greift diesen Konflikt, diesen Krieg auf.
In der Ukraine hat der Krieg Lieferwege zerstört. Es fehlt Treibstoff. All das macht den Export kompliziert. In Russland ist die Lage anders. Das Land exportiert weniger als sonst und verfolgt dabei ein klares Ziel.
Gerade jetzt, wo die Preise international nach oben gehen, dass die Preise in Russland selbst für Lebensmittel nicht allzu sehr steigen. Weil das würde die Bevölkerung aufbringen und das kann Putin im Moment überhaupt gar nicht gebrauchen. Und insofern gibt es durchaus auch ein interesse, Getreide nicht zu exportieren, um die Preise im eigenen Land niedrig zu halten.
Hier muss man aber ganz wichtig sagen, wir reden hier nicht von einer von uns gewohnten Auswahl in einem Supermarkt oder so und das niedrige Preisniveau, sondern hier geht es nur darum, geht man zum Bäcker und kriegt ein Brot, egal welches. Ja, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, wir hören nochmal einen Auszug aus dem Beitrag von Arte.
Tatsächlich ist die Ukraine-Krise nicht allein für die hohen Preise verantwortlich. Schon vor Kriegsausbruch war Getreide teuer.
Das lag daran, dass die Energiepreise insgesamt ja in den letzten Jahren hochgegangen sind, wieder sehr deutlich. Und die Energiepreise sind eng auch an die landwirtschaftlichen Preise gekoppelt. Sie brauchen natürlich Energie, um zu produzieren, auch um zu transportieren. Sie brauchen Energie, um Düngemittel herzustellen.
Steigende Energie- und Getreidepreise, gerade in Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländern, können das zu einer wachsenden Inflation führen, fürchten Beobachter.
Du hast es gerade schon gesagt, es geht jetzt nicht darum, geht man in den Supermarkt, greift man ins volle Regal, welches Produkt hätte man gern, sondern kann man sich überhaupt etwas leisten, das Brot ist. Und im süddeutschen Podcast geht es dann auch mal darum, wie viel eigentlich afrikanische Familien ausgeben müssten ihres Einkommens für Lebensmittel.
Du sagst immer der süddeutsche Podcast, natürlich der Podcast der süddeutschen Zeitung.
Ja.
Wir wollen ja hier ganz korrekt sein.
In anderen Ländern, vor allem afrikanischen Ländern, ist der Anteil dessen, was vom Familieneinkommen ausgegeben werden muss für Lebensmittel, oft bei 70, 80 und noch mehr Prozent. Das heißt, wenn dann die Preise weiter steigern, kann man gar nicht mehr irgendwo anders sparen, um es möglich zu machen, sondern da ist man einfach an der Grenze angekommen.
Ja, und auch an der Grenze des verständnisses für irgendetwas. Denn das ist eine Bedrohung, die so radikal ist. Dagegen ist die Pandemie ja nichts gewesen. Also das haben die ja dann auch noch hinnehmen können. Aber das ist so existenziell der Hunger, dass man sich schon ausmalen kann, welche Konflikte da entstehen. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Wir hören noch mal in den SZ Podcast hier an.
Weil wir durch Covid die Unterbrechung von Nachschublinien hatten. Wir hatten auf derselben Seite einen unglaublichen finanziellen Aufwand der Länder, mit Covid umzugehen. Wir schätzen, dass 26 Trillionen mit einem T-Dollar ausgegeben worden sind für Covid. Und die Folge davon ist ganz eindeutig, dass viele überschuldete Entwicklungsländer noch ärmer geworden sind, noch größere Schwierigkeiten haben, irgendwelche Kredite auf dem Weltmarkt zu bekommen. Gleichzeitig sind die Wechselkurse weggeschmolzen. Also sie haben zum Beispiel in Venezuela oder im Libanon oder in Südsudan dreistellige Inflationsraten. Und auf dieser ganzen Gemengelage kommen jetzt noch die explodierenden Preise auf dem Weltmarkt für Weizen, für Mais, für Speiseöl. All das zusammen schafft einen explosiven Mix.
Das heißt, wir brauchen einen Schuldenschnitt für die Entwicklungsländer, sonst kommen die da nicht raus.
Er meint aber Billionen oder Trillionen. Also 26 hat er jetzt genannt. Wir haben bei Adam Toos gelesen, dass allein die amerikanische Zentralbank 14 Billionen zur Verfügung gestellt hatte, geschöpft als Weltbank für die ganze Welt plötzlich. Wir fanden das schon viel, aber jetzt haben wir gehört, die Bedarf, die Dimension des Bedarfs war dann doch noch mal größer. Also insgesamt. Und man hat auch kein systemisches Problem gelöst. Das stellt sich eben wirklich ein. Also wenn dieses, wenn Getreide in Millionen Tonnen fehlt, kann man nicht einfach ausweichen. Dann gibt es keinen zweiten Lieferanten oder so. Das ist dann einfach nicht da.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt noch mal zu diesem Artebeitrag und können ja mal über kurzfristige Lösungen nachdenken.
Roggen, Weizen oder Mais werden heute Benzin und diesel beigemischt. So entstehen Kraftstoffe wie E10. In Deutschland etwa wird insgesamt 12 Prozent des produzierten getreides als Treibstoff verwendet.
Wie viel Getreide und auch wie viel Pflanzenöl in den Bereich Bio-Kraftstoffe fließt, das ist enorm, macht aber am Ende nur einen sehr geringen Teil der Kraftstoffe aus. Das ist etwas, was wir reduzieren könnten, kurzfristig reduzieren könnten, es nicht in den Tank zu stecken, sondern für menschliche Ernährung verfügbar machen.
deshalb können wir jetzt nicht sagen, Indien macht jetzt auch einen Exportstopp, die sollen mal mit uns weiter Handel treiben und die sollen auch bitte mal Getreide exportieren, während wir das verfeuern für unseren Treibstoff. Das ist ja unglaublich eigentlich.
Ja, er hat jetzt gesagt, kurzfristig ist immer so die Frage, inwieweit man die Felder, die ja dann doch auch auf so eine Benutzung für, also es ist ja nicht dasselbe Getreide, was wir verfeuern, wie wir das essen würden, wie auch das Tierfutter und so. Das erfordert dann doch immer schon ein bisschen Planung und auch Verfügbarkeit und ob mit kurzfristig dann schon die jetzt laufende und die Ernte des Sehens stattfindet, um dann die nächste Ernte, die Phase des Sehens, um die nächste Erntephase da schon so zu wirken. Naja, es ist super knifflig.
Ja, man hätte es sicherlich vorher machen müssen. Man müsste es aber jetzt tun, denn klar ist ja, das sind ja fast alles außerhalb der Krieg Effekte des Klimawandels. Das heißt, das wird sich alles verstärken. Und dann wird man immer wieder Nahrung brauchen. Und wenn man dann in dieser Weise damit umgeht, dass man sagte, wir machen da Biokraftstoffe draus, das kann ja nicht sinnvoll sein. Und das ist ja auch wiederum, wenn man das global bespricht, nicht mehr zu rechtfertigen. Also das ist dann auch mit unserem Wertekanon, oder wie immer man das nennen will, eigentlich nicht vereinbar ist. Aber wie ist es überhaupt mit den Exportbemühungen der EU? Denn natürlich war das mit dem Kurzfristigen auch deshalb gesagt, da es ja jetzt auch nicht so sein kann, dass wir als Europa plötzlich die ganze Welt ernähren. So kann es ja auch nicht gedacht sein.
Die EU geht bislang andere Wege. Anstatt das Getreide anders aufzuteilen, will sie vor allem mehr produzieren, um so die Nachfrage auf dem Weltmarkt zu erfüllen. deshalb sollen mehr Flächen für die Landwirtschaft freigegeben werden. Eigentlich sollen auf diesen ökologischen Vorrangflächen Habitate entstehen, etwa für Insekten, und kein intensiver Anbau betrieben werden. Hier nun noch mehr Getreide anzupflanzen, wäre für einige Beobachter ein Fehler. Nicht nur wegen des klimaschutzes.
Das langfristig falscheste ist tatsächlich noch mehr Exportfähigkeit der europäischen Landwirtschaft und damit negative Einflussnahmen auf die Länder, die jetzt so abhängig sind. Damit ist die nächste Krise eigentlich schon vorprogrammiert, letztendlich, wenn die Länder noch mehr Weizen einführen, auch wenn es vielleicht gut gemeint wäre.
Stimmt alles, ist leider ein Problem, stimmt alles.
Ja, das ist das Tragische. Man hört das alles und kann nur zustimmen und muss eigentlich mit fast einer fatalistischen Stimmung daraus gehen, weil sich so wenig da ändert. Auch Fragen, die noch mal immerhin neu gestellt werden müssen, ist ja auch, was würde eigentlich angebaut und wie sinnvoll ist das? Martin Frick war dann im tagesspiegel-podcast zu Gast jetzt vor einigen Tagen. Und da spricht er dann mal über die Getreidearten, die eigentlich angebaut werden.
Wir sollten auch darüber sprechen, wie sehr die Welt von nur drei Getreidearten abhängig ist, nämlich von Weizen, Mais und von Reis. Auch das ist eine gefährliche Situation. Was Sie ansprechen in Indien, das ist ja nicht so, dass Indien traditionellerweise ein Land gewesen wäre, das Weizen anbaut. Die weistliche Diät ist mode geworden. Und wenn Sie sich die Karte anschauen, wo es in Indien jetzt so unglaublich heiß geworden ist, dann ist das genau da auch, wo diese riesigen Weizenfelder sind. Das ist auch kein Wunder, weil da steht weit und breit kein Baum, der irgendwie Schatten spenden könnte. Eigentlich ist in Indien das Grundnahungsmittel Linsen. Und Linsen werden viel besser angepasst, weil sie viel weniger Wasser verbrauchen und gleichzeitig den Menschen auch Mineralstoffe und Vitamine geben, die sie aus dem Weizen nicht bekommen.
Uff, Linsen.
Ja, genau, das wollen wir dann nicht so, aber wir wollen denen diktieren, was für sie besser wäre. Da kommen wir natürlich wieder an so ein Problem.
Genau, hinzu kommt ja noch, dass die chinesische Mittelschicht jetzt alle Fleisch essen wollen. Ja. Und dafür auch wieder die Futtermittel gebraucht werden. Er hat jetzt gemeint, dass die Bäume da keinen Schatten spenden. Er meint aber wahrscheinlich auch wirklich große Klimaveränderungen, dadurch, dass da Bäume fehlen, die grundsätzlich dafür Wolken und Niederschläge und Kreislauf und so sorgen.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Noch mal so ein bisschen größer gedacht.
Er bringt aber noch ein Beispiel zum Getreideanbau.
Also wenn man sich anschaut, was die Menschen eigentlich traditionell im Sahel gegessen haben, der zwar trocken ist, aber ganz bestimmt keine Wüste, dann sind das eben Sorten wie Hirse zum Beispiel, die viel widerstandsfähiger sind gegen Trockenheiten. Mischung mit Bäumen, agroforestry, also das Mischen von Bäumen und Landwirtschaft ist ein ganz mächtiges Instrument, um resilienz aufzubauen und auch in ganz schwierigen klimatischen Umständen noch vernünftig Landwirtschaft betreiben zu können. Aber das ist eben kleinteilige, arbeitsintensive Landwirtschaft und lange Zeit hat man Entwicklungsländern eigentlich das Gegenteil gepredigt.
Wir springen ein bisschen zu gutteres, der war im Sicherheitsrat zu Gast und hat dort gesprochen über die Konflikte, die mit dem Hunger einhergehen, beziehungsweise wenn man über Konflikte spricht, dann spricht man eigentlich, sagt gutteres, immer über Hunger.
letztes Jahr lebten die meisten von den 140 Mio. Menschen, die mit dem Hunger einhergekommen sind, um die Welt zu leben, in nur 10 Ländern. Afghanistan, die Demokratische Republik der Kongo, Äthiopien, Haiti, Nigeria, Pakistan, Südsudan, Sudan, Syrien und Yemen.
Ja, da kommt mir und vielleicht schlage ich es ein bisschen über die Strenge, aber immer wieder dieses... Das ist dieses Hitler-Argument. Ich muss es leider sagen, in dem Sinn. Denn auch eine der Argumentationen, jetzt gerade für all die Probleme, ist ja immer, warum muss man so übertreiben? Hier geht es ja dann immer um die letzten 5 Prozent Profit, die man sich noch rauszieht aus einem System, das man ansonsten auch gut balancieren könnte. Und mit Hitler-Argument meine ich da, warum ist Hitler, nachdem er Frankreich erobert hat, auch noch nach Russland gegangen? Hätte er das nicht gemacht, wären diese ganzen Hollywood-Szenarien mit, über kurz oder lang, hätte er dann ganz Europa erobert und so, wäre ihm das wahrscheinlich besser gelungen. Und es scheint sich immer wieder so zu finden, dieses über die Stränge schlagen.
Da muss ich natürlich gleich widersprechen, da das ja ein systemischer Zwang ist, den wir hier beobachten. Der Kapitalismus muss wachsen, muss Profite maximieren. Und das tut er natürlich überall. Und das tut er auch da, wo es ans Existenzielle geht. Oder er kann es da besonders gut tun, weil die Nachfrage existenziell ist und man gar nicht mehr ein Gebrauchswertversprechen braucht. Man muss gar nicht dafür werben, esst doch mal Brot, sondern die Leute müssen ja Brot essen.
Aber im Critical Infinity Podcast, den du ja vorhin auch schon erwähnt hast, weil Breitenbach dort Dings gelesen hat, Habermas, hat er jetzt auch aktuell, das ist auch die Folge von heute, sehe ich gerade, 31. Mai, ich habe heute Morgen schon viel Podcast gehört, nochmal die Degrowth-Phase aufgepacht. Und da kam Patrick eben auch noch mal unterschieden zwischen... Klar, es ist das prägende Paradigma unserer Zeit. Kapitalismus, Kapital-Akkumulation, weil wir über diesen... Wir gehen mit einer investition rein, die uns eine Zinsverpflichtung eingegangen hat. Wir müssen also mit mehr rausgehen, als wir eingegangen sind. Irgendwo muss was verbraucht werden. Und jetzt haben wir uns aber auf die Natur gestürzt. Nur wir müssen ja nicht alles dem unterordnen. Wir können ja zum Beispiel beim Wohnen oder bei der Ernährung sagen, das machen wir jenseits der kapitalistischen Logik, beispielsweise mit einer genossenschaftlichen Logik, Vereinslogik, wo sich interessenorganisationen finden, die gar keine Gewinne machen dürfen, sondern nur dem Zwecke ihrer Organisation Mitglieder binden. Und da kann man ja durchaus ein paar Felder identifizieren, die wir bislang dem Kapitalismus überlassen haben, aber die wir auch politisch anders regeln können. Thema Antipolitik, wir haben es ja häufiger betont. Was macht Christian Lindner da gerade? Er sagt, die Schuldenbremse gilt. Und damit ist ja gemeint, die Politik hält sich da raus. Die Politik investiert da nicht, sondern der Privatsektor investiert und der will dann Rendite sehen. Nur in viele Sachen, in die Privatmenschen oder Unternehmen investieren, mit einem Renditeversprechen. Das kann man auch organisieren ohne Renditeerwartung. Dann gründet man halt Behörden, die sich einfach darum kümmern oder Genossenschaften. Also diejenigen, die es konkret betrifft, weil sie in einem Haus wohnen oder so, kümmern sich dann selber darum, dass das Dach da dicht bleibt und so weiter und so fort. Also ich glaube, man kriegt die Renditeversprechen leichter raus, als wir uns das manchmal zugestehen wollen.
Ich stimme dir voll und ganz zu. Nur das würde ja dann nur über den Weg der Politik funktionieren.
Richtig.
Und alles andere ist aber Unsinn. Also man kann jetzt sagen, ja, die Unternehmen, die Lebensmittelkonzerne, die machen dies und das. Das wird sich nicht ändern. Und die machen dann vielleicht jetzt mal gerade, weil es auch im Vogue ist, nicht mit russland-geschäfte, aber natürlich ist ihnen sonst der Hunger in der Welt egal, beziehungsweise sie verdienen auch daran. Und sie spekulieren ja auch, das ist ja nochmal ein ganz anderes Feld, das mit Nahrungsmitteln spekuliert wird. Und zwar nicht von jenen, die sie produzieren. Also das gibt es ja auch. Das ist ja eigentlich mal die Idee von der Börse als termingeschäft, dass man dort eine gewisse Absicherung dann auch hat, für das, was man vor hat zu ernten. Aber wer einfach nur mit Lebensmitteln spekuliert, aber selbst gar keine hat, ist natürlich ein reiner Spekulant und sorgt dafür, dass natürlich diese Preise nach oben gehen. Und das könnte man alles aus der Sphäre der Ökonomie herausführen. Also man kann genauso wie man sagen kann, Ulm macht das mit dem Vorkaufsrecht.
Genau.
Ulm vergibt Grundstücke und die zu einem vernünftigen Preis und nicht zu Spekulationspreisen. So könnte man auch sagen, nein, Nahrung ist Angelegenheit des staates und darum kümmern wir uns. Und dann gibt es noch mal die Unternehmen, die was verarbeiten. Und auch die müssen einen fairen Marktpreis zahlen. Und da muss auch immer eine soziale Verantwortung für die ganze Welt mit implizit sein. Das kann man natürlich alles machen, aber das verlangt dann natürlich wirklich politischen Willen. Und ich sehe auch gar nichts in der Debatte dafür. Also das ist das ist so interessant, dass der Staat ja komplett rausgehalten wird. Das ist ja nicht nur Christian Lindner. Also ich will dir, ich bin schon überlegen, ob wir eine neue Rubrik brauchen hier. Der dümmste Tweet des Monats. Jedenfalls kam der, da bin ich mir ganz sicher, ich habe nicht alle Tweets der Welt gelesen in diesem Monat. Aber ich bin mir sicher, es ist dennoch der dümmste. Kam der von Thorsten Sträter. Das ist so ein Comedian. Der hat bei Twitter folgendes geschrieben. Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, Thema Alltagsarmut fand ich erstmal schon schöner Begriff. Was ist denn nicht Alltagsarmut? Also heißt Alltagsarmut am Wochenende geht es einmal prima oder?
Also naja, gut, wir spazieren die ganze Woche auf, um am Samstag dann Fehlte zu machen.
Wahrscheinlich ja Thema Alltagsarmut wäre es eine Idee, wenn alle, die es können, Supermarktgutscheine kaufen, per DM versenden, also per Direct message versenden und so vielen Bedürftigen wie möglich einen großen Zusatzeinkauf ermöglichen. So für 100 Euro jeden Monat. Mir fällt nichts anderes gutes ein. Und ich hab diesen Tweet ja nur gefunden, ich folge ihm ja nicht, weil Micky Beisenherz den natürlich zuverlässig geliked hat. Und das ist einfach herrlich zu sehen, dass man das Thema schon jetzt wahrgenommen hat. Armut gibt es auch in Deutschland. Wir sprechen ja hier nochmal über ganz andere Dimensionen, aber bleiben wir gerade mal in Deutschland. Armut gibt es und jetzt fällt einem nichts anderes ein, als zu sagen, wir könnten doch so eine Charity-Aktion machen, wo jeder, der ein bisschen mehr Geld hat, Supermarktgutscheine per DM an irgendwelche Leute versendet. Und die meisten, die arm sind, sind aber dann komischerweise nicht bei Twitter. Was machen wir denn da, könnte man ja auch fragen. Und da meint man, das wäre jetzt des reizes Lösung. Und dann auch noch zu schreiben, mir fällt nichts anderes gutes ein. Gut, ich würde jetzt mal sagen, Erbschaftssteuer, Vermögenssteuer, ohnehin kann der Staat Geld ausgeben, wie wir sehen, wenn wir aufs Militär blicken. Aber nein, den Comedians fällt nichts anderes ein, als einen solchen Unsinn, der dann hunderte Male geliked und geteilt wird, zu twittern.
Ja, Torsten Sträter war lange auf der Suche nach einem Batmobil. Er hat dann jemanden gefunden, der ihm eins baut. Also hat er sich ein Batmobil gekauft. Dann denkt man natürlich anders über Sachen nach. In der Alten Republik unterscheide ich auch zwischen... Wirklich?
Hat er ein Batmobil? Ja, hat er sich ein Batmobil.
Es gibt da so einen Typ, der guckt sich so die Batman-Filme an und denkt, dieses Auto habe ich jetzt mal Lust zu bauen. Und da er nur am Bauen Spaß hat und nicht das Auto dann einfach stapeln möchte, sucht er dann Käufer und dann haben sie sich irgendwie gefunden und jetzt hat Torsten Sträter ein Batmobil.
Und damit kann er ja auch dann noch mal ein paar Lebensmittel rumfarben, aber das passt ja sehr gut. Denn das ist ja Bruce Wayne, ist der Private, der privat wirtschaftet, der dann sagt, aber ich mache, eigentlich macht Robin Hood ja nur Charity. Batman macht ja nur Charity.
Genau.
Und das ist genau das, was man dann hier nochmal ideologischen Reihenformen in so einem Tweet gefasst hat.
Ja, und dieses Milliardär und Reichsein ist ja für ihn auch eine Bürde. Das ist ja, das ist ja eigentlich alles gar nicht.
Wer kennt es nicht? Hast du es gesehen? diese, darüber sprechen wir natürlich nicht über Finn Kliemann. Finn Kliemann macht ja jetzt so alle fünf Tage neue Entschuldigungsvideos und bekommt immer wieder einen drüber und macht dann wieder neues. Und jetzt hat er auch nochmal so ein Video gemacht, in dem er so sagte, ja erst durch die Wirtschaftsprüfung hat er überhaupt erfahren, dass er da eine viertel Millionen verdient hat. Und dass das erstmal Leute abkaufen, finde ich natürlich toll. Und zweitens, wenn es wirklich so wäre, dann sieht man ja, der muss ja verdammt reich sein. Also wenn einem die vierte Million nur noch auffällt, wenn der Wirtschaftsprüfer darauf hinweist, dann muss ich mich fragen, wie viel Geld ist denn da? Da schwimmt man ja nur noch im Gelden.
Genau, Krise ist geil. Ich habe zu Finn Kliemann ein kleines Argument. Ich habe mir die Böhmermann-Aufarbeitung nicht angesehen, nur so ein paar Spiegel-Online-Texte kurz reingelesen. Es kam so die Frage auf, und die kommt zu unserem Thema hier wieder zurück. Es kam so die Frage auf Finn Kliemann. Er hat dieses Kliemannsland, und da arbeiten Leute für lau. Gleichzeitig bereichert er sich da so. Müsste er nicht vor Ort mal für Ausgleich sorgen. Diejenigen, die da bei ihm sind, mitarbeiten, auch Inhalte seiner Videos sind, die er so erfolgreich sind. Ich will hier mal einen Punkt machen, der für die Altenrepublik ganz, ganz wichtig ist. Denn wir stellen ja fest, Thorsten Streeter und so weiter, wir gehören ja zu den Ländern, die eigentlich wohlhabend geworden sind, bevor sie alt wurden. Also bei uns sind es nur Verteilungsfragen. Es ist bei uns nicht die Situation, wie in Vietnam, dass wir feststellen, oh so auf halben Wege, wir waren gerade mitten im Sprung in die Innovation und ins vortrittliche Land. Und dann haben wir plötzlich keine Mitarbeiter mehr und nur noch viele Alte. Und jetzt sind alle alt und arm. Nee, wir haben ja auch viele reiche Alte. Und dann, wie Torsten Sträter anmerkte, kann man das nicht so ein bisschen anders verteilen. Jetzt hast du gesagt Erbschaftssteuer. Ich würde sagen, ja, Erbschaftssteuer, Mieteinnahmen. Warum gibt es ein Recht auf Rendite? Das steht doch nirgendwo. Eigentum verpflichtet, auch dazu für die Stadt, in der man lebt, ein bisschen zu sorgen, also dass sich da alle wohlfühlen und nicht jeder 60 Prozent seines Einkommens für sein Wohnen verbraucht. So, und jetzt ist ja die Frage für uns, was haben wir denn von unserem Wohlstand, wenn wir ihn nicht so verteilt bekommen, dass die eine Hälfte der gesellschaft einfach nichts davon hat. Als Bettler ins Rentenalter geht und dann 20 Jahre lang nur noch vor sich hin leidet. Und was wollen diese Leute eigentlich? Wollen die echten DM-Gutschein, der ihnen so geschenkt wird, wo sie nicht genau wissen, kriege ich nächsten Monat eigentlich wieder ein, also kann ich damit planen oder was ist das hier für eine Gönnerstruktur? Und das, was gerade ältere Menschen und insbesondere Männer wollen, ist geselligkeit. Und jetzt kann sich Deutschland die Frage stellen, wenn die FDP regiert und so und es ist wirklich schwer, damit Geld anders zu verteilen, also ein paar Milliardäre zu Millionären zu machen und dafür ein paar sehr arme Menschen ein bisschen Geld zu geben. Was wollen die eigentlich? Und jetzt kann man die Klammer schließen, auch zu Finn Kliemann. Was wollen die Menschen eigentlich, die bei Finn Kliemann auf der Farm mitarbeiten und in diesen Videos vorkommen wollen? Wollen die wirklich Geld? Ist denen damit geholfen? Nein, die sind da wegen geselligkeit. Und darin steckt ein ganz, ganz großes Argument. Finn Kliemann bezahlt diese Leute mit geselligkeit. Sie reisen dahin und haben plötzlich Freunde und sind plötzlich YouTube-Stars und haben was zu tun den ganzen Tag. So und das betrifft erstaunlicherweise unsere Altenrepublik, und damit meine ich jetzt mal ganz spezifisch unsere Alten, sehr vielen Menschen im Rentenalter, ist nicht damit geholfen, wenn man ihnen einfach Geld gibt, obwohl sie zu wenig haben, sondern die wollen geselligkeit haben. Die möchten gerne entweder Geld haben, um dann auch mal einmal die Woche sich nachmittags beim Bäcker oder so zum Kuchen verabreden können. Das größte Hindernis, dass es dazu nicht kommt, ist, dass sie sich den Kuchen nicht leisten können. So und jetzt ist die Frage, machen wir eine große politische Anstrengung und verteilen das Geld neu? Oder nehmen wir uns die Herausforderung politisch zu sagen, wir schaffen den Menschen jetzt geselligkeit, unabhängig davon, wie viel Geld sie haben? Denn Menschen, die Geld haben, sind gesellig. Die gehen in ihren fitness-club, die machen ihre Reisen, sind in irgendwelchen...
Aber warum oder? Also das muss ja dann eines mit dem anderen verbunden sein.
Man kann auch beides.
diese geselligkeit muss ja sich...
Genau, die eigentliche Frage ist, kriegt man, und das formuliere ich auch genau so im Buch, kriegt man es hin in Deutschland den Rentnern, um mal auch von dieser Rentendiskussion wegzukommen? Kriegt man es hin? Ich würde dir in allen Deutschen das versprechen zu machen, wenn dein Arbeitsleben rum ist und du gut mitgearbeitet hast. dieses kleine spd-respekt-ding würde ich schon zugestehen. Wir haben es ja thematisiert an Sendl und so weiter. Wenn du selber der Meinung bist, ich habe jetzt 40 Jahre gearbeitet, mein Beitrag ist geleistet, warum verschafft dir nicht der Staat als Staatsziel einen Urlaub bis zum jahresende, sodass du deinen kleinen Rückzugsort hast, in einer großen Gemeinschaft lebst und weißt, wenn ich morgen aufstehe, gehe ich erst mal frühstücken. Und dann sitze ich, je nach Lust und Laune, eine Stunde oder drei Stunden bei Egon, Peter und Tim und Hanne Lore, als wäre ich im Urlaub und frühstücke mit denen. Und ich weiß dann, wenn das Frühstück vorbei ist, ist Mittagsruhe, dann gibt es einen kleinen Happen, und nachmittags ist hier irgendwie Programm, da ist so ein, zwei Stunden was los. Und das ist das, was die Leute eigentlich wollen. Und deswegen ist die Rentendiskussion im Sinne von, wie viel wollen wir denn den Leuten, die einsam in viel zu großen Wohnungen leben, noch zusätzlich eine Rente geben, damit sie das irgendwie wegsparen für ihre Enkel oder so. Das ist nicht die Frage. Sondern die Frage ist, wie schaffen wir für alle so eine Kliemannsland-Rentenzeit, 20 Jahre Urlaub. Und das ist eigentlich nicht so schwer, das zu machen, denn so viel ist gar nicht nötig. Es geht ja nur um, was weiß ich, drei Nachmittagstermine die Woche und geselligkeit beim Essen. Und damit wäre schon viel gemacht. Also allein über architektonische Veränderungen, ohne dass es Mehrkosten verursacht, hätte man schon ganz schön viele Probleme in der Alten Republik gelöst. Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, wie Leute überrascht sind, dass sie nicht genau wissen, was eine stationäre Aufnahme für psychisch Kranke bedeutet. Das ist jetzt nochmal thematisch auch ein düsteres Thema, aber man ist dort nicht dauerhaft in einem therapeutischen Zusammenhang, sondern auch auf Stationen lebt man mit Patienten und die Patienten sind unter sich und einmal die Woche ist dann mal eine Stunde Therapie. Also man hat nicht mehr Therapie, nur weil man in einer Station untergebracht ist, sondern die Station selbst ist dann die Therapie, aber unangeleitet. Man trifft sich halt so auf dem Hof, man kommt zu uns quatschen, man ist aus seinen alten sozialen Gefüge raus und da kann man relativ viel lernen, wie man mit den eigentlichen Problemen so einer alten Republik umgeht. Aber wir sehen eben in Deutschland auch nichts davon. Und das sieht man da wieder an dieser Sträter-Argumentation. Im Grunde bräuchten wir so die Tafel, aber wirklich als sozialer Ort, zu dem man gerne hingeht. Und nicht das, wie wir es jetzt haben, dass man sich da so vermummt und hoffentlich sieht mich keiner und so.
Nee, der rest wäre Aufgabe des staates. Also, dass der Aufgabe des staates wäre, erstmal dafür zu sorgen, dass genügend Geld da ist, dass man sich den Kuchen leisten kann. Und dann wäre es wiederum die Möglichkeit für einen jeden, sich geselligkeit zu verschaffen. Und dann braucht man aber auch Orte der geselligkeit. Und das ist dann vielleicht nicht einfach nur die Bäckereikette irgendwo. Also da gibt es das ja, da ist das ja zu beobachten. Also da sind ja die, sagen wir, 65- bis 85-Jährigen, wenn man mal so durch die kleineren Orte fährt, dann sieht man das, wie diese ganzen Bäckereien, alle heißen Kampfshöfer und sonst was. Und dort treffen sich die Senioren. Und da treffen sich natürlich immer nur die Senioren, die sich das leisten können, überhaupt sich da mal zu treffen. Und auch da könnte man fragen, warum muss das alles immer privatwirtschaftlich sein? Wir haben das ja auf der kulturellen Ebene auch sehr viel mehr, nicht privatwirtschaftlich.
Warum ist eine Bäckerei privatwirtschaftlich organisiert? Es gibt dafür ganz wenig Gründe. Und jetzt stellt man sich mal vor, man organisiert die Bäckerei so, dass 100 Leute, die die Bäckerei gerne nutzen, also so eine kleine Backstube, dass sich die wie in so einem Dienstplan aufschreiben, wer an welchem Tag mit wem die Kuchen backt. So und dann hast du, jeder ist jeden zehnten Tag dran. Und die Leute würden das noch besser finden, den Kuchen noch selber zu backen, obwohl das ja Arbeit ist und so weiter. Aber das mit einzubauen, und dann kannst du das einfach als Verein organisieren. Die brauchen halt nur eine Backstube. Das ist das Problem. Die können sich keine Backstube leisten für 50.000, 100.000 Euro. Die wissen aber, wie man backt, wie man mit den Zutaten umgeht. Die haben Lust darauf, gemeinsam die Zutaten zu besorgen, das zu backen und so weiter. Und sich einfach nachmittags mit Kuchen zu versorgen, um darüber einen sozialen Raum zu schaffen, in dem sie sich einfach alle wohlfühlen. So und das kriegt man jenseits von Marktwirtschaft einfach organisiert. Das ist gar kein großes Problem.
Wir brauchen natürlich auch erstmal wieder ein Bewusstsein dafür, dass das wirklich etwas erstrebenswertes ist. Also wir haben ja auch viele solche Einrichtungen, die dann zu wenig genutzt werden. Wenn man zum Beispiel mal schaut, was die Kirchen so vor Ort anbieten, dann sind das ja mitunter genau solche Dinge, die du da beschreibst. Aber da sind dann nur sehr wenige Leute, die überhaupt sich da engagieren, weil sie das in irgendeiner Weise komisch finden. Engagieren klingt doch immer gleich so, als würde man die Welt da retten. Erstmal kann man sagen, man macht sich selbst eine gute Zeit. Und hilft vielleicht auch noch ein paar anderen Leuten dabei. Aber das ist ja etwas, was zum Beispiel Kirchen anbieten, was aber gar nicht so groß wahrgenommen wird. Also ich glaube, da könnte man überall vor Ort auch noch hingehen. Und da gibt es natürlich Kontakt-Show, da gibt es auch einfach diese Tatsache, dass das sehr verlernt wurde, dass so gesellschaft ist. Sondern gesellschaft ist eigentlich, dass so jeder auf eigene Faust mit sich alleine mit dem Koffer ringt und dann aber doch noch hofft, dass der große Stefan Schulz im Abteil steht, damit er den Koffer oben vuxieren kann. Ja, darauf hofft man dann, wenn es nicht so ist, dann muss man sehen, wo man bleibt. Ja, und das ist das große Problem, dass man dadurch so eine Kultur der Ellenbogen etabliert hat, die dann am Ende auch zur Neidkultur wird, wo ich dann auch irgendwann selbst das 9-Euro-Ticket niemandem mehr gönnen möchte.
Genau, ganz genau, richtig.
So, wir kommen noch einmal kurz zurück zu dem Thema Hunger. Und wir haben in den vergangenen Monaten viel über feministische Außenpolitik gesprochen. Und gutteres greift das hier indirekt auch einmal auf.
Mr. president, around the world 49 million people in 43 countries are in emergency levels of hunger, known as IPC-4, just one step away from famine. In other words, they are facing starvation and are doing everything they can to survive. As always, women and girls are worst affected. And this is reflecting in rising rates of trafficking, forced marriage and other abuses.
Wenn die Armut steigt, dann steigen die Zwangsverheiratungen und vor allem die ganz jungen Zwangsverheiratungen, weil die Familien dann wenigstens hoffen, noch ein bisschen Geld zu bekommen, wenn sie die 13-, 14-jährigen Töchter verheiraten. Und wir haben ja jetzt eben den Berichten auch gehört. Es sind dann die Frauen, die mit den Kindern irgendwo zurückbleiben, versuchen, sich durchzukämpfen und oft gelingt das nicht. Also ein feministisches Thema. Und dann haben wir jetzt den UN-Chef gehört. Und jetzt bin ich dann noch so ein bisschen durch die Audiothek der ARD gestolpert zum Thema Hunger. Und dann sah ich, ach im November im SWR war Entwicklungsminister Gerd Müller zu Gast, so als einer der letzten Amtshandlungen. Und er erzählt da, was erreicht wurde.
Die Staatengemeinschaft hat sich ja vor 30 Jahren das Ziel gesetzt, 0,7 Prozent des bruttosozialproduktes für Entwicklungszusammenarbeit. Da haben wir jetzt 30 Jahre gearbeitet, aber es ist uns jetzt gelungen im vergangenen Jahr. diese Linie muss ausgebaut werden. Wir müssen mehr tun. Ich sage es noch mal, nationales Klein-Klein, die Herausforderungen sind heute global. Klimaschutz, Pandemiebekämpfung, eine Welt ohne Hunger.
Ja, 0,7 Prozent. Lächerlich. Deutschland sollte sich Nigeria als Partnerland schnappen und dort auf aller Ebene mit diesen 200-plus Millionen Menschen, die im Durchschnitt 14 Jahre alt sind, einfach mal zusammenarbeiten, als wäre es ein weiteres bundesland.
Jahrzehnte gebraucht, um überhaupt mal diese 0,7 Prozent zu haben. Ein Ziel, von dem wir wahrscheinlich gar nichts wussten. Müller spricht auch über die Zunahme von Hunger.
Weltweit, seit 1990, wurden die Zahl der Hungernden halbiert. Aber mit der Pandemie steigen die Zahlen wieder. Wir sind leider bei 800 Millionen Menschen, die täglich nicht wissen, was sie am nächsten Tag essen können. Und heute werden sie das Interview hören, am heutigen Tag sterben 15.000 Kinder an Hunger. Es müsste nicht sein. Und das ist die Hauptaufgabe des oder der Entwicklungsministerin. Laut zu werden. Eine Welt ohne Hunger ist möglich. Warum tun wir es nicht?
Es ist genug für alle da.
Ja, es ist genug für alle da. Man kann nicht sagen, wir sind leider noch nicht weit genug entwickelt oder wir sind zu viele auf dem Planeten. All diese Argumente sind Quatsch. Man könnte tatsächlich alle satt bekommen. Es ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber man macht es nicht. Und dabei wäre es auch gar nicht so teuer wie Müller.
In unseren Köpfen muss sich was ändern. Welcher Politiker kann sich dem verwehren, eine Welt ohne Hunger zu schaffen? Ich sage, wer sich verwehrt, der macht sich schuldig. Hunger ist Mord, weil wir die Technik, das Wissen haben. Und beim Geld, wir haben im Ministerium mit den internationalen Experten einmal die Frage untersucht, wie viel Geld brauchtet ihr, damit jedes Kind, jeder auf der Welt genug zu essen hat? 40 Milliarden die nächsten 10 Jahre bis 2030 in Landwirtschaft, in Produktivitätssteigerung, in Bewässerung und in vieles mehr investiert. Wir wissen, wie es geht. Warum machen wir das nicht?
Es gibt auch eine ganz super interessante demografische Argumentation für alle, die sich jetzt fragen, ja, aber warum kriegen die so viele Kinder? 5% Wirtschaftswachstum und die Aussicht, da partizipieren zu können, also selber auch 5% in die eigene Biografie jedes Jahr, zack, 1,8 Kinder pro Frau von sieben. Dauert eine Generation, hat im Iran anderthalb Generationen gedauert, um von über sieben Kindern auf unter zwei Kinder zu kommen. Einfach nur, ja, hier ist Entwicklung möglich, du kannst partizipieren, musst natürlich deine Biografie ein bisschen gestalten, du kannst jetzt nicht so in den Tag hinein leben, du musst planen, setzt dir ein Ziel in fünf Jahren den und den Bildungsabschluss und so hat in jedem Land bisher funktioniert. Es ist absolut ein kulturell unabhängiges Paradigma, das immer gilt.
40 Milliarden haben wir jetzt gerade gehört. dieses gespräch ist vom November 21. Der Krieg ist also noch nicht da und wir haben jetzt 100 Milliarden mehr für die bundeswehr über dieses Sondervermögen. Dann soll das NATO-Zwei-Prozent-Ziel übererfüllt werden. Aufrüstung ist weltweit in vollem Gange. Noch nie wurde so viel ausgegeben und die Rüstungskonzerte in aller Welt jubilieren. Sie haben steigende Kurse, große Gewinnerwartungen für die nächsten zehn Jahre. Und jetzt sagt Gerd Müller immerhin ja von der Union folgendes.
Die Rüstungs-Lobbyisten in der Welt haben größten Einfluss, 2000 Milliarden, 2000 Milliarden. Und auch bei dieser Koalitionsregierung wurde wieder gerungen, den Rüstungsetat mit der Perspektive 2 Prozent zu erhöhen. Ich sage, wer 2 Prozent bei Rüstung anstrebt, der muss bereit sein, mindestens auch 1 Prozent für Entwicklungszusammenarbeit einzusetzen. Und das weltweit.
Jo, 1 Prozent, was für eine unverschämte Forderung.
Ja, aber auch das wird vermutlich nicht kommen. Und so ist der Hunger ein Problem, das uns lange erhalten bleibt. Und da ist dann von westlichen Werten auch nicht mehr die Rede. Das muss man, und da braucht man nicht Relativismus oder so, oder Whataboutismus vorzuwerfen, sondern das ist einfach eine knallharte Tatsache. Müller hat es ja ganz klar auf den Punkt gebracht. Niemand muss verhungern. Hunger ist Mord und daran machen wir uns schuldig.
Von ihm haben wir auch den Spruch gehört, für uns arbeiten jeweils 50 Sklaven. Also der Imperialismus ist schon ziemlich beträchtlich. Wolfgang, du hast ein Smartphone, auch wenn du es nicht mit dir rumträgst.
Ja, aber nur um Instagram zu bedienen.
Nur um Instagram zu bedienen. Dann bist du, naja, der Hüller kann man nicht sagen ausgeliefert, denn Robert Habeck nutzt ja auch nur Instagram und nicht Twitter, denn Twitter ist ja die Hölle und auf Instagram geht es ja gemäßig zu. Aber du nimmst Teil am, wie soll man sagen, Real-Time-Bidding. Hast du davon schon mal gehört?
Nein.
RTB, das war ein großer Skandal jetzt hier im Mai, denn stellt sich raus, und wir reden nachher auch noch über China, wir denken ja immer, auch in China, da werden ja alle überwacht und da gibt es ja so viele Informationen zu tracken, uns werden Profile angelegt, stellt sich raus, es gibt einen 100 Milliarden Dollar jahresumsatzgroßen Markt allein in Amerika, also für die dort lebenden 350 oder wie viele Millionen Menschen. Es werden alle Menschen, die am Internet teilnehmen, zu Hause am Browser oder unterwegs, weil sie ein Smartphone mit sich haben, sind Teil dieses marktes, ohne es zu wissen, denn 4.698 US-Unternehmen, 1.058 EU-Unternehmen und weitere aus Russland und China und so weiter greifen auf Daten zu, die diejenigen, die die Technik zur Verfügung stellen, als Webseitenbetreiber, als Smartphone, Softwarehersteller, Hardware, vor allem Betriebssysteme, also Google und so weiter, oder eben einfach so. All die Daten, die anfallen und die Zahlen sind wirklich atemberaubend, ich werde sie gleich nennen, kumulieren dann zu diesem und keiner wusste bescheid. Also das Irish Council of Civil liberties hat im PDF veröffentlicht, wo der RTB-Scandal, also der Real-Time-Bidding-Skandal, einmal aufgedröselt wurde. Es geht darum, Menschen, die zum Beispiel ihre Location über Google, weil Google das Betriebssystem herstellt, oder ihre, welche Webseite besuche ich eigentlich gerade, und so weiter, diesen Datenschatz weiterverkaufen. Man dachte ja immer, ja, das handel ich gerade mit, was weiß ich, dem Smartphone-Hersteller aus, dass ich seien es, ich bezahle es ja auch, dass ich dann so ein bisschen unter mir bin. Aber nein, die Deutschen werden pro Minute, die sie online sind, wird einmal pro Minute wird ein Datensatz weitergegeben, was bedeutet, dass 19,6 Millionen Datenpunkte allein aus Deutschland jede Minute weitergegeben werden. In Ohio, das war auch so ein Beispiel, das sie herausgegriffen haben, wird die Location von Personen 812 mal am Tag verkauft. Einfach nur die Frage, wo ist denn da gerade jemand und so weiter.
Wer kauft die?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also es gibt sehr viele Unternehmen und auch Behörden. Und wir hören uns das hier mal in drei Clips an, um dann über das Digitale dienstgesetz, das Digital services Act hier in Europa zu reden. Twig, This Week in Google, Ausgabe 664, Leo Laporte referiert, was er übers RTB Real Time Bidding über den Skandal erfahren hat.
Das bedeutet, deine Locationdata, besonders. Also RTB exposuret Menschendata auf average 747 Mal pro Tag. Google, der größte Spieler im RTB System, erlaubt 4.698 Unternehmen, um Daten über die Menschen in den USA zu bekommen. Microsoft, das in Dezember in RtB in Bezug auf die Involvenzen von Zander, die AG Tech Firmen von AT&T kauften, kann Daten von 1.647 Unternehmen vermitteln. Privilegien und Sicherheitsverlusten haben seit Jahren über RTB geschaffen, besonders in Europa, aber die Beweidung in den USA ist aufwuchs.
Es gibt 294 Billionen Datensätze, die pro Jahr von den Amerikanern und 197 Milliarden, also Billionen, die von den Europäern abgeschnorchelt und eben verkauft werden. Und business ist business, da denkt man sich, ja gut, ich nehme am business teil, die Unternehmen auch, also ist das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die wollen mir ja Werbung zuspielen und so. Stellt sich raus, nein, dieser China-Vergleich ist gar nicht so schräg, denn, und das ist hier Shoshana Weissmann, die referiert in diesem Podcast von Neulaport eingeladen, es sind auch die Regierungen. Es sind tausend Unternehmen, die Milliarden dieser Datensätze einfach abrufen.
Wie kann man sich dieses Bieten vorstellen? Also es gibt dort das interesse eines Unternehmens zu werben. Und jetzt muss man die Werbung anpassen, zum Beispiel ich möchte Männer in Frankfurt erreichen. Und dann gibt es wiederum andere Unternehmen, die diese Informationen, wo du dich zum Beispiel gerade in Frankfurt aufhältst und dass du dich in Frankfurt aufhältst, abgespeichert haben. Und du bist dann Teil in einem großen Pool, der dann verkauft wird an dieses Unternehmen, das interesse hat, Männer, die in Frankfurt leben, zu bewerben.
Genau, bisher war ja die Erklärung von Facebook zum Beispiel immer, wir verkaufen keine Nutzerdaten. Wir kategorisieren nur Publikumssegmente. Die wir dann anbieten, für diejenigen, die dann ihre Daten, nämlich ihre Werbematerial zu uns bringen und hier präsentieren. Und jetzt stellt sich heraus, nein, das läuft auch umgedreht. Die Informationen, die Google über die Google Maps-Funktion auf deinem Smartphone und so weiter hat, wo du bist und was du dann wahrscheinlich auch tust, das könnte man ja dann einfach rückschließen, die werden einfach so, also die sind kaufbar. Man kann auf diese Daten zugreifen und das machen Tausende von Unternehmen.
Und was hat der Staat davon?
Ja, was hat der Staat davon? Also diese Frage, die vertiefen wir gleich nochmal mit, Shoshana Weissmann. Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht, dass wir das hier so gar nicht jetzt im Mai mitbekommen haben.
Ja.
Das hier so eine große Ausleuchtung und wir sind alle der gläserne Bürger, obwohl wir es ja eigentlich andersrum wollten. Wir wollten ja eine gläserregerung und so weiter. Und dass dieses Verhältnis mal wieder so krass verdreht ist, das stellt Shoshana Weissmann hierher, denn die Informationen, für die sich der Staat interessiert, sind ja für den Staat verfügbar, wenn er den Weg über den Richter und so weiter geht. Also wenn es ein echtes ermittlungsinteresse gibt und dann auch Verfahren eingehalten werden und so weiter und so fort. Und hier liegt der Shortcut vor. Das sind die Informationen, die man dann haben will. Also das Irish Council for Civil liberties mit dem PDF weist darauf hin, dass in Europa die Daten, also Datenpunkte pro Person 376 Mal am Tag abgerufen werden. Also das ist sozusagen der digitale Schatten, den wir alle hinter uns herziehen, der dann einfach da kaufbar ist, zur Verfügung gestellt wird. So, jetzt haben wir hier einen amerikanischen Podcast gehabt, wo sie meinten, ja, was gibt es eigentlich gesetze dagegen? Nee, der Staat selbst hat ein interesse daran, dass das so ist, wie es ist. Und so ein paar gesetze gibt es ja doch. Also dieses Digital services, der Digital services Act da jetzt hier, den wir hatten ja auch schon mal thematisiert, als er losging, jetzt ist er so in seiner finalen Stadium. Wir wissen immer noch nicht genau, was drinsteht. Niemand hat den Text bisher gesehen, außer diejenigen, die ihn mit verhandelt haben. Die äußern sich dann allerdings auch so ein bisschen in dem Podcast. Und das große gesetz löst ja dann auch so ein paar kleine ab oder deren Probleme auf, wie z.B. das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, wo es ja im Mai auch wieder interessant war. Die Berliner Zeitung hat hier mal diesen Jan Böhmermann-Sendung aufgegriffen. Die habe ich auch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe seinen Tweet gesehen, dass es dann zu Polizeieinsatz kam und so weiter. Also Böhmermann hat in seiner Sendung thematisiert, dass die Behörden gar nicht so hinterher sind, wenn jemand gesetzesverstöße, die online stattfanden, meldet. Und sie schreiben, Mitarbeiter des Teams gaben sich dabei als normale Bürger aus. Das Experiment, wie es Böhmermann in der Sendung am Freitag nannte, also bei der Polizei anzurufen, zu sagen, wir brauchen hier mal Hilfe, Ermittlung und so weiter, brachte unterschiedliche Ergebnisse. Während in einigen bundesländern ermittelt wurde und auch ein Täter wegen Hassbotschaften im Netz verurteilt wurde, begannen in anderen bundesländern die Ermittlung gar nicht erst oder die Anzeigen wurden nicht aufgenommen. Was dann dazu führte, die Böhmermann-Recherche hat für ein paar Beamte nun juristische Konsequenzen. Es gibt in einigen Fällen interne Ermittlungen wegen Strafvereidlungen. Also da liegt eine gewisse Unterlassung vor in den Verwaltungsapparaten, die gesetze anwenden sollen und wir finden ja, die gesetze sind schon ein bisschen Unterlassung, denn so viel regeln die ja eigentlich gar nicht. Und der Spiegel informiert hier auch mal über Clearview. Das haben wir ja auch schon mal aufgegriffen. dieses Unternehmen, das einfach mal das ganze Internet nach gesichtern abgesucht hat, dann gematcht hat, welche Informationen haben wir denn über diese gesichter. Und Patrick Beuth schreibt hier über die Bedrohung sozusagen, dass diese New Yorker Firma jetzt ihr widerrechtlich erstellte Biometriedatenbank monetarisiert, indem sie einfach den Schulen nach diesem Attentat in Uvalde das Angebot macht, ja wir können ja für euch an der Tür oben so eine Kamera hinhängen, die dann kontrolliert, wer geht denn hier eigentlich gerade rein und ist der irgendwie bekannt als, hat er vielleicht vor 5 Minuten einen Facebook-Post gemacht mit und so. Also hier geht es so richtig zur Sache. Und auch in Vorbereitung des DSAs, also unserer Thematisierung, Facebook-Leaks. netzpolitik.org hat jetzt im Mai mal darüber geschrieben, dass Vice, also Motherboard von Vice, darüber geschrieben hat, dass es ein 15-seitiges Dokument gab, in dem so drin steht, und das ist von Facebook selbst hergestellt, also geleakt, wir können jetzt darin nachlesen, dass Facebook eigentlich DSGVO gar nicht einhalten kann. Die brauchen ja immer eine zweckbestimmung für die Datenverarbeitung und müssen das eben dann auch intern immer, also jede Art der Datenverarbeitung, rückkoppeln an die gesetzesgrundlage und sie stellen fest, dass sie es eigentlich nicht können. Sie können, falls wirklich mal jemand die DSGVO nachschauen möchte, ob die da gesetzeskonform handeln oder nicht, dann können sie es eigentlich nicht nachweisen. Und dann ist das Dokument so eine interne Warnung, dass man sich doch hier mal mit diesen Problemen befassen sollte und so weiter. Also die Polizei setzt die DSG, setzt das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz nicht durch. Clearview macht die einen oder anderen Versuche und springt einfach auf so einen politischen Zeitgeist auf. Facebook weiß, dass es die DSGVO nicht einhalten kann und wir reden jetzt über den Digital services Act als das gesetz, das uns jetzt versucht, das, was mit der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung schon gelungen ist, noch mal zu übersetzen für alle möglichen Themen, nicht nur Privacy. Und das ist natürlich kompliziert.
Vielleicht eine Sache noch, die es ja auch noch gab, war die Frage, ob man die Shed-Protokolle filzen darf. Und das ist ja etwas, wo sich jetzt doch die deutsche Regierung sehr dagegen stellt, dass das möglich sein soll.
Genau, da haben wir zum Glück eine FDP-grüne Regierung, die so ein bisschen auf der, naja, wie soll man sagen, mal abwarten, was da passiert. Da hat mir Tanja gestern aus Österreich, die arbeitet da bei Epicenter Works mit, auch schon noch einen Hinweis gegeben, genau, die Chat-Kontrolle. Das ist dann noch mal ein eigenes Thema für sich, wie auch die ePrivacy-Verordnung oder Richtlinien, ich weiß gar nicht genau, was von beiden, die ja auch noch mal ansteht. Also es gibt ja gerade ganz viele gesetze, die irgendwie irgendwas wollen. Und der Digital services und Market Act, also einmal für alle Marktteilnehmer und dann einmal für die ganz Großen, die so 10 Prozent der Nutzer oder der 10 Prozent der Bürger in Europa und zu ihren eigenen Nutzerkreis zählen, also mehr als 35 Millionen Mitglieder haben, Facebook und so, Twitter, die kriegen ja dann noch mal ihr eigenes gesetz und ein paar Sachen sind dann doch drin. Wir beginnen mal hier bei der Betrachtung. Lawfare heißt der Podcast. Ich habe ihn bei YouTube gefunden. Nicht bis es viele Abrufe, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch dem Thema geschuldet. Man sitzt in Amerika und redet darüber, was die EU macht.
While US congress has been doing hearing after hearing with tech executives, that include a lot of yelling and not much progress, Europe has been quietly working away on some major tech regulations. Last month, it reached agreement on the content moderation piece of this package, the Digital services Act.
Während die Amerikaner nur quatschen in ihren Anhörungen, machen die Europäer jetzt mal kurz einen prozess und haben ein gesetz. Ist es ein kurzer prozess? Nicht ganz.
So the DSA went through a standard Brussels legislative process, which is the European Commission went through a long consultation process about what the new rules should be, and then put together a draft. And this is something I really like about the European process, is that the people who did this consultation and who wrote the draft have been thinking about this for years. They're extremely knowledgeable about these issues. They've heard from civil society and from platforms and from academics and from other people in government going back at least to 2011 about what works and doesn't about notice and takedown and how well automation works or fails to work in trying to catch prohibited speech, things like that. And so they asked smart questions in their consultation and they took the responses into account and they came up with a draft.
So, man ist also irgendwie froh und mutig in Amerika, dass man in Europa hier so ein vorbildgesetz geschaffen hat. Es hat ein Jahrzehnt Konsultationen gebraucht. Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, wie schnell die Zeit vergeht, denn die DSQVO wurde 2014 verabschiedet, kam dann irgendwann 2017 in Effekt und das ist auch schon wieder fünf Jahre her. Also am Ende geht das dann doch wahnsinnig schnell, das so rückblickend zumindest. Klar, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, das gesetz ist jetzt irgendwie fertig, wird demnächst veröffentlicht und dann dauert es noch mal zwei Jahre, bis es dann, aber das heißt halt 2024 ist es dann auch da. Alexandra gese.
Bist du auf einen Spielplatz umgezogen, jetzt bei der Podcastaufnahme?
Es ist ein Kindergarten hier draußen.
Ach so, die haben jetzt frei gerade.
Die verbringen gerade ihre Zeit draußen, 1337.
Man hört das Lachen der Kinder, auch hier in Koblenz noch.
Genau so soll das doch sein. Und ab und zu hört man auch einen Hahn krähen. Alexandra gese, die für die Grünen mitverhandelt hat, von Seiten des Parlaments. Wir wissen ja, wie es abläuft. Kommission macht einen Vorschlag. Rat und Parlament verhalten sich dazu. Dann haben wir drei Vorschläge. Die müssen dann in einem Trilog ganz intransparent ausklamüsert werden. Sie betont auch nochmal diese Vorrangstellung Europas.
Aber eigentlich würde ich eben heute Abend gerne über den Digital services Act sprechen. Das heißt, das neue grundgesetz für das Internet, wo wir in Europa der erste demokratische Kontinent sind, der wirklich ganz klare Regeln jetzt festlegt. Für die großen Plattformen, für alle Plattformen, alle digitalen Plattformen, aber im besonderen natürlich für die ganz Großen.
So, Europe Calling hat hier so einen kleinen Talk gemacht. Der ist ganz interessant. Markus Becke Dahl, Sven Giegold, jetzt Habeck, Handlanger da, Staatssekretär, aber eben auch da im Europaparlament lange zuständig für solche Sachen und Shoshana Zuboff, die wir ja nun kennen als die Autorin des Überwachungskapitalismus buches, die sich auch ganz erfreut zeigt. Wir beginnen aber bei Markus Becke Dahl von netzpolitik.org, der eine etwas gerusame Einschätzung macht im Vergleich zu dem, was wir gleich hören.
Mal wie Alexandra schon sagte, bis das erstmal alles in Kraft getreten ist, bis wir mal die Auswirkungen sehen, bis wir mal mehr erforscht haben durch die neuen Möglichkeiten, die der DSA schaffen wird, werden wieder einige Jahre vergehen, wo die Plattformen sozusagen noch weitgehendere Narrenfreiheit haben. nichtsdestotrotz ist alles besser als der derzeitige Status Quo, wo sie halt in den letzten, sagen wir, zehn, 15 Jahren weitgehend Regulierungsferien und Narrenfreiheit im Rahmen der Selbstregulierung genossen haben und dadurch unvorstellbare Macht ausgebaut haben und viel zu wenig demokratische Kontrollmöglichkeiten erlebt haben.
Die größten Regulierungsferien ist ein sehr schönes Wort, wie ich finde.
Nun stellt sich da für mich gleich die Frage, man kann das natürlich so einordnen und auch da feststellen, dass es zwar jetzt auf den Weg kommt, aber nicht schnell genug ist oder man davon ausgehen kann, dass die Konzerne wieder sehr schnell sein werden, irgendwelche Grauzonen zu finden und diese auszunutzen. Da stellt sich ja grundsätzlich die Frage, das ist ja zunächst einmal notwendig so gegeben, dass die gesetzgebung hinterherhinkt, weil die gesetzgebung auf etwas reagieren muss. Und wenn es noch nicht da ist, kann noch nicht alles eingehegt werden. Und so werden viele Tatsachen geschaffen. Und dann muss man im Nachhinein, auch wenn es dann Jahre dauert, wieder verhandeln, wie man da manches wieder einhegt. Die Frage ist aber dann doch bei einem Fortschritt, der so rasend geschieht, ob das Jahr noch zeitgemäß ist, dass es dann so viele Jahre dauert. Und gäbe es irgendeine Möglichkeit, diese Verfahren zu beschleunigen, ohne dabei die Demokratie aufzugeben? Denn die Antwort, die ja auf diese Frage immer, dann kommt es, ja klar, aber das Dumme ist halt die Demokratie. Und das, glaube ich, wird schon die Frage des Jahrzehnts sein. Ist es demokratisch möglich, sehr viel schneller zu regulieren? Oder ist das jetzt, wenn wir wieder etwas erkennen, auch eine Phase, die wir dann am Ende dieser Neuen Zwanziger einläuten und sagen, gut, dass es jetzt auf den Weg gebracht ist?
Steht natürlich noch ein bisschen offen, aber dieses gesetz, und wir hören erst nach den Einschätzungen, was drin steht, hat zum Beispiel ein paar Mechanismen, wo die Unternehmen begleitet werden. Wo man nicht einfach jetzt zum Pflok einschlägt und sagt, so ist die Sache, sondern ich habe ja häufiger dieses von Thomas Kleber, dem Justiziater IG Metall dieses Argument aufgeworfen, dass man ja einen Gefahrgut-Transporter in dem Moment, wo er auf der Autobahn fährt und brennt, einfach stilllegen kann, weil nämlich jemand ruft die Polizei, die Polizei fährt auf die Autobahn und legt ihn einfach still. Fährt einfach vorhin und sagt, du musst jetzt mal raus, bist zu gefährlich. diese Mechanismen gab es ja bisher nicht, und die könnte man aber nachbauen, also dass sozusagen eine Polizei auf der Datenautobahn mit fährt und sagt, das muss man jetzt aber mal stilllegen hier. Und da warten wir nicht erst die nächste große Entscheidung des Europaparlament ab, weil es ein neues gesetz braucht, sondern wir haben dann schon eine gesetzesgrundlage, um einfach in den laufenden Betrieb der Dinge eingreifen zu können, entsprechend demokratisch legitimiert. Aber vorher die Einschätzung von Shoshana Zuboff. Also wir haben jetzt Markus Begeda gehört, ja, es ist besser als der Status quo, die Unternehmen sind unglaublich mächtig geworden, haben Regulierungsferien gehabt und haben sich im Schatten dieser Narrenfreiheit da ausgebreitet. zumindest das zu beenden oder ein bisschen zu begrenzen, ist schon mal gut. Shoshana Zuboff zündet hier ein ganz anderes Feuerwerk. dieser gesetz, und wir hören sie übersetzt auf Deutsch, der YouTube-Team hatte das nur so in einer Tonspur.
DSA ist nicht nur ein weiteres Brüsseler gesetzesstück, das wieder unheimlich viel Papier produzieren wird, sondern das ist wirklich ein mutiger Beginn eines neuen Zeitalters. Es ist die erste umfassende Erklärung einer demokratischen digitalen Zukunft, die sich auf legitime Autorität der demokratischen Rechte stützt und auf die Rechtsstaatlichkeit. Um nur noch mal das als Fußnote zu sagen, ich habe auf 40 Jahre damit verbracht, auf so etwas zu warten. Und es ist für mich eine wirklich enorme Freude. Das ist für mich eine riesen-inspiration. Und ich bin auch unglaublich dankbar dafür, dass das jetzt erreicht wurde.
Also es ist da ganz außer sich über diese neue Machtbegrenzung für die Unternehmen.
dieses digitale dienstegesetz ist genau das, was in der ersten Phase jetzt erreicht werden musste. Denn die Schallgrenze der Unvermeidlichkeit wird jetzt hier durchbrochen. Die Unternehmen sind selbstgefällig geworden. Sie haben sich einfach alles getraut, alles erlaubt. Und sie hatten auch die Möglichkeit, einfach das zu tun, was sie wollten, sich das zu nehmen, was sie wollten.
So und jetzt hören wir von ihr nochmal so ein kleines Snippet.
Wir haben jetzt eine neue Seite, ein neues Kapitel aufgeschlagen. Und wir schreiben jetzt die geschichte hier neu weiter.
Und jetzt hat sie als Vierten nochmal so eine kleine Metapher.
Unabhängig davon, was da vielleicht jetzt noch fehlt, was noch verbessert werden kann. Also dieses digitale dienstegesetz hat es uns ermöglicht, die Titanic vom Eisberg wegzusteuern. Und alles, was sie jetzt noch tun müssen, ist weiterfahren, weiterfahren, bis wir wirklich ans Ufer kommen, an der Küste landen unserer neuen digitalen demokratischen Zukunft, die dann wirklich greifbar sein wird. dieses digitale dienstegesetz sagt ganz klar, die digitalen Dienste leben im Haus der Demokratie, wo sie auch schon immer hingehört hätten.
So, sie kennen den Text allerdings auch nicht. Sie hat erst mal nur aufgegriffen, was so vor ihr lag und hat dann diese Urteile daraus gestrickt.
Die Titanic, die Titanic ist für Ernst Jünger wichtig. wusstest du das?
Nein.
Und zwar in seinem Essay Der Waldgang schreibt er darüber, dass wir in der Moderne nur noch Passagiere sind. Für ihn ist die Titanic das Sinnbild der Moderne. Wir haben es nicht mehr selbst im Griff, sondern wir sind nur noch Passagiere und gehen unter. Das ist ja ein demokratiekritischer Text. Und das ist jetzt ganz lustig, dass sie sich auf die Titanic bezieht und sagt, wir steuern die Titanic, aber jetzt können die auch steuern. Wir müssen also nicht nur Passagiere sein, sondern wir können durchaus auch Steuermann werden und können dann das Schiff in Richtung Demokratie lenken.
Ja, also eine wahnsinnig positive Einschätzung dieser gesamtlage. Und um das zu verbinden, also Shoshana Zuboff, die das aus Amerika kommentiert, Markus Beckerdahl, der das ja aus Deutschland kommentiert, mitten drin eben Sven Giegold, der hier nochmal drei Anmerkungen macht, die so ein bisschen die, wie soll man sagen, fast Realpolitik nochmal vergegenwärtigen.
Der erste große Erfolg war die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, mit denen Europa Regeln für den Umgang mit Daten gesetzt hat. Und jetzt haben wir mit dem Digital Markets Act Regeln für den Wettbewerb durch insbesondere der großen Akteure und mit dem Digital services Act auch die Verbraucherschutz und die Regeln zum Schutz der Meinungsfreiheit, aber genauso auch die Verpflichtung der Akteure.
So erhebt das also auf die DSGVO-Ebene, die ja nun schon ziemlich reingeschlagen hat. Das Generfe war jedenfalls groß, aber die Effekte dann doch irgendwie auch. Und zum Thema Titanik soll jetzt mal weiterfahren, jetzt wo sie nicht gegen den Eisberg geknallt ist, sagt er hier folgendes und da zeigt sich schon die Geruhsamkeit eines Politikers, der in Europa einfach mal seine Zeit abgesessen hat.
Die Unternehmen werden jetzt überwacht. Es gibt eine Institution, bei der man sich beschweren kann. Und was vermutlich die Unternehmen am aller unangenehmsten finden, in ein paar Jahren kommen Leute wie Alexandra wieder und gucken, was nicht funktioniert hat und verschärfen die gesetze. Eine Zumutung für jeden, der glaubte, man steht eigentlich über dem Recht.
So, naja gut, in ein paar Jahren zieht man dann Bilanz. Aber wie gesagt, ich bin auch mal davon überrascht, wie schnell die Zeit dann doch vergeht. In der Hinsicht kann das eine funktionierende Drohung sein. Außerdem von ihm auch nochmal dieses Bild von Europa als Vorbild.
Schauen wir, was jetzt passieren wird in Australien, in Neuseeland, in Südkorea, in Südafrika, in allen anderen Demokratien auf der Welt. Die werden sich doch fragen, warum machen das einen Rie-Europäer? Wir haben doch den gleichen Ärger. Und irgendwann wird es auch Susanna gelingen, ein ähnliches gesetz in Amerika zu beschließen. Und dann reichen sich die Demokratien die Hand und werden dafür sorgen, dass auch all das Geld von Elon Musk nicht genug sein wird, um die Regeln auf unseren Kraniten zu bestimmen.
So, das fällt also in Zeit gleich mit Elon Musks Gebot für Twitter, dass er jetzt wieder so ziemlich weit zurückgezogen ist.
Ja, er will es jetzt anders finanzieren.
Genau.
Über die eigenen Aktien, sondern will Kredite da aufnehmen. Da muss man sehen, ob er sie auch bekommt. Er hat sicherlich auch gesehen, dass da eine große Gefahr drin besteht, wenn er da mit den eigenen Aktien kommt, die verkaufen will, weil das natürlich nicht gut dann für tesla aussieht, wenn der Chef die eigenen Aktien abstößt, weil er jetzt mal Lust auf Twitter hat. Aber was sicherlich der Effekt sein wird, ist, dass Unternehmen von Anfang an es mit der Angst zu tun bekommen haben werden. Da hat Giegold recht. Und deshalb vielleicht manche Dinge erstmal nicht tun oder versuchen gleich zu schauen, ob es doch noch andere geschäftsfelder gibt als die, die Susanne Zuboff in ihrem Buch beschrieben hat. Ich bin nicht so optimistisch, weil natürlich wir noch nicht wissen genau, was da tatsächlich dann am Ende drinsteht. Und ich muss da mich auch fragen, ob es diesen demokratischen Konsens dann geben kann zwischen den Ländern. Also hat Deutschland, hat Europa da diese Vorbildfunktion, dass man sagt, in der EU hat es geklappt und andere Länder gucken sich das jetzt ab. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, weil das bei vielen anderen Dingen, gerade auch bei Umweltschutz oder so, auch nicht der Fall ist. Insofern, ja, das ist sehr müßig, jetzt darüber zu reden an sich. Aber es ist gut, dass es überhaupt jetzt mal auf dem Wege ist.
Genau. Und was ist auf dem Wege? Also wir gehen es mal so durch, wie sie es hier zusammensammeln ließ. In diesem Lawfare-Podcast haben sie mal eins vorgestellt, wo dann auch Markus Becke da gleich betont, das ist für ihn so das Highlight. So, es gibt also ein researcher-access. Wir haben also jetzt die Möglichkeit. Die Universitäten sich darauf bewerben, Zugang zu Facebook oder wo auch immer hin zu bekommen. Es bleibt dabei, geschäftsgeheimnisse müssen gewahrt bleiben und man kriegt auch nicht direkten Zugriff auf den Algorithmus, aber so ein bisschen näher ran rückt man doch. Markus Becke da kommentiert es so.
Sehr gefreut hat es mich, dass Wissenschaftlerinnen und Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen einen verbesserten Datenzugang bekommen können, wie der genau ausgestaltet sein wird und welche verbesserungen dadurch möglich sein werden. Das wird sich halt in der Realität und nach ausgestaltung der Texte nochmal genau zeigen. Aber im Moment gibt es halt ein Damokrissschwert für alle Wissenschaftlerinnen und alle Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen, die versuchen zu verstehen, wie beispielsweise die Empfehlungsalgorithmen funktionieren, indem sie ja halt quasi die allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen verletzen und deswegen auch damit mit der rechtlichen Keule daran gehindert werden können, im interesse der Allgemeinheit hier mehr Licht ins Dunkle zu bringen. Das ist sicherlich einer, wie gesagt, der Highlight.
Also mal gucken, man kriegt relativ viel über die Funktionsweise raus, wenn man sich die Effekte der Arbeit, der Algorithmus anguckt. Man braucht gar nicht so den Zugriff auf die Algorithmen. Auf der anderen Seite hat ja Eden Musk wieder angedeutet, der möchte dann auch das Twitter-Algorithmen, wenn sie dann mal ihm gehören, veröffentlicht werden. Das ist natürlich auch noch mal eine andere Qualität von Zugang, die man da hat. Also mal gucken, ob hier Transparenz reinkommt. Als zweites, deine Frage von vorhin, ja, es gibt jetzt so eine Art Polizei, die mitfährt und mitbeobachtet. Das wird hier im Lawfare Podcast mal betont.
You also have this much more evolving, ongoing relationship with a regulator. And every year you have to do a formal risk assessment. You know, what risks you see from your platform operations. And a formal risk mitigation plan. And be audited by an outside auditor. And then submit the results of all three of those things to the regulator, which will be the European Commission in this case.
So, es gibt also eine laufende jährliche Risikoeinschätzung, die gemacht wird. Und da gibt es eine ganz interessante Einschätzung von der Alexandra gese. Denn bisher netzwerkdurchschnittungsgesetz DSGVO, da guckt man ja so auf die Inhalte. Welche Daten werden da verarbeitet und so weiter. Geht das denn auch? Und das ist hier ein neues Paradigma, das eingezogen wird.
Allgemeiner könnte man sagen, den negativen Einfluss, den sozialen Netzwerken möglicherweise auf die gesellschaft, auf die politische Meinungsbildung ausüben. Und dazu ist es im Durchbruch von DSA, dass endlich nicht mehr auch wirklich die Mechanismen der Plattform in den Blick genommen werden, die demokratischen gesellschaften schaden und nicht nur immer einzelne Inhalte.
Das halte ich wiederum für ein echtes Highlight, wenn man sich anschaut. Einmal ist es passiert, dass irgendwie Trump da Unterstützung erfuhr und dann durch irgendwelche Werbemaßnahmen und so weiter. Und dass man dann das zum Anlass nehmen kann, sich das System selbst mal anzuschauen. Und nicht nur die einzelnen Werbeanzeigen, die dann in irgendeinem Archiv weggespeichert werden, um das nachzuvollziehen, sondern die ganze Funktionsweise selbst soll dann in den Blick genommen werden. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist ja auch viel effektiver. Wir haben diese ganze Debatte über Hass im Netz jetzt seit Jahren. Man kann es ja nicht mehr hören. Und dann geht es aber selten darum, dass man mal darüber nachdenkt, wie sind eigentlich diese Plattformen strukturiert, dass die ganze Zeit diese Hassinhalte nach vorne gespült werden, sondern man spricht dann lieber über einzelne Posts. Und da müsste man mal den verklagen und da müsste die Polizei einschreiten. Ich finde das alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Wenngleich ich auch und deswegen bin ich so froh, dass wir jetzt nicht diese Chat-Visite da bekommen. Wenngleich ich das auch sehr, sehr schwierig finde, dass wir jetzt so eine ganz komische Diskussion über Hass im Netz haben. Also es gibt natürlich Leute, die werden bedroht. Die bekommen Morddrohungen und so weiter. Aber wir können jetzt auch nicht so tun, als müssten wir eine gesellschaft haben, in der Hass keine Rolle mehr spielt, weil Hass auch wiederum etwas ist, was ganz schwer zu definieren ist. Also wann haben wir es dann mit Hass zu tun? Was mir jetzt zum Beispiel aufgefallen ist, ist, dass sehr viele Influencer Kritik an sich einfach als Hass jetzt als Hass im Netz deklarieren. Oder Sascha Lobo sagte, Influencer-Kritik ist dann gleich Frauen-Hass. Und was man eigentlich jetzt versucht, mit diesem Hassbegriff, ist sich vor jeglicher Kritik zu immunisieren. Und deswegen würde ich sagen, man muss gerade weggehen von diesen Inhalten. Und ich würde auch sagen, man muss unterscheiden zwischen Leuten, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, die was abbekommen, und Leuten, die nicht in der Öffentlichkeit stehen. Und das ist ja auch alles gesetzlich so festgeschrieben. Aber wir haben es diskursiv gerade damit zu tun, dass wann immer jetzt Kritik laut wird und auch mal scharfe, polemische Kritik, dann kommt schon gleich jemand, der darunter schreibt, bevorsicht, das ist aber jetzt Hass im Netz. Und wir waren uns ja immer mal wieder einig, manchmal kann Hass im Netz auch gut sein.
Genau, es ist eine nicht nur von den Inhalten abhängige Frage, wie man sich solchen Sachen umgeht, insbesondere wenn politische Entscheidungen folgen sollen. Patrick Breyer für die Piratenpartei im Europaparlament war hier bei heise.de, also Holger Bleich und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob es der Podcast war oder einfach, dass sie zum Anlass des gesetzes. Und er dimmt unsere Erwartungen auch noch mal ein bisschen klein. Aber wir haben ja dieses Sven-Gigold-Paradigma. Über die Zeit kann sich das ja auch noch bessern.
Neu eingeführt wurde auch die Pflicht, für sehr große Plattformen systemischen Risiken zu begegnen. Und damit gemeint sind nicht nur die Verbreitung illegaler Inhalte, sondern eben auch die Verbreitung schädlicher Inhalte, die legal sind, die aber Menschen schaden können. Stichwort Head Speech, Stichwort Disinformation und so weiter. Und die Plattformen werden auch verpflichtet sich, die sehr großen Plattformen werden verpflichtet, sich externen Audits zu unterziehen. Das sind also schon einige neue Elemente in diesem gesetz drin. Aber man merkt, es wird sehr stark auf Selbstregulierung gesetzt. Die Plattformen sollen sich selbst an der Prüfung unterziehen. Sie sollen selbst Abhilfemaßnahmen vorsteigen. Sie sollen freiwillig an verhaltenskodizes teilnehmen. dieser Ansatz ist sehr industriefreundlich. deswegen hat auch keine große Plattform protestiert, als dieser gesetzentwurf kam. Die sind alle sehr damit zufrieden.
Aber das kann sich ja noch ändern. Die Risikoeinschätzung ist jetzt da. Sie ist noch mehr Selbstkontrolle. Aber sobald da die Effekte so sind, kann man ja auch umentscheiden und sagen, wir gucken jetzt hier rein. Jetzt ist die Frage, wer? Genau. Und da gab es ein großes Gerangel. Es gibt ja in Deutschland die landesmedienanstalten, die sich auch um diese Kompetenzen bemühen, dann aber im gesetz eben thematisiert werden müssen. Wurden sie da nicht? Dann gab es auch die Frage, die DSP-Fraktion.
Das haben wir doch auch mal hier besprochen.
Das haben wir hier auch besprochen.
Da waren doch eher Leute, die auch sehr hinter dem Mond gelebt haben, wo wir uns schon dachten, und die handeln das dann mit Google und Facebook aus.
Genau. Und die wollen da jetzt noch mitspielen. Was soll denn das werden? Also die müssen ja diesen Schrift von Radio, Fernsehen dann zum diesen ganzen digitalen Kram dann machen. Dann ist natürlich auch eine Erfahrung aus der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, wenn man die Aufsicht nicht europäisch regelt, sondern trotzdem bei der irischen Datenschutzbeauftragten lässt und die aber finanziell nicht ordentlich ausgestattet ist, dann gibt da halt auch nichts. Dann haben wir zwar einen Anspruch in Deutschland bei den Iren in der Datenschutzbehörde, da irgendwas zu wollen von denen, aber das wird dann halt vertagt auf, keine Ahnung, man kriegt dann in drei Jahren und so weiter einen Termin. Das hat alles nicht so gut funktioniert. Also springt jetzt die EU-Kommission als oberste Aufsichtsbehörde ein. So, und dann hat Patrick Breyer aber auch wieder seine kritische Anmerkung zu machen.
Wir sehen ja zum Beispiel bei den Vertragsverletzungsverfahren, also welche EU-Staaten verklagt die EU-Kommission, weil sie EU-Recht nicht beachten, sehen wir eine stark politische Auswahl. Die Urteile gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind nie durchgesetzt worden. Kein EU-Mitgliedstaat wurde verklagt, weil er noch gesetze zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat. Und das hat ganz klar politische Gründe. deswegen ist es auch nicht nur gut, dass die EU-Kommission künftig für die Durchsetzung gegen die Großen zuständig ist, denn die Kommission ist ein politisches Gremium, kein unabhängiger Regulierungsbehörde. Und da wird politisch entschieden, in welche Richtung will man gehen und in welche Richtung nicht.
Brauchen wir eine EZB für das Internet, die einfach den Auftrag hat, Preisstabilität oder Datensicherheit, das ist dann jeweils für die Institutionen unterschiedlich und die sind aber dann unabhängig.
Ja, das ist so.
Und zugleich sind wir aber diejenigen, die sagen, schade, dass die EZB so unabhängig ist. Jetzt könnte eigentlich von der Leyen viel enger mit dir zusammenarbeiten. Also wir sind hier wieder in einem ganz heiklen Kosmos. Ich war jetzt auch, bevor ich jetzt den Clip von Breyer gehört habe, schon wieder innerlich am Plädieren für die Expertokratie. Denn hier zeigt sich immer in gewisser Weise, dass Expertenwissen sehr wichtig ist, um das zu machen. Das kriegt man auch nicht auf Marktplätzen hergestellt, was man da braucht, sondern das ist jetzt Expertenwissen, Kommissionen, die, Tagen und so weiter. Und jetzt aber gibt es natürlich da wieder diese politischen Implikationen, die angesprochen wurden. Und ich frage mich, ja, aber was wäre dann besser? Hier wird jetzt die Unabhängigkeit gesagt, aber wie unabhängig ist dann diese Unabhängigkeit?
Es ist alles super knifflig. Wir haben, deswegen, also du hast die EZB angesprochen, ich die BaFin, die Bankenaufsicht in Europa funktioniert ja auch ein bisschen so. Wir haben uns ja sehr gewundert bei Wirecard zum Beispiel. Ach so, die BaFin hat gar keine eigenen inhaltlichen Kompetenzen, sondern die beauftragt da nur, wenn sie selber den Verdacht hat, hier muss mal was gearbeitet werden, wir müssen mal was tun, die beauftragt dann auch nur wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften, die ihrerseits aber schon die unternehmen und so weiter. Also die Verstrickungen sind da so ein bisschen groß. Jetzt will man in der EU-Kommission eine sozusagen Unterbehörde mit eigener Kompetenz schaffen, weiß aber noch nicht genau, wo man sie so ansiedeln soll. Im Digitalkommissariat bei vestaka oder dann doch mehr bei Thierry Breton und so in der so Wirtschaftsregion ist alles ein bisschen knifflig und wenn man sich dann dafür entscheidet, kann man sie ja später immer noch auslagern, ausgliedern wie auch immer oder eben hausintern von der EU-Kommission die entsprechende Freiheit geben, da einfach handeln zu können. Patrick Breyer findet es auf der einen Seite blöde, dass wir eine politische Agentur da jetzt haben, die zum Beispiel Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also wenn der EUGH sagt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist nicht, dann ist der EU-Kommission das egal. Dann lässt sie einfach alle Länder trotzdem weiter gesetze zum Thema schreiben. Und das droht hier natürlich auch, dass da einfach politische Ansinnen durchgedrückt werden. Aber...
Weil die EU-Mitgliedsstaaten immer sehr schwierig sind, wenn es um zusätzliche Mittel geht, haben wir uns eine Lösung überlegt, nämlich eine Gebühr. Die sehr großen Plattformen sollen künftig also eine Gebühr leisten müssen. An die EU zahlen müssen, mit denen dann eben das nötige Personal auch hoffentlich dann finanziert werden kann. Ich weiß nicht, wo es angesiedelt wird. Ich denke, beim Digitalkommissar wäre es vielleicht noch besser aufgehoben als bei der Innenkommissarin. Aber die sind einerseits doch schon sehr industriefreundlich, aber sie verstehen wenigstens. Sie verstehen, worum es geht. Und das ist schon mal eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung.
Also immerhin, zwei Pluspunkte in der EU-Kommission. Gibt es Leute, die sich auskennen, denen könnte man das auch überlassen und da wäre auch er mit zufrieden. Und wenn man so einen Mehrbedarf oder so sieht, das sagt dann auch, können wir uns hier von Sven Giegold nochmal anhören. Wenn man einen Mehrbedarf sieht, kann man auch einfach von denen, die betroffen sind, da kontrolliert zu werden, eine höhere Gebühr einsammeln, so wie die Banken ja auch für die Bankenaufsicht bezahlen. Es ist also eine allgemeine Aufgabe, die aber nicht von allen bezahlt wird, sondern dann nur von den Banken. Und das droht hier dann den Unternehmen auch.
Wir haben jetzt eine europäische gemeinsame Aufsichtsstruktur. Und das Gemeinste an dem Ganzen ist, dass dadurch, dass die Selbstfinanzierung da ist, man nicht mal sagen kann, wir haben kein Geld dafür. Das wird nämlich dazu führen, dass wenn dort Bedarfe sind, die real sind, die entsprechenden Bedarfe auch finanziert werden.
So, wir können also hier so eine Zwischenbilanz ziehen. Wir haben jetzt ein gesetz, das wir noch nicht kennen, aber das es zumindest so gibt. Und so wie die hier darüber reden, gibt es da so eine Aufsichtsbehörde. Und die darf natürlich dann auch Ende erstrafen. Da kommen wir noch drauf, welche Beträge. Das ist so wie bei DSGVO ordentlich. Also so 6 Prozent des umsatzes weltweit und so weiter kann da an Sanktionen ziehen. Es gibt diese Begleitung. Unternehmen kriegen den festen Ansprechpartner. Man muss eine Risikoeinschätzung machen und so weiter und so fort. Daher können wir diesen Lawfare-Beitrag hier vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen locker sehen. Ja, wir wissen natürlich nicht genau, was wir dann bekommen. Erstmal sind es diese Wünsche. Aber es ist jetzt zumindest so eine Titanic da, die man jetzt anschieben kann irgendwie, um mal in diesem Bild zu bleiben. Was ist noch drin und was ist auch schwierig? Zum einen, es gibt ein Christchurch Paragraphen.
Sie haben besondere Beobachtungen, die so genannt Krisenprotokolls zu erhören. diese Dinge sind wie die Protokolle, die in der Wache der Tragödie in Christchurch entwickelt wurden, die Mechanismen, die in geheimen Situationen die Worte schnell auf Plattformen senden, hey, es ist etwas böses, es ist urgent, nimm es ab.
Also wenn der nächste Attentäter versucht, live zu streamen, sollen nicht nur die Unternehmen selbst, wir haben gehört, wie das bei Twitch und Facebook war, man hat dann einfach nur das Wort, also wirklich nur die Buchstabenfolge, Christchurch einfach mal gesperrt, weil man es nicht mehr einfahren konnte, wo das alles auftaucht. Also da ist auch Scott Galloway ganz, wird kaum funktionieren oder war es, also einer von diesen Kommentatoren, kann auch Jeff Jarvis gewesen sein. Es ist schwierig, diesen Live-Charakter, diesen Echtzeit-Charakter wieder einzufangen. Im gesetz ist es erst mal angelegt. Na mal sehen, ob dieses Ineinandergreifen von irgendwelche Polizeibehörden sehen irgendwas und dann soll sofort reagiert werden. Was auf jeden Fall kommt und da bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt, wie es dann technisch aussieht, ist die Interoperabilität für die messenger, die Patrick Weier hier nochmal hervorhebt.
Wir haben einen Teilerfolg erreichen können. Das ist großer Erfolg auch für uns Piraten, das im Digital Market Interoperabilität verpflichtend eingeführt wurde für messenger-dienste. Wir hätten es uns auch gewünscht für die sozialen Netzwerke. Das ist uns nicht gelungen, aber die marktbeherrschenden messenger-anbieter, also insbesondere WhatsApp, die müssen künftig Interoperabilitätsschnittstellen anbieten. Nun, das bedeutet konkret, ich kann von WhatsApp wechseln und trotzdem den Kontakt mit meinen Kommunikationspartnern halten.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was den Unternehmen noch einfällt, um das den Usern so schwer wie möglich zu machen. Und jetzt Shoshana Zubauf, riesiges Buch über den Überwachungskapitalismus. Diejenigen, die sich hier auskennen, weil sie mitverhandelt haben, also Alexandra geese und Patrick Bayer, müssen sich da leider ganz ernüchtert zeigen, was das Werbetracking angeht.
Das war für mich eines der wirklich großen Ziele, was wir in DSA erreichen wollten, diese Art von Überwachungswerbung ganz stark einzudämmen. Der Deal ist mittelmäßig. Wir haben ein Verbot, Werbung auszuspielen, die auf Profilbildung basiert, welche sich auf sensible Daten stützt. Sensible Daten sind zum Beispiel politische und sexuelle Orientierung, Gewerkschaftsgehörigkeit und Religion. Das hört sich auf den ersten Blick eigentlich ganz gut an, ist aber auch wieder rechtlich unklar, weicht ganz stark von dem ab, was das Parlament eigentlich gefordert hatte. Weil im Moment, wir hatten einfach gefordert, dass jegliche Form von Targeting auf der auf der Grundlage dieser sensiblen Daten verboten wird. Und diese komplexe Formulierung ist ein Kompromiss, der in die richtige Richtung geht, bei dem aber im Moment nicht klar wird, was für konkrete Auswirkungen auf die wirklichen Praktiken der Plattform in diesem Bereich haben wird.
Ja, ist natürlich ein bisschen blöde. Das war ja eigentlich das große Ziel dieses gesetzes, genau das zu unterwinden. Und jetzt nur die Gewerkschaftzugehörigkeit und die sexuelle Orientierung. Wer schreibt denn das überhaupt in sein Profil und wo? Also nur das daraus zu nehmen. Patrick Breyer, fast mit der gleichen Einschätzung.
Tatsächlich ist ein Großteil des Übels im Internet darauf zurückzuführen, auf dieses geschäftsmodell des Überwachungskapitalismus, dass man sein Geld damit verdient, Nutzer total zu überwachen, ihre Daten zu verkaufen und sie dann mit Werbebotschaften oder auch mit politischer Werbung manipulieren zu können. Und wir hatten ursprünglich überlegt, das Ganze zu verbieten, diese personalisierte, gezielte Werbung. Dann hatten wir überlegt, wenigstens eine leichte Wahlmöglichkeit einzuführen, indem man im Browser das Ein-für-alle-mal sich dagegen entscheiden kann. Das hat auch nicht geklappt. Dann hatten wir überlegt, zu erreichen, dass bei diesen Cookie-Banners Nein zu sagen, genauso einfach möglich wird, wie Ja zu sagen. Und auch das wurde tatsächlich nicht erreicht. Das heißt, es ist weiterhin sehr schwer, diesen Nein-Knopf irgendwo im Interface versteckt zu finden, weil das Dark-Patterns-Verbot massiv verwässert wurde. Und wie gesagt, das einzige ist im Bereich Minderjährige und im Bereich sensible Daten, wo Minieinschränkungen vorgenommen wurden. Wir müssen jetzt bei der noch ausstehenden E-Privacy-Reform, also der Reform der Verordnung über den Schutz unserer Privatsphäre in der elektronischen Kommunikation, da müssen wir jetzt massiv für den Mechanismus Do-Not-Track erkämpfen.
Zwei Anmerkungen dazu. Shoshana Zuboff schreibt ja in ihrem Buch darüber und nimmt einen historischen Vergleich, nämlich sie spricht von der Landnahme, vor allem von der Landnahme der Weißen, die nach Amerika gekommen sind. Und worum es ja hier geht, ist, dass man ein Land schon gewonnen hat, zwar nicht rechtlich eigentlich, man hat einfach Recht gesetzt, indem man sagt, das gehört nun zur ganz üblichen Praxis, dass man auf diese Weise Geld verdienen kann, indem man diese Daten erhebt und das dann entsprechend verkauft und dann wieder angepasste Werbung ausspielt. Und da sind wir, wenn wir mal bei der Landnahme bleiben, natürlich auch wieder bei der Wohnungsfrage. Man hat irgendwann mal entschieden, man kann doch eigentlich auch mit Boden spekulieren. Man kann einfach auch Boden kaufen, Bauland erschließen, es zehn Jahre prach liegen lassen und dann erst was darauf bauen und dann hat sich der Wert verdoppelt. Wir haben Möglichkeiten geschaffen, die dann politisch nicht eingehegt wurden und auch nicht eingehegt werden, dass Wohnraum, der knapp ist, immer teurer wird. Und all diese Dinge sind ja Fragen des politischen Willens, was man jetzt an so einem Detail sehr gut sehen kann. Denn was ja hier beschrieben wird von prior ist, dass man verschiedene Vorschläge hatte, auch konzessionen schon bereit war zu machen und trotzdem mit all dem nicht durchkam, weil man jetzt sagt, nein, dieser Wirtschaftszweig soll erhalten bleiben. Auf Teufel komm raus. Und das kann man ja nur mit Korruption oder so ähnlichem dann erklären, warum das überhaupt so gestützt wird. Denn das ist ja nicht ein wirtschaftlich wichtiges Feld, genauso wie Bodenspekulation ja den meisten Menschen in Deutschland nichts bringt. Das ist ja nicht irgendetwas, wo man sagen kann, das dient aber auch dem Allgemeinwohl oder das ist volkswirtschaftlich sinnvoll und genauso volkswirtschaftlich sinnlos ist es natürlich mit diesem Tracking. Und ich finde, da kann man wieder sehr gut dran erkennen, dass die interessenvertreter natürlich nur partikularinteressen häufig vertreten und hier einfach nur unternehmensinteressen vertreten, die meines Erachtens nur mit Dreh-Tür-Effekt oder sonst was zu erklären sind, dass man die überhaupt vertritt, denn da gibt es ja auch nicht jetzt irgendeine liberale Argumentation, die man anführen kann, warum das eigentlich gut ist, dass man in dieser Weise Werbung ausspielt. Man könnte aber vielleicht einen Schritt zurücktreten und sagen, ja, das ist alles sehr bedauerlich, wie das jetzt gelaufen ist, und dann aber sich noch mal die Frage stellen, wenn das das geschäftsmodell ist von den großen Plattformen. Und Google hat es ja quasi eingeführt, die anderen haben es nachgemacht, so beschreibt es zu Wolf. Wenn das das geschäftsmodell ist, dann heißt das ja noch nicht zugleich, dass es für uns als Konsument auch funktioniert. Und ich habe das schon mehrmals gesagt, aber ich stelle es ja immer wieder fest. Die Werbung, die mir angezeigt wird, trifft sehr häufig nicht zu auf mich. Also grundsätzlich nicht zu. Dass Dinge angezeigt werden, wo ich sage, die würde ich niemals kaufen. Und jeder, der mich auch nur entfernt kennt, ich würde fast sagen, jeder, der schon mal den Podcast gehört hat, würde nicht auf die Idee kommen, mir dieses Produkt zu schenken. Und da frage ich mich, wie effektiv sind die überhaupt? Ich will dir ein anderes Beispiel geben, das habe ich auch glaube ich schon mal erwähnt. In Mojgan für alle sprechen wir ja manchmal über Coaching und Bitcoin. Und natürlich bekommt fast jeder, der auf YouTube sich den Podcast ansieht, dann als erstes Coaching und Bitcoin-Werbung. Man kann aber davon ausgehen, dass die Leute, die das jetzt ausgespielt bekommen, garantiert nie auf so einen Finanzcoach hineinfallen. Das heißt, mich macht das in gewisser Weise glücklich. Das ist ja wirklich ein Kampf gegen den Kapitalismus, der da geführt wird, dass wir dieses Werbegeld einfach sinnlos abfließen lassen. Wir nutzen es und zugleich hat es aber nicht den erwünschten Effekt. Ich hatte auch schon mal darüber nachgedacht, weil manchmal bekommt man ja so Werbeanfragen, irgendeinen Unsinn. Und da sind ja so verlockende Angebote. Und jetzt habe ich mich entschieden, so was eigentlich in der Filmanalysen nicht zu machen. Und ich werde es auch nicht machen. Aber ich hatte irgendwann schon mal drüber nachgedacht. Eigentlich müsste man so ein Video mal drehen, wo man sich ja die Community richtet und sagt, so, ihr wisst, man muss ja auch das Ganze irgendwie finanzieren. Und Werbung, so eine Produktplatzierung hier, wäre eine Möglichkeit. Bitte kauft das Produkt nicht. Es ist vollkommener Unsinn. alles, was ich bewerben werde, ist Stuss. Ihr braucht auch diesen komischen Finanzvertrag nicht. Braucht ihr alles nicht. Ich mache das nur, damit das Werbegeld abfließt und seid gemeinsam mit mir subversiv und kauft einfach das nicht und druckt ja nicht auf den Rabattcode. Und dann würde man Werbung machen und bekäme das Geld zugespielt. Also in gewisser Weise frage ich mich, ob nicht eine Subversion auch für Hacker oder so noch mal darin liegt, also dass man wirklich diese Werbung, die es zwar gibt, zwar weiterhin hat nun, aber dass man sie mehr in Sackgassen laufen lässt.
Ja, also die Trennung von Verlag und Redaktion sollte dir ja so einen Stunt ermöglichen, denn als Werbepartner kannst du natürlich nur Reichweite buchen. Du entscheidest wo, aber dann nicht darüber, was da redaktionell geschieht. In der Hinsicht ist jeder Überraschung möglich.
Ja, ich werde es jetzt nicht anfangen, aber es wäre eigentlich eine schöne Idee, einfach das Werbegeld abgreifen und vorher noch mal allen sagen, bloß nicht auf die Werbung hören, die ich gleich angespreche.
Aber man kann auf jeden Fall diese Analogie, die du eben aufgegriffen hast, zum Wohnen. Seit 150 Jahren ist unklar, welchen volkswirtschaftlichen Beitrag eigentlich die Rendite auf Wohneigentum, das man nicht selber nutzt, sondern einfach nur, man vermietet drei Wohnungen in der Stadt B, lebt aber in Stadt A, also fließt dieses Geld einfach in Stadt A und die Miete ist so hoch, dass sich die Leute in Stadt B das gerade so leisten können, das heißt für die Supermärkte in Stadt B und die Veranstalter ist da weniger Geld da, weil die Budgets sind abgeflossen. Welchen volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen hat das? Und wir rätseln seit 150 Jahren und finden ihn einfach nicht, sondern partikularinteressen setzen sich da durch. Es ist halt einfach politisch entschieden, wie es entschieden ist. Es ist ja auch eine der größten Lobby-Schlachten überhaupt. Niemand bezahlt so viel Geld für Lobbyismus wie Google. Sie sind da absolute Führer und gleich dahinter kommen dann alle anderen. Amazon, wir haben es ja gelesen, wie sie sich da einkaufen, in Washington und Jeff Bezos präsentieren und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Frage, welchen volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen hat eigentlich, dass das ganze Werbegeld jetzt zentral zu Google nach Amerika fließt, ist genauso unbeantwortet. Wir können es einfach nicht sagen. Die deutschen Zeitungen und die europäischen Publikationshäuser haben weniger von dem Geld. Das heißt, es wird aus der lokalen Wirtschaft abgezogen. Der volkswirtschaftliche Nutzen ist, wenn, dann negativ zu bemessen. So, warum gibt es da keine gesetze dagegen? Also hier wäre wirklich was zu steuern. Hier gibt es ja was politisch zu entscheiden. Hier brauchen wir ja politische Programme. Und da können wir ja zumindest den letzten Clip hier Shoshana Zuboff gönnen. Denn als wir die Anhörung hörten, gab es ja auch einen jungen Demokraten, der von der Innovation Kill-Zone sprach. Also in dem Rahmen, wie die großen Player diese Werbegelder abziehen und auch das Personal von Start-ups aufkaufen, durch irgendwelche Fusionen und so weiter, fehlt es natürlich an Innovation. Da kann Eric Schmidt noch so häufig behauptet haben, wir sind ja nur Google. Es kann ja jeder mit einer tollen Idee kommen und schon sind wir auch geschichte. Nee, die kaufen das natürlich vorher auf, bevor es da gefährlich wird. So macht es ja Facebook auf. Auch haben wir alles gekauft, WhatsApp, Instagram sind gekaufte Sachen. tesla ist auch gekauft von Elon Musk, dass er da als Gründer gilt, stand ja auch erst nachträglich in Verträgen. Das hat er sich also gekauft, diesen Titel. Und Shoshana Supav eröffnet jetzt hier wieder die Innovationsmöglichkeiten. Aber mal sehen.
Wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, den Raum für Demokratie auch in Form der Innovation wieder zu öffnen. Es ist jetzt vorbei mit diesem Innovations-Blabla, bei dem es immer nur um Performance geht, aber letzten endes nur so mächtige Monopole in der Marktstruktur geschaffen werden, bei denen es immer nur um Verbrauch, Kaufen und Konsum ging.
Das ist natürlich der Traum des Internet seit Anbeginn, aber, ja, weiß, da können wir pessimistisch bleiben, glaube ich. Abschließender Gedanke, es gab einen sehr guten Text von Richard Gutjahr, der hängt hier auch in diesen ganzen Diskussionen so mit drin, hat so Hörerfragen gestellt bei der Heise-Show zum Beispiel, oder da als Beckett Dahl und Giegold und so weiter da alle zusammensaßen. Und bei gutjahr.biz hat er das noch mal runtergebrochen auf, darüber sprachen wir ja auch, wie Apple bei iOS 5 14.5 das ATT, das App Tracking, die App Tracking Transparency eingeführt hat. Also mit diesem Einhaken, ne, ich will nicht getrackt werden und das gilt jetzt für das ganze Gerät. Ich will das nicht jeder einzelnen App sagen, sondern es gilt für das ganze Gerät. Und dann hat sich ja Facebook Monate später beschwert, dass sie da einfach wirklich substanziell 30, 40 Prozent Umsatz verloren haben, da nicht mehr vorwärts kommen. Dafür hat Apple seine Werpe-Plattform da aufgebaut. Das haben wir ja auch im Salon mal besprochen, wie die da einfach profitiert haben, weil die sich natürlich jeden Zugriff auf die Daten gönnen, die sie den Drittanbieter nicht mehr gönnen, was ja dann auch wieder ein Antitrust-Problem ist, das ja soweit, wir haben es ja gelesen bei Globo-Char, alles thematisiert ist. Man muss es halt nur dann auch mal politisch entscheiden. Jetzt hat man in Europa was entschieden und naja, man kann mal abwarten, was daraus dann folgt. Ich würde sagen, die Sven-Giegolt-Logik in ein paar Jahren oder so wird dann mal ein bisschen bilanzgezogen und nachgesteuert. Mal schauen. China, wir wollen noch kurz über China reden, was heißt kurz. China ist ja wirklich ein mega Thema. Hier in Deutschland war das jetzt Doppelthema im Mai. Zum einen, weil die jingyang-police-files veröffentlicht wurden. Man kann das jetzt an vielen Orten, zum Beispiel über Spiegel Online, nachlesen. Es ist das größte League über staatliche Umerziehungslager in Jingyang, die es je in die Öffentlichkeit gelangt sind. Darin befinden sich Informationen über rund 300.000 Einwohner Jingyangs. Zum größten Teil gehören sie der muslimischen Volksgruppe der Uyghuren an. Der Datensatz landet bei dem deutschen Anthropologen und Chinerexperten Adrian Zenz, der Seniorfeller an der Victims of Communism Memorial Foundation in Washington DC ist. Zenz war schon in der Vergangenheit der wichtigste Aufdecker der Zustände in den Lagern von Jingyang. Also, die Dinger sind veröffentlicht, bestätigen im Grunde, was vorher schon immer geahnt wurde und auch aus Zeugenberichten zur Verfügung stand. Spiegel Online hat sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben, den Artikel ordentlich aufzubereiten, finde ich, denn man scrollt da so ein bisschen durch. Das ist einer dieser etwas kunstvollen Scroll-Dinger, wo man dann auch zwischendurch Bilder und hier und Satelliten und insbesondere interessant, weil es eben nicht nur um die inhaltliche Aufarbeitung geht, sondern sie auch die ganze Forensik mal mit erklären. Also es tauchen Bilder auf innerhalb der Gebäude und dann versucht man herauszufinden, wie breit sind denn die Gänge, die man da sieht, von innen fotografiert, dann nimmt man sich Satellitenbilder, guckt wo man in dieser breiten Gänge findet, steckt so ein Toleranzbereich ab und Schlussfolger dann, naja, das ist dieses und jenes Gebäude. Und dann ordnet man hunderte von Orten, wo man solche Lager vermutet, einfach mal zu und sieht dann eben was da drin passiert. Also dieses Matching ist sehr aufwendig gewesen, mehr als 30 Journalisten haben da weltweit dran gearbeitet, das ist nicht schlecht. Und der Deutschlandfunk hat die China Science investigation gemacht oder beziehungsweise hier veröffentlicht. Es sind mehrere europäische Medienhäuser, Follow The Money, Corrective, SZ, Deutsche Welle, Deutschlandfunk und so weiter. Das chinesische Militär arbeitet sehr eng mit deutschen Forschungseinrichtungen zusammen. Man hat sich mehr als 3000 Forschungskooperationen sich angeschaut. Auf der einen Seite geht es um, was weiß ich, simple Sachen wie irgendeine Optik oder so. Physiker tauschen sich auf und dann stellt sich heraus, damit bauen die chinesen dann in ihrer Universität, die Military im Namen trägt, und es ist hier keinem aufgefallen, dass man mit denen zusammenarbeitet, bauen die dann irgendwelche Überwachungstechnologie, wo sie noch mal gucken wollen, ob hier sich irgendwer irgendwo versteckt auf einem Platz, den man mit einem Video überwacht. Und lauter solche Sachen, Zielerkennung und so, alles Mögliche ist da möglich. Es hat irgendwie keine große Aufruhr in Deutschland gebracht, die wäre aber nötig, denn es ist die Frage, wo ist denn das eigentlich angesiedelt? Bettina Stark-Watzinger, unsere neue Bildungsministerin, sagt so, ja, Forschung ist doch freie Lehre, was die Unis machen, wissen wir doch nicht. Die Unis so, naja, sind ja die professoren, keine Ahnung, da haben wir ja auch kein Zugriff. Also niemand ist so richtig zuständig dafür, mal nachzuschauen, mit wem arbeitet man hier eigentlich und so. Aber dafür ist diese Forschung, Forschungskooperation relativ intensiv. Auf der anderen Seite wollen wir ja nicht diese große Trennung jetzt in dieser Forschungsinitiative haben. Also da gibt es noch einige Fragen zu beantworten.
Wir haben ein System kreiert, das sehr stark auf Drittmittel ausgelegt ist und da gilt natürlich das alte gesetz, Geld stinkt nicht und das nehmen dann auch Akademiker gern, wenn es auch aus Staaten wie China kommt. Das ist ja etwas, was schon seit Jahren immer mal wieder thematisiert wird. Aber an die Öffentlichkeit gerät es dann mal durch solche Enthüllungen, aber niemand beschäftigt sich wirklich damit. Also man kann da auch noch mal den Einfluss der sozialen Medien ganz gut dran sehen. Es gab ja da ganz interessante Zahlen von einer Plattform, die man sich angesehen hat, wie stark, oder eine Datenfirma, wie stark ist eigentlich die Interaktion bei gewissen Themen in den sozialen Medien, wenn Artikel erscheinen? Und die Untersuchung jetzt für die vergangenen Wochen sieht so aus, dass durchschnittlich 508 Social Media Interaktionen, also likes, Kommentare und shares, stattgefunden haben, bei einem Artikel, der sich um was drehte. Das ist also der Rekord, 508 Social Media Interaktionen im Durchschnitt, wenn irgendwas dazu gepostet wurde. Wobei könnte das gewesen sein, in den USA. Aber ich glaube, das würde hier gar nicht so viel anders aussehen.
Kann ja nur was popkulturelles sein, oder? Top Gun?
Johnny Depp und Amber Heard, der prozess natürlich. Dann nur noch 141 Interaktionen beim Thema Abtreibung und 44 Interaktionen beim Thema Covid. Und dann kann man ja mal schauen, ob irgendwo auch noch China aufgelistet ist. Habe ich jetzt hier zumindest nicht gefunden.
Genau. Und dann hören wir noch ein paar Clips zu den Police Papers aus China und schließen an, was wir vorhin häufiger schon als roten Faden hier für heute entdeckt haben, nämlich Merkels Erbe. Also am 24.05. unterrichtet unser Deutschlandfunk mit Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag und so weiter, überall, dass es diese Bilder jetzt gibt und dass man sie sich anschaut. Und sie haben dann am Ende mit den Menschenrechtsbeauftragten der CDU-Fraktion gesprochen, Michael Brandt. Wir lassen ihn uns mal vorstellen.
Über mögliche politische Konsequenzen aus diesen Enthüllungen habe ich kurz vor der Sendung mit Michael Brandt gesprochen. Er ist der menschenrechtspolitische Sprecher der cdu-csu-bundestagsfraktion.
So und der stellt jetzt fest, wir sind ja ganz schön eng verbandelt mit China.
Was würden Sie denn sagen, hat Deutschland China völlig falsch eingeschätzt?
Absolut. Also es gibt eine falsche Einschätzung bei der Vorgängerregierung und bei der jetzigen Regierung. Mit einer stummen Haltung werden wir grundlegende Freiheiten beim Thema Menschenrechte nicht verteidigen. Es braucht Courage und Stehvermögen. Und ich wundere mich auch über die Außenministerin, dass sie jetzt nach diesen Berichtern Fassungslosigkeit zeigt und anschließend erklärt, China müsse sich jetzt positionieren. Genau andersrum wird ein Schuh raus. Wir müssen uns endlich positionieren.
So, er ist also im Verlauf des gesprächs ganz froh, dass es jetzt Annalena Baerbock gibt, die sich naja so äußert, dass sie halt erst mal von China jetzt Erklärung haben will. Was hat sie damit auf sich und gibt es von euch irgendwas? Oder sollen wir jetzt mit politischen Forderungen oder sowas kommen?
Und wir können uns gleich als Stimme im Ohr immer Peter Altmaier vorstellen. Nehmen wir mal an, wir hätten noch die Union an der Regierung und er bekommt dann eine solche Frage gestellt. Haben Sie das dann da schon gesehen, was da aufgedeckt wurde mit China? Und ich bin mir sehr bewusst, wird er dann sagen, dass wir über Werte vermehrt sprechen müssen. Aber ich sage Ihnen auch, wir haben eine Verantwortung den Menschen vor Ort gegenüber. Und damit müssen wir auch versuchen, dass wir über den Weg des Handels einen Wandel erzielen.
Ja, also VW hat ja auch Produktionsstätten dort. Und die selbst hat jetzt schon gesagt, es ist besser, wenn wir dort sind, als wenn wir nicht da wären. Das hilft den Uiguren. Du hast es jetzt im Sinne von, was wäre wenn? Der Industriearm der CDU ist ja noch da. Und der sagt das genauso. Also die sind da ganz entschieden. Und der Michael Brandt, der Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der CDU, in diesem gespräch sagt er eigentlich ganz wunderbar, wenn auch nur aus Versehen, wo die Versäumnisse sind. Aber nicht von Annalena Baerbock, sondern von Angela Merkel.
Falls China nicht ja sagt und nachgibt und einsehen zeigt, würden sie sagen, dann auch Exportstops und Schließung deutscher Unternehmen?
Ja, natürlich müssen wir auch Konsequenzen ziehen, indem wir bestimmte Deals dann nicht machen. Was ist denn die Alternative, dass wir sagen, weil unsere Wirtschaft brummt, nehmen wir in Kauf, dass eine Million Menschen interniert werden und die Uiguren und andere ausgelöscht werden. Wir reden auch über die Tibeter. Derjenige, der in Xinjiang verantwortlich ist, war vorher in Tibet. Wir haben über 80 Millionen Christen in China, die unterdrückt werden. Das sind mehr Menschen, als bei uns in unserem Land, in Deutschland leben.
Ja, schön. interessantes Fazit.
Herr Rosse-Wurm ist dann nicht so begeistert vom BDI. Der hat schon gesagt, dass es so einfach geht, das nicht. Und das bedeutet auch ganz klar Wohlstandseinbußen hier für uns, wenn das gemacht wird. Also da muss man noch mal auf Thomas Fischer verweisen, für wie viele Opfer ist man bereit zu bringen, ja, was geht und was geht nicht. Und deswegen würde ich da sagen, es ist genau der richtige Weg, das jetzt zu thematisieren. Aber mein Problem bei der ganzen Sache ist, es ist unglaublich schnell wieder vergessen. Also das ist jetzt so ein Thema Uiguren, das erreicht dann sogar manchmal insta-stories bei den Influencern, dass sie das mal irgendwie mitbekommen haben. Aber dann spielt es doch wieder keine größere Rolle.
Genau, hier liegt ein echtes Problem vor. Man müsste eigentlich mal so richtig rein ins Thema. Und am Ende des gesprächs bleibt da Michel Brandt auch nur übrig, nochmal explizit die Merkel-Regierung zu kritisieren. Und das ist es dann auch im Grunde.
Muss man auch sagen, Ihre Partei hat schwere Fehler gemacht?
Absolut, auch da gab es Fehleinschätzung gegenüber Russland und China. Nur hilft uns das heute überhaupt nicht mehr weiter. Wir stehen in einer historischen Auseinandersetzung, in einem Systemwettbewerb. Und da hilft es nicht, Parteipolitik zu machen. Ich selbst habe im Übrigen für die Unionfraktion meine Meinung nicht danach orientiert, ob wir in der Opposition und der Regierung sind. Ich habe auch die Kanzlerin Angela Merkel immer sehr deutlich, wenn es notwendig war, kritisiert und auch intern meine Position wie andere auch, Norbert Röttgen und viele andere, immer wieder auf die tagesordnung gebracht. Aber es hilft uns eins nicht, jetzt, wenn eine neue Regierung da ist, sozusagen lauthals über wertebasierte Außenpolitik zu sprechen. Alle zeigen sich entsetzt, der Finanzminister, der Außenminister. Aber die Frage stellt sich doch, ja, was tut ihr denn jetzt eigentlich und wie sieht die Neuorientierung aus?
So, wenn Brandt hier die Kommunikation kritisiert, dann möchte ich aber auch seine Kommunikation kritisieren, denn es handelte sich durchaus nicht um eine Fehleinschätzung. Nur, weil jetzt noch ein paar Details bekannt sind, und Journalisten in akribischen Recherchen und dank sehr guter Hacker noch mal konkret machen können, wie schlimm es ist. Sind diese Informationen bekannt? Wahrscheinlich weiß die bundesregierung mehr als uns lieb ist, weil die ja auch Geheimdienste haben. Und das ist keine Fehleinschätzung, sondern das ist ein, ich weiß es nicht, pragmatischer Umgang, wie immer man das nennen möchte, mit der Tatsache. Also es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, ach so, das hätten wir gar nicht gedacht. Das war eine Fehleinschätzung für uns. Also eine Fehleinschätzung war vor 20 Jahren, zu glauben, dass das mit dem Wandel durch Handel tatsächlich funktioniert. Aber das konnte man ja spätestens 2010 sehen. Und spätestens mit Xi an der Macht, dass das auf China nicht zutrifft. Also da musste man ja beide Augen zumachen, um das nicht zu sehen.
Ja, also wir haben es ja mit einer politischen Entscheidung zu tun, die im Lichte allem, was man wissen kann und wissen muss, da getroffen wurde. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir über Jingyang genauso bescheid wissen wie über die Ukraine. Wir haben einfach Augen von oben und können eins plus eins zusammenrechnen. Es ist nur nicht alle bescheid, sondern das ist dann politisches Wissen.
Nur einen. Es lohnt sich im Übrigen, das mal nachzuvollziehen, wenn man sich für diese neue Form des Journalismus, denn das ist es ja interessiert. Es gibt diesen Podcast jetzt Weltmacht China von öffentlich-rechtlichen asien-korrespondenten. Und da ist auch jemand zu Gast, der an dieser Recherche beteiligt war und der mal genau sagt, wie sie da vorgegangen sind, wie auch gesichter verifiziert wurden, also wie da mit modernster Technik gearbeitet wurde. Also wer sich für diesen journalistischen Zweig interessiert, der kann da viel erfahren.
Genau, da wurde insgesamt ganz gut gearbeitet. Und nur einen Tag später, am 25. Also das war ein gespräch, das wurde am 24. Abends dann so aufgenommen im Lichte der tagesereignisse und nur einen Tag später im Heuterschönerl.
China-Staatschef Xi Jinping hat Kritikern vorgeworfen, sich in innere Angelegenheiten seines landes einzumischen. Der Verweis auf Menschenrechte sei ein Vorwand. Ihre universelle Gültigkeit stellte er in Frage. In einer Videokonferenz mit UN-Menschenrechtskommissarin Bachelet sagte Xi Jinping, Länder müssten ihren passenden Pfad der Menschenrechte erkunden. Bachelet will diese Woche die Provinz Xinjiang besuchen, wo nach Angaben von Menschenrechtlern hunderttausende muslimische Uiguren in Umerziehungslagern festgehalten und auch gefoltert werden.
Das ist hochinteressant und das kann man sich schon mal für den Salon merken, dass sich Xi hier auf die Menschenrechte bezieht, dann aber sagt jeder muss seine eigene Vision der Menschenrechte haben. Womit es ja keine Menschenrechte mehr sind. Da wir ja alle Menschen sind, können sie nur in universell sein. Da kann man nicht sagen, ja aber Mensch, der 1000 Kilometer weiter lebt, hat andere Menschenrechte. Nein, Menschenrechte sind natürlich nur universell möglich. Und das ist etwas, was Slavoj Šicek in seinem Text auch richtig herausarbeitet. Das ist also mit den neuen Blöcken, die sich da bilden, gerade mit China und Russland, darum geht, dass man sagt, wir relativieren alles, wir lassen den Universalismus nicht mehr zu und dann findet jeder seinen Umgang damit und wir lassen uns vom westen nichts mehr sagen. Da ist wirklich Obacht angesagt, denn es gibt ja diese Kritik am westlichen Blick, am Eurozentrismus und oft darüber weggefegt wird dann auch, wenn es um die Menschenrechte geht, dass man sagt, die wickeln wir auch noch gleich mit ab. Das ist ja so eine europäische Erfindung, weil die ja von europäischen Boden sind. Das wurde ja mal um 18 Jahrhundert. Und wenn man das anfängt zu machen, also wenn man den Universalismus dann auch glaubt, mal schnell historisieren zu müssen und damit über Bord zu werfen, dann kommt man genau dabei heraus, dass man sagt, ja, dann sind für die einen das Menschenrechte, für die andere das und dann können wir auch alle nichts mehr sagen. Dann lebt man so nebenher, hofft, dass es nicht allzu wild wird, dass man sich nicht die Köppe einschlägt. Aber sonst kann dann jeder machen, was er will. Und eine Großmacht kann sowieso immer tun, was eine Großmacht tut. Und da sind wir in einem ganz, ganz heikenden Gefilde angekommen. deswegen, wer postkolonial argumentieren will, darf nicht den Universalismus aufgeben.
Genau. Oder ein guter Lehrer werden. Mein Sozialkundelehrer, ich erinnere daran, wenn es nicht für alle ist, dann ist es nichts. Also dann haben wir es mit anderer Politik zu tun. Die Michelle Bachelet war also als UN-Hochkommissarin für Menschenrechte auf Tour in China, da oben in Xinjiang. Und zwei Tage später ist das hier die Berichterstattung.
Sechs Tage war Michelle Bachelet in China unterwegs, unter anderem in der Region Xinjiang, der Heimat der Uiguren. Doch Medienvertreter durften sie dabei nicht begleiten. Auf der heutigen abschlusspressekonferenz hielt sie sich mit direkter Kritik an China zurück. Während meines besuchs versicherte mir die Regierung, dass das Lagersystem aufgelöst worden sei.
Ich habe die Regierung ermutigt, alle Maßnahmen zur Terrorismusbekämpfung und Deradikalisierung zu überprüfen, damit sie Menschenrechtsstandards entsprechen und nicht willkürlich und diskriminierend sind.
Vertreter der Uiguren zeigten sich enttäuscht von den Worten der UN-Hochkommissarin. Journalistische Recherchen hatten gerade erst, dass Ausmaß der Menschenrechtsverletzungen erneut belegt.
Ja, ich guck mal, ob ich in diesem Clip, es gab da noch eine Szene, die war so abenteuerlich. Ach so, Ulf Röller hat diese Berichterstattung gemacht. Hier in dem Clip ist es drinne. Sie ließ sich noch ein Buch schenken.
Als junge Frau hat Michelle Bachelet Selbstfolter erlebt. Ihre Familie fiel in Ungnade während der Pinochet-Diktatur in Chile. Sie und ihr Vater wurden eingesperrt. Nun ist sie die Menschenrechtskommissarin der UN und in China unterwegs. Man hätte sie gerne zu ihrer Vergangenheit befragt, aber die chinesen schirmten sie ab. Bachelet ließ sich ein Buch zum Menschenrechten schenken, das Präsident Xi selbst geschrieben hat.
Also Xi hat ein Buch über Menschenrechte geschrieben und hat es dann ihr, während sie auf der Tour war, um sich das dann nochmal fortan zu schauen, noch geschenkt hat. Das ist natürlich eine Art von Demütigung, die einen wirklich auch ein bisschen traurig macht. Auf der anderen Seite, was sollen die Vereinten Nationen jetzt machen?
Wenn ich dieses Buch gerne lesen würde, dann muss man mal gucken, ob das ins Englische übersetzt ist, denn das ist hochinteressant, wenn man da mal eine Auskunft von Xi hat, was er so denkt. Man hat ja diese drei Bände mit seinen Reden. Das ist schon ganz erhellend, aber wenn es dieses Buch wirklich gibt, auf Englisch, dann wäre das auf jeden Fall mal ein Salonkandidat.
Genau, das haben sie sicherheitshalber Podcasts auch noch mal betont. diese Xi, also man hat wenig Zugang zu chinesen gerade, auch in der Forschung und so weiter, weil es gibt keine Konferenzen. China ist Covid-mäßig abgeriegelt, aber sie senden viel über diese Bücher, über diese Texte, über diese Reden und die soll man auch alle lesen. Da steckt doch einiges drin. In der Hinsicht würde ich auch sagen, dieses Buch von Xi, was hier da noch feierlich überreicht wurde, scheint eins zu sein, dass man sich dann mal anschauen kann. Naja, ein Clip hätte ich noch, bevor du uns... Das ist auch so eine Art Brückenschlag. Das waren jetzt so Themen, die nicht den großen Krieg oder so befassen, sondern so dieses Klein-Klein, diese ideologischen Scharmützel, die China überall macht.
Wir haben noch gar nicht über die Lockdowns gesprochen in China, über den Lockdown da in Shanghai. Das sind ja ungeheure Bilder, die man dort sehen kann. Die korrespondenten, auch da muss man wieder das öffentlich-rechtliche, das Radio sehr loben, was dort die korrespondenten erzählen, wie sie dann selbst unter diesen Quarantänen leiden, große Angst haben, mal positiv getestet zu werden, damit man ja gleich da abgeholt. Und das ist alles so erschütternd, dass jetzt im Welt-Spiegel gab es da auch einen Beitrag. So ist es, viele Arbeiter in die Firmen ziehen und diese nicht mehr verlassen, dort dann leben, um ein bisschen Produktion wieder zu ermöglichen. Es sind katastrophale Bilder. Und auch die große Frage, warum Xi das eigentlich macht. Es gibt ja verschiedene thesen. Für mich ist die einzige momentan wirklich interessante these, ob es um, wenn man, also es scheint ihm ja irgendwie wichtig zu sein. So die Systeme sind anders, Menschenrechte und so. Und nun hat ja China tatsächlich gezeigt anfangs bei der Pandemie. Wir greifen richtig hart durch, aber wir haben auch so gut wie keine Toten. Und wir machen dann hier Siro-Covid. Und das war ja am Anfang das, was bei uns eher zögerlich war. Hammer and Dance und die Hammer waren natürlich nicht so hart wie bei China. Aber damit ist man eine Zeit lang gut gefahren und hat damit den System Vorteil herausgearbeitet, was ja auch oft in Talkshows in Deutschland kommuniziert wurde. So ja, wir blicken immer so arrogant nach Asien, aber guckt mal, wie die das machen. Und dies wäre nun natürlich jetzt ein ungeheures zugeständnis. Nein, das liberaldemokratische System ist doch besser und es hat die besseren Impfstoffe. Die wollten ja selbst mRNA-Impfstoffe produzieren, haben das bis heute nicht geschafft. Kann sein, dass mal jetzt bald irgendwann was zugelassen wird, aber haben es bis heute nicht geschafft. Sind aber zu fein, sich jetzt die Impfstoffe von uns geben zu lassen. Und jetzt muss man eigentlich diese Linie weiter durchpeitschen, damit man beweisen kann, dass man das bessere System ist und auch die besseren Menschenrechte und was weiß ich hat. Und ich glaube, dass es wirklich nur noch diese ideologische Frage gibt, die so vehement ist, dass man damit auch bereit ist, eine Volkswirtschaft zu ruinieren, was ja verwunderlich ist, während wir ja hier dann doch, zum Beispiel in Deutschland, immer noch die Politiker haben, die sagen, gut, aber am wichtigsten ist uns das BIP. Du hast es ja auch bei der NRW-Wahl gesehen, es geht am Ende darum, dass sich der Unionskandidat an das gerade anpasst, was so in der Schwebe ist, wonach man gerade gut greifen kann und was ankommt. Und dann wird das irgendwie gemacht. Aber das ist ja keine ideologische Ausrichtung mehr. Der wird ein paar rote Linien irgendwo haben, wenn man länger sucht, aber eigentlich ist es auch egal.
Ja, das ist die Söderisierung der Politik, dass man einfach alles, vom Asyl-Tyrismus und ein Tag später rettet man plötzlich die Bienen. Hauptsache, man trifft irgendwie gerade so den Wind, der weht.
Das scheint hier nicht der Fall zu sein.
Genau, das ist wirklich eine ideologische Falle, in der China da sitzt. Sie haben sich da selber reinmanövriert. Und jetzt schlagen sie so ein bisschen um sich. Und der Reinhard Bütikofer, der ja seit einer Weile für die Grünen im Europaparlament arbeitet, hat hier eine interessante Verwendung des wortes Gewalt. Er breitet den Begriff mal so ein bisschen aus. Das war mein Eindruck am 24. 5. in den tagesthemen gehabt.
Ich teile die Befürchtung, dass dieses Regimenpicking keineswegs ein friedliebendes ist. Es ist auch schon Gewalt angewendet worden, nach außen. Nicht jetzt in jüngster Zeit militärische, aber die Tatsache, dass China zum Beispiel versucht hat, Litauen ökonomisch zu erpressen, dass China versucht, Australien ökonomisch zu erpressen, versucht hat, Schweden, die Tschechische Republik oder Norwegen so unter Druck zu setzen. Das ist ja schon auch Gewalt und Picking hat. Immer deutlich gemacht, dass man sich vorbehält, im Zweifel auch einen militärischen Überfall auf Taiwan zu organisieren. Ich glaube nicht, dass China soweit ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das unmittelbar droht. Aber es ist schon auch unsere Aufgabe, die Solidarität mit dem demokratischen Taiwan deutlich zu stärken.
Ja, der Gewaltbegriff ist hier nicht schlecht verwendet so insgesamt. Denn das ist es im Grunde. Es ist so eine Ersatzhandlung für kriegerische Auseinandersetzung, die aber die gleichen Ziele verfolgt. Eroberungen und so weiter. Vormachtstellung ausbauen, ideologische Sachen verankern. Und das durchzieht doch dieses chinesische Handeln so auf vielen, vielen Ebenen.
Das ist eine ideale Überleitung. Denn man kann natürlich auch mit Schamützen, die nicht direkt militärisch sind, sich in irgendeiner Weise dann doch kriegerisch an irgendetwas gütlich tun. Und wir springen jetzt mal zu den Pazifik-Inseln. Denn auch da ist in den vergangenen Wochen viel passiert. Das haben wir medial nur ein bisschen aufbereitet bekommen. Nicht so stark, wie es eigentlich müsste. Und gerade kann man das immer ganz gut vor dem Hintergrund des Ukraine-Kriegs sehen, was Putin sich da immer so mehr genommen hat und ertreistet hat. Und irgendwann geht er dann zum Angriff über. Und jetzt blicken wir mal nach China. Worum geht es da eigentlich? Da gab es eine sehr gute Arte-Doku zu, die das Grundproblem uns ein bisschen markieren wird.
Gleich zu Beginn seiner Amtszeit im Jahr 2012 brachte Xi Jinping alle chinesischen Seebehörden zusammen, um eine einheitliche strategische marine Streitkraft zu gründen.
Um eine Seemacht zu werden, muss China jedoch zunächst ein geografisches Handicap überwinden. Die gesamte chinesische Küste hat keinen Zugang zum offenen Meer. Er wird von mehreren Inseln behindert, die sich von den japanischen Hauptinseln im Norden, über Okinawa und Taiwan bis zu den Philippinen im Süden erstrecken. diese Inseln sind seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg alle mit den USA verbündet. Derart eingekesselt zu sein, will Peking nicht mehr hinnehmen.
Die kommunistische Partei Chinas sieht diese erste Inselkette auch sinnbildlich als ihre Türklingel, ihre Haustüre an. Sie muss diese Eingangstür kontrollieren und den Schlüssel dafür in Händen halten.
Zuletzt würden wir ins Panel. Das ist der Leiter des nachrichtendienstes der US-Pazifik-Flotte. Und wie geht China nun vor?
Das ist ja echt interessant. Ich habe ja nie drüber nachgedacht. China kein Zugang zum offenen Meer.
Und wenn man sich auf die Karte guckt, denkt man, das war eine wiese, was da da war.
Stimmt. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Erkenntnis, dass Mailand auf der Höhe von New York liegt. Irgendwann denkt man so, echt stimmt? Ja, stimmt. New York ist einfach wahnsinnig weit im Süden. Die haben nur keinen Golfstrom, deswegen ist es da unser Klima, obwohl es hunderte Kilometer südlicher liegt. Und jetzt, wo man sich die Karte hier von China anschaut, ja, es ist einfach von Südkorea. Also da ist einfach sehr viel Japan, Taiwan. Dann sind da diese, man sieht bei Google Maps so ein bisschen diese Verklüftungen auch unter Wasser. Genau und interessant. Da hab ich noch gar nichts mir so vergegenwärtig.
Nun können die ja nicht einfach irgendwo einmarschieren, aber man hat da eine Strategie gefunden.
diese Profimilitzen haben ihre Kunst der Einschüchterung perfektioniert, die so sorgsam ausgearbeitet ist, dass es keiner Waffen bedarf. Ihre Einsätze zur See verlaufen koordiniert in mehreren Etappen. Zuerst wird eine Truppe von Fischern vorgeschickt, um ein ausländisches Schiff zu blockieren, das sich nicht allein verteidigen kann. Bei Komplikationen ist die Küstenwache Chinas bereit, einzuschreiten und die chinesische Marine zu informieren, die ebenfalls alarmbereit in der Nähe ist. diese Aufgabenverteilung hat sich erstmals 2014 bei der Verteidigung einer chinesischen Ölplattform bewährt, die in den strittigen Gewässern vor Vietnam bohrte. Innerhalb von zwei Monaten kam es zu 300 absichtlichen Zusammenstößen. Ein vietnamesisches Schiff wurde versenkt. Doch heute ist das Geheimnis dieser Strategie enttarnt. Als 2021 in einer ausschließlichen Wirtschaftszone der Philippinen 200 Fischkutter vor einer kleinen Insel aneinander gebunden werden, hat man in Manila endgültig genug.
Das heißt, da werden die ganze Zeit schon Konflikte ausgetragen. Minimal Konflikte, auch dann nicht uniformiert, sondern wir machen das mal über Fischer. Und dann werden wir jetzt im Folgenden sehen, dass man auch mit den Inseln im Pazifik versucht, ähnlich umzugehen. Wir haben Ende April schon mitbekommen, wir haben es nur nicht hier thematisiert, dass die Salomonen für China wichtiger werden, dass man da so einen Pakt geschlossen hat, um besser zusammenzuarbeiten, wirtschaftlich zu fördern. Es geht da sehr viel um Ökologie, Nachhaltigkeit, Klimawandel. Auf den Salomonen leben 700.000 Menschen, die im Übrigen gar nicht so begeistert davon sind. Aber die Regierung ist dafür, auch weil sie sich von Australien vernachlässigt fühlt. Also das tut sich jetzt gerade schon. Also da werden schon Allianzen jetzt geschmiedet. Und darin vorgesehen ist dann auch, dass man durchaus auf den Salomonen auch mit Sicherheitskräften, mit chinesischen Sicherheitskräften dort, wenn irgendeine Bedrohungslage da ist, rumlaufen kann. Also es bleibt alles sehr im Wagen. Also man sagt natürlich jetzt nicht, wir stationieren da militär. Aber so diese ganzen Graubereiche, die es da so gibt, und derer sind viele, die können wir da jetzt erleben. Wir können das auch erleben beim Thema Aufrüstung. Es kommen jetzt ein Vize-Admiral der französischen Marine zu Wort und noch einmal james Fanel.
Über Aufrüstung freut man sich auch in Frankreich, aber gleich drei Kriegsschiffe.
Chinas Fortschritt ist beeindruckend.
Anfangs waren es Patrouillenbote, dann Korvetten, dann Fregatten und nun Zerstörer und Flugzeugträger.
Der Fortschritt der letzten 20 Jahre in China ist bemerkenswert. Aus einer simplen Küstenmarine ist heute die größte Marine der Welt geworden. Und sie wächst immer weiter. Wo die USA ein Schiff bauen, kommen die chinesen auf vier.
Jetzt können wir nochmal ganz kurz dieses Taiwan-Thema aufgreifen, das Bütikova schon angesprochen hat, auch nochmal der Artebericht.
Wenn es China gelingt, Taiwan einzunehmen, würde das ein großes Loch in diese erste Inselkette schlagen. Die Volksbefreiungsarmee würde die Insel dann kontrollieren und befestigen, so wie sie es auch mit den kleineren Inseln im südchinesischen Meer getan hat. China würde von dort aus operieren und weiter in den Pazifik und nach Japan vorstoßen können.
Das wäre das Ende der USA im asiatisch-pazifischen Raum.
Sie würden keine Rolle mehr spielen, weil vor allem ihre Glaubwürdigkeit zerstört wäre.
Wenn sie erst einmal aus dem westlichen Pazifik vertrieben wären, könnten die chinesen früher oder später an die westpiste der USA vorstoßen.
Es geht bei dieser Solidarisierung mit der Bevölkerung in Taiwan selbstverständlich nicht um die Bevölkerung in Taiwan vielmehr, sondern wir haben es hier ganz klar von Geostrategen skizziert bekommen, einmal von einem Australischen und einmal von james Fannell, darum, dass der westen seine Vormachtstellung verlieren würde auf See, wenn Taiwan eingenommen werden könnte. Bis dahin ist es sicherlich noch ein weiter Weg oder es muss auch vielleicht nie dazu kommen, aber es tut sich dann in anderen Regionen schon sehr viel. Und wir hören jetzt mal einen Beitrag von CBS zum Thema Sicherheitsabkommen mit den Salomonen-Inseln.
China and the Solomon Islands this week agreed to a controversial security deal. Now the nation is located in the South Pacific, a little more than 2,000 miles east of Australia. It's in the middle of a vital shipping region. It's packed with China would allow Beijing to send police and military personnel to the nation and China could also port some of its warships there.
Es wird jetzt auch klarer nochmal, warum Olaf Scholz auch mal nach Japan jetzt als erstes gefahren ist. Gut, Merkel ist immer nach China, das wäre jetzt sowieso wegen der Lockdowns schwierig. Aber wir sehen schon, Japan kann nochmal in sehr wichtiger Verbündeter werden, nicht nur wirtschaftlicher Art, sondern auch was die sicherheitsinteressen anbelangt. Und was sind denn nun die interessen Chinas? Hier nochmal CBS.
So warum ist China so interessiert in den Solomon Islands? Für eine sehr lange Zeit wissen wir, dass China versucht, die Influenz auszuweichen und ihre Macht auszuweichen. Es ist wichtig, dass die Solomon Islands zwischen Australien und den USA sind.
Das sind sehr kontrollierte Absatzmärkte, die man bedient, die eigenen Soldaten auszurüsten. So wie auch diese Vormachtstellung, wenn man auf Taiwan ist, ist man auch ganz schnell an der westküste der USA. Ich würde sagen, wenn man auf Taiwan ist, hat man erst mal diese ganze Chip-Produktion in der Hand und hat so ein richtiges erpresserpotenzial der Welt gegenüber und so weiter. Schon allein, weil man dann so ausfuhrbestimmungen regeln kann, was die Insel Taiwan betrifft.
Ja, wir springen ein bisschen zu Cyrus Jansen. Das ist ein Pro-China-Influencer, so würde ich ihn mal beschreiben. Er macht so einen YouTube-Kanal und wir hören uns mal an, was er zu sagen hat.
Also dieser Influencer-Zuarbeitung kommt, wie man ihn motiviert, da so rumzustöbern und dann sich so an Guardian-Texten abzuarbeiten, um nochmal zu betonen, dass die chinesen aber immer sehr drauf achten, dass es auch im interesse der Länder ist, was da passiert.
Ich glaube, die Antwort auf deine Frage ist sehr simpel. Sie heißt viel, viel Geld.
Aber muss ja mega viel Geld sein.
Jedoch spricht er hier einen Punkt an, der nicht von der Hand zu weisen ist, den Australien auch zugibt. Denn Penny Wong, die Außenministerin, die Neue von Australien, hat sich gesagt, oh, jetzt ist gerade der Außenminister von China da unterwegs und macht, die macht ja so eine fröhliche Tour zu den Pazifik-Inseln. Der ist ja Kiribati, den Salomonen, Samoa, Fiji, Tonga, Vanuatta, Papua, Neuginea und timor-leste. Ich hab's mir natürlich aufgeschrieben, nicht auswendig gelernt. Da ist er gerade und sie macht jetzt quasi so die Gegentour und war dann auch auf den Fiji-Inseln und ist da weiter unterwegs, um quasi so ein Gegenprogramm zu machen, zu sagen, bitte, ja, wir haben euch zu lange vernachlässigt und wir sind wieder bei unserem großen Über-Thema. Es geht natürlich um den Klimawandel, dass Australien sich nicht darum geschert hat, was mit diesen kleinen Inseln, die natürlich sofort vom Klimawandel bedroht sind, eigentlich geschieht. Und wir hören jetzt die pressekonferenz von Penny Wong.
I acknowledge that, and I understand that under past governments, Australia has neglected its responsibility to act on climate. Ignoring the calls of our Pacific family to act. disrespecting Pacific nations and their struggle to adapt to what is an existential threat. The triple challenges of climate, Covid and strategic contests will challenge us in new ways. We understand that the security of any one Pacific family member rests on the security of all. And we have a collective responsibility as we face these challenges to secure our region's interests today and in the future.
Ja, diese collective responsibility, von der sie spricht, vielleicht schlummert darin ja nochmal ein Potential, so wie wir das eben auch mit Europa und Afrika und so betont haben. Denn es ist ja die gleiche Art der Vernachlässigung, immer nochmal diesen kleinen, partikularen Vorteil daraus ziehen, aber dieses große Bild einfach nicht sehen wollen, bis es dann mit einem Mal einfach da liegt und man sieht, Mist, das haben wir echt blöd gemacht.
Und auch Biden ist unterwegs. Er ist in Südkorea und sagt folgendes.
So viel für die Zukunft des weltes wird hier in der Endopacific in den nächsten einigen Jahrhunderten geschrieben. Wir stehen an einem Inflexionpunkt in der geschichte, wo die Entscheidungen, die wir heute machen, die weltweite Auswirkungen auf unsere Kinder morgen haben werden. diese vibrieren Demokratie ist ein Powerhouse der globalen Innovation.
Die wurde gekauft von Alibaba, ist also auch nicht ganz unabhängig, aber dennoch hört man mitunter dort Stimmen, die interessant sind.
Weil in diesem kontroversiegelten Jobdokument, das auf sozialen Medien verweigert wurde, wird China die Polizei senden lassen, und zudem zerstören, dass die Solomons in Ordnung der sozialen Ordnung sind.
Es wird auch Beijing erlauben, die geplante Strecke zu verhindern, die Sicherheit des chinesischen Personnels und der großen Projekte in dem Land zu schützen.
Und das, wie wir wissen, ist wegen der Anzeigen und Sorgen, die letztes Jahr in den Solomons folgen.
Mal über diese Sicherheitsbedenken, die schon angedeutet wurden. Was ist eigentlich das, was die Pazifik-Inseln interessiert?
Ich bin sehr interessiert, dass du diese Frage über die FG und die Pazifik-Inseln und den Klimawandel gerätst. Es ist das eine Thema, das die australische Regierung nicht mit den USA diskutieren möchte, selbst wenn sie ihre Nachbarn in der Pazifik sind. Bist du wirklich mit dem Kontrast, dass die australische Regierung die Idee der Sicherheit.
Das ist die entscheidende Frage. Und nicht, wie viele in Kamouflage laufen hier eigentlich rum.
Ja, genau. indonesien und so, das ist ja auch alles nicht weit. Und von da ist es ja echt gut dokumentiert, wie sehr die da betroffen sind. Es gab diese Einschätzung des German-Denkstabums, der mal diese, wo geht eigentlich viel kaputt? Und es ist Deutschland, Japan und dann indonesien. Weil da einfach entweder viele Werte sind oder diese kleinen Inseln besonders flach, wo einfach viel kaputt geht. Und da das ja wahrscheinlich allgemein für alle Inselregionen da irgendwie zutritt, ist es in Australien selbst die Hitze, das steigende meeresspiegel drum herum. Das ist wirklich eine krasse Region. Irgendwann werden wir uns wieder, nachdem wir uns jetzt immer uns selber so ein bisschen weg malgenalisierten, wir sind ja nur fünf Prozent der Weltbevölkerung und so, irgendwann werden wir uns wahrscheinlich wieder freuen, dass wir in Europa sitzen, wenn wir dann die richtigen Nachrichten aus dieser Region mal hören.
Nun ist unklar, warum man wirklich diesen Deal eingegangen ist. Vielleicht wollte man damit aber auch nur mal aufschrecken. Und das ist jedenfalls Präsident Sogarware gelungen, dass er sagte, naja, ihr habt euch für die Salomonen nicht interessiert, dann richte ich mich mal an China.
Ich meine, er hat es erfolgreich geschafft, zwei top australische Intelligenz-Chiefen, einen Minister und einen US-lehrer, und dann senior japanische Minister, um Honiara zu fliegen, in ziemlich kurzer Sitzung, mit einigen Verhandlungen auf der Tafel.
Und egal, wie erfolgreich diese Verhandlungen sind, hat er sehr akut demonstriert, die Möglichkeit für pacifische Leader, geopolitische Probleme in ihre Forderungen zu verhindern.
Jetzt hören wir noch in den Spectator-Podcast rein. Da ist der Historiker Rana Mitter unter anderem zu Gast. Und der will jetzt aber nochmal deutlich machen, wo die Unterschiede liegen zwischen China und Russland.
Da gibt es eine echte Unterschiede in den UN-Taktikern von Russland, die natürlich auch noch ein P5-Sicherheitskanzler und China sind. China's Behaviour ist ziemlich genau, wie Ujia es gesagt hat, dass es sich um die Späße, die in der UN existieren und die Strukturen dort befinden, um zu befinden, dass sie versuchen und zu interessen konformieren, die China hat. Das ist ehrlich gesagt die USA, die Russen interessieren sich im Hinblick auf das System. Es ist viel mehr nihilistisch, denn Russen bezieht sich als ein Land, das wirklich am Ende der International Systeme ist. China sieht noch viele Möglichkeiten, um sich in der UN zu verbessern und sein Status in der UN als ein Mittel, um seine eigene Stärkung zu verbessern. Also sind die Russen und die chinesen ziemlich anders, wenn sie in dieser Organisation sind.
Ich halte diese Einschätzung richtig. Bisschen hoffnungsstiftend würde ich sagen.
Oder ist es vielleicht genauso schlimm, nur anders? Das frage ich mich gerade. Er sagt ja, Russland ist nihilistisch. Die sagen, wir wollen das eigentlich alles zerschlagen. Die würden sagen, Menschenrechte, was soll das sein? Jetzt kommt Xi und bezieht sich zwar auf die Menschenrechte, sagt aber, naja, wir sind für die Menschenrechte, aber unsere Menschenrechte sind so. Und ob nicht dieser Einfluss auf die UN dann am Ende so aussieht, dass die einfach ihre Art der Menschenrechte dort festschreiben wollen. Also man weiß gar nicht, mit welchem Gegner es leichter umzugehen oder gibt's wirklich da noch mal die Grundlage einer Partnerschaft. Aber die kann natürlich dann nicht so sein, dass man die Menschenrechte so akzeptiert, wie China sie sich vorstellt.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen, wir Europäer haben ja die UN ziemlich marginalisiert. Es gäbe ja tausend Möglichkeiten, diesen französischen Atomwaffen tragenden Sicherheits-, also permanenten Sicherheitsratssitz irgendwie zu europäisieren. Macron hat es ja angedeutet. Deutschland ist nicht drauf eingegangen. Also da ist einfach eine Möglichkeit verstrichen. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt gesehen, wie China die Hochkommissarin für Menschenrechte da einfach vorführt, aber als Gremium sozusagen noch ernst nimmt. Jaja, du kannst ja gerne herkommen und wir machen dann auch einen großen Termin und der Regierungschef selbst kümmert sich dann darum, dass auch das Foto stimmt und so. Russland dazwischen, das ist ja wirklich verrückt. Auch diese Lage, die jetzt häufiger so thematisiert wird, sie wollen nicht peripher für Europa eine Rolle spielen, ohne da auf Augenhöhe zu sein. Gleichzeitig ist die einzige Alternative, dass sie Junior-Partner Chinas werden, was sie auch nicht wollen. deswegen hängen die da total in der Luft. dieser Art, wie der Rana das hier meint, dass sie da alles kotz und klein schlagen wollen, das sehen wir ja gerade. An der Ukraine, wie sie da von nichts zurück schrecken. Das ist schon eine verrückte Lage eigentlich.
Und er bringt noch ein Beispiel. Wir erinnern uns, gutteres ist ja auch in die Ukraine gereist.
Ein kleines Anekdote. Am Morgen, an dem wir das verabschieden, dass als Generalsekretär gutteres in den USA in Kiev ist, die Russen, so wie es hier ist, vorsichtig, aber ziemlich bequem gefeiert haben, Roketten, Gebäude, sehr nahe wo er ist. In der unwahrscheinlichen Situation mit China haben wir eine Parallele Situation. Es gibt keinen Ort, wo sie das tun, denn der selbe Generalsekretär, Antonio gutteres, ist der selbe Mann, der sich sicher hat, dass China's eigenen Ziels.
In den nächsten zehn Jahren zu verfolgen, welche Filme entstehen. Da gibt es so ein paar hurra-patriotische Filme, will ich mal sagen, aber da gibt es unglaublich viel Kritik. Unglaublich viel Kritik wird von Hollywood gleich verarbeitet. Etwas, was doch in China eher nicht vorstellbar oder gar nicht vorstellbar wäre. Und in eine ähnliche Richtung wird auch hier argumentiert.
China hat keine wirklichen satisfaktiven Mechanismen, um das zu passieren. Die domestik-sphäre von China ist so sehr kontrolliert. In anderen Worten, wenn du sagen möchtest, die USA in Irak Wettbewerb haben, du wirst von jemandem getroffen werden, aber du bist also frei zu tun. Wenn du sagen möchtest, die USA in Irak nichts falsch gemacht haben, wie einige der Schauspieler in der Bush-Ammunistration, Nummer 2 Bush-Ammunistration, gesagt haben, bist du natürlich frei zu tun und zu debattieren. In China kannst du sicherlich ein sehr starkes Argument machen, dass China den ganzen Südchina-Sea nehmen sollte. Es ist viel schwieriger in der chinesischen öffentlichen Sphäre. Das bedeutet in Denktank, es bedeutet eine Diskussion über internationale Beziehungen, es bedeutet in der Regierung als ganzes. Es bedeutet nicht, dass Diskussionen niemals passieren, und manchmal passieren sie hinter geschlossenen Türen. Aber es bedeutet aber, dass das Element der öffentlichen Input, das wir jetzt wissen, und ich denke, alle internationalen Beziehungstheoristen sagen, dass das eigentlich eine sehr wichtige Teil des Schöpings der Außenpolitik, auch in internationalen Organisationen, nicht in China existiert, in der Art, wie es in vielen anderen großen Akteuren in internationalen Organisationen funktioniert. Also für mich ist das eine große Teil der Unterschiede.
Und das würde ich jetzt nochmal gerne stark machen wollen, ohne missverstanden zu werden, und das ist vielleicht nicht ganz leicht. Ich kann durchaus diesem Free-Speech-Argument viel abgewinnen. Ich würde sicherlich mehr rote Linien machen wollen als ein Elon Musk. Und wir haben ja auch einige rote Linien, zum Beispiel unsere geschichte betreffend. Aber dennoch bin ich sehr dagegen, wenn man glaubt, man müsste Meinungsfreiheit einschränken. Natürlich muss auch jeder mit Konsequenzen rechnen, wenn er extreme Meinungen zum Beispiel vertritt. Man kann dann nicht sagen, es läuft alles so weiter und ich kann Karriere machen. Es kann auch sein, dass ein das Publikum dann nicht mehr mag, wenn man gewisse Dinge gesagt hat. Aber wir müssen wirklich aufpassen, dass wir jetzt nicht im Zuge einer, wir müssen uns mal alle wieder besser verstehen und gegen Hass im Netz kämpfen, im Zuge dessen dazu übergeht, dass die Meinungsfreiheit als Wert nicht mehr ganz so wichtig genommen wird, auch wenn da natürlich Kollateralschäden dranhängen. Und die wird man nie auch ganz minimieren können. Aber diese Unterscheidung, die hier gemacht wird zwischen China und Amerika oder zwischen Russland und Europa, könnte man sie machen, ist mir doch eine ganz entscheidende. Denn nur da, wo diese Meinungsfreiheit, und wenn sie auch die Freien Radikalen zulässt, nur da, wo diese Meinungsfreiheit besteht, ist es möglich auch Opposition zu bilden gegen irgendetwas, um tatsächlich auch wieder eine andere Situation zu schaffen. Denn das ist ja das große Problem jetzt auch bei Russland. Man kann natürlich hier sitzen und sagen, Putin muss gestürzt werden. Und die Frage, die sich aber daran anschließt, ist, wer kommt dann? Und wenn ich aber schon die Meinungsfreiheit so lange beschnitten habe, dass ich eigentlich keine Opposition mehr habe, dann ist das Risiko hoch, dass einfach jemand anders kommt, der wie Putin ist, nur anders heißt. Genau. Und deswegen ist diese Meinungsfreiheitsfrage sehr wichtig. Wenngleich ich jetzt nicht hier so Ulf Poschart mäßig sagen will, wir erleben der Cancel Culture, wir können alle nichts mehr sagen. Aber dennoch glaube ich, brauchen wir ein sehr starkes Bewusstsein dafür und manchmal vielleicht auch ein dickes Fell, um zu dieser Meinungsfreiheit genauso auch die Kunstfreiheit zu stehen. Dass man nicht plötzlich sagt, oh das geht aber jetzt nicht und das hat jemanden verletzt. Denn diese Argumentation, der ich fühle mich verletzt, das war eine, die wir kannten von islamistischen Terroristen, die sagen, ich fühle mich in meiner Religion verletzt und deswegen habe ich da mal eine Bombe in die Kirche geworfen, wo das blasphemische Bild hing. Oder diese Argumentation haben wir jetzt von Chi, der sagt, ich bin beleidigt, so könnte nicht mit mir umgehen. Und ihr, die mir da irgendwas von Uiguren erzählen wollt.
Ja, es ist super knifflig. Vielleicht, keine Ahnung, ob man es irgendwie trennen kann, also zwei Diskussionen draus zu machen, so einen politischen Einschlag irgendwo zu identifizieren und das dann aber anders zu behandeln. Auf der anderen Seite, es gibt große Sorgen in Deutschland bei den Wahlkämpfern. Du hast ja bestimmt auch auf dem Kirchentag mitbekommen, wie Olaf Scholz sich da äußerte, nachdem da ein paar Typen aufstanden und nochmal aufs Klima zu sprechen kommen wollten.
Ja, das war natürlich eine unmögliche Aktion von ihm, dass man da gleich so einen Nazi-Vergleich an den Tag legt, nur weil man mal gestört ist. Und ich finde auch, da muss man wieder den Unterschied machen. Er sitzt in der machtvollen Position. Da ist er. Der bundeskanzler sitzt da oben auf dem Podium. Jeder, der das Mikrofon hat, auf dem Podium sitzt, muss auch damit klarkommen, dass er unterbrochen wird. Das ist jedem, glaube ich, der schon mal öffentlich aufgetreten ist, schon mal passiert. Und damit kann man dann auch leben. Und zumal dieser Einwand, der gemacht wird, ja auch mit Argumenten dann bestritten werden kann. Es ist ja keineswegs so, als hätten sie jetzt diese ganze Veranstaltung torpediert. Und das muss man einfach aushalten, gerade weil man auch in dieser Machtposition ist und am Ende immer zum Mikrofon greifen kann.
Genau. Auf der anderen Seite diese Wahlkämpfe, die jetzt abliefen, Saarland, nordrhein-westfalen, schleswig-holstein. Laut der Einschätzung der Journalisten, die da so ein bisschen dabei sind, gibt es wirklich gar keine Veranstaltung mehr, die nicht dauerhaft niedergeschrien wird. Also es scheint bei jeder Veranstaltung, wo landes- oder bundespolitiker da sind, ein dauerhaftes, störendes Pfeif- und Schreikonzert zu geben. Und da hat sich vielleicht auch was aufgestaut bei Olaf Scholz. Er hat es dann überschnappen in der falschen Situation so expliziert. Genau, aber da ist auch einiges, was man thematisiert werden muss. Gerade weil die Journalisteneinschätzungen, also ich referiere jetzt so ein bisschen aus dem Deutschlandfunk, die dann meinten, das ist halt wirklich super neu. Also das war einfach vor einem Jahr noch anders. Das ist einfach jetzt, wer weiß. Aber es werden ja auch schon Torten auf die Mona Lisa geworfen. Also derzeit kreiert ja alles so ein bisschen in die Schieflage.
Jaja, es ist eine eigenartige Verrohung da. Und das wird auch sehr aggressiv geführt. Und das sehe ich auf jeden Fall. Und das wiederum ist ein Problem, das uns wieder zu sozialen Medien und so weiter zurückführen würde. Also dass dann doch nicht nur dieses Pöbeln in den Kommentarspalten stattfindet, sondern auch dann auf der Straße genauso gemacht wird. Meine Erfahrung ist generell, dass der öffentliche Raum, und da findet das ja statt, auch so ein gespräch mit Olaf Scholz, nicht mal als der öffentliche Raum wahrgenommen wird. Und ich kann jetzt wieder meine alte konservative Kritik hier anführen, aber ich will euch das ersparen. Aber ich will nur sagen, wenn man den öffentlichen Raum irgendwann nur noch so versteht, wie sein eigenes Wohnzimmer und im eigenen Wohnzimmer sich aber wie die Sau aufführt, dann darf man sich nicht wundern. deswegen glaube ich, müssen wir mal wieder lernen, wie die öffentliche Sphäre funktioniert. Und das ist auch mein Anliegen, nochmal an alle Menschen, die Bahn fahren und hier zuhören. Wenn wir in einem Ruheabteil sitzen, dann ist Ruhe. Dafür haben wir uns entschieden, da zu sitzen. Und es ist dann nicht wieder heim, wo man nochmal quasseln kann. Nein, dann ist einfach mal Ruhe. Das muss möglich sein. Und da fängt es eigentlich schon an. Und da ist viel verrutscht. Und ich glaube, dass, was wir da dann sehen, dass keine Politikerveranstaltung mehr ohne Schreihälse stattfindet, das ist nur so die extremste Auswirkung eines ziemlich verroten Bürgertums, das da unterwegs ist und einfach nochmal die Ellenbogen ausfährt und sagt, ich mach das jetzt hier, aber ich dreh auch das Handy auf Lautsprecher und telefoniere damit im Zug. Also auch wenn man nicht im Ruheabteil sitzt, würde ich sagen, über Lautsprecher? Ja, das kann doch alles gar nicht sein.
Ich hätte jetzt sonst reingerufen, neues Kahn zu legen, Wolfgang, aber das scheint ja dann.
Ja, aber dann muss man ja irgendwann sich ganz abdichten vor der Wirklichkeit. Wir haben noch drei Clips. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie hoffnungsfrohe stimmen, aber wir wollen noch mal überlegen, ob dieser Konflikt westen, China, kann man den so halten? Also ist China gar nicht westlich? Wird auch noch mal bei dem Spectator-Podcast angesprochen.
western-originiert Konzepte, in jedem Fall.
Das heißt, die internationale Regel, zum Beispiel, kommt von der Notion von westfälischen und Menschenrechten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Konzept in Confusionsismus oder irgendeiner der chinesischen intellektuellen geschichten hat.
Kannst du uns ein bisschen an das fleschen geben?
Ich denke, es gibt zwei Teile der Antwort auf das, Cindy. Die erste ist, dass die Idee, dass westfälische Universitätssysteme in China alien sind, als eine große Überraschung für Präsident Xi Jinping, der oft sagt, dass er ein 21. Jahrhunderts Marxist ist. Denn die letzte Zeit, die ich besucht habe, hat Karl Marx das Gefühl, dass es nicht wirklich aus den Gründen der Shandong-Provizien herrscht. Und es ist der liberalste, den ich an der Zeit nicht in der Fashion finde.
So, also ein Universalismus irgendwie schon, aber nicht dieser Liberale. Er bezieht sich auf Marx. Und jetzt noch mal, auf wen bezieht sich eigentlich da Xi oder der chinesische Diskurs?
Wenn du auf die Außentritte der Confucian-Tradition die zwei größten Denker in Beijing heute hast, sind sie beide Karl, einer von ihnen ist Karl Marx, der andere ist Karl Schmitt. Sie sind beide deutsche Philosophen, einer der 19. und einer der 20. Jahrhundert. Sie haben ziemlich unterschiedliche Ansprüche. Aber sie sind der hoteste Denker in der chinesischen Denkung in Beijing heute.
Na gut, nicht nur das. Und auch wenn Beijing das Gefühl von obsession.
Bezieht sich auf Hobbs, beziehungsweise Karl Schmitt arbeitet sich in seinem gesamtwerk an Hobbs ab. Es geht darum, den Bürgerkrieg zu vermeiden, Ordnung zu schaffen und eine Freund-Feind-Konstellation vielleicht nicht eskalieren zu lassen, aber diese doch als die Grundkonstellation von Politik zu begreifen. Für Karl Schmitt bedeutet aber diese Ordnung im eigenen Reich oder im eigenen Land dann, dass es eine Homogenität herrscht, also dass man nicht ein Parlamentarismus hat, also kein liberaldemokratisches System, sondern das theoretisch auch einer allein bestimmen kann, was für alle gut ist. Es gibt diesen Karl-Schmidt-Aufsatz, wo er Hitler rechtfertigt, der Führerschutz das Recht. diese Idee ist bei Karl Schmitt sehr ausgeprägt. Und er hat noch etwas. Er sagt, dass Großmächte das tun, was Großmächte tun. Damit ist ganz klar das Recht des Stärkeren, auch das geht auf Hobbs zurück, etabliert. Und dann ist noch bei Karl Schmitt das Thema der Menschenrechte. Wer Menschheit sagt, will betrügen. Womit Karl Schmitt sagen will, also wer immer Menschenrechte oder sowas anführt, der will eigentlich nur seine politischen interessen durchdrücken. Und das macht sich jetzt schie zu eigen, indem er sagt, ja gut, wir sind auch für Menschenrechte, aber andere als ihr. Das ist also die Schmitt-Lektüre, die sehr basal jetzt von mir runtergebrochen ist, die in China geleistet wird. Und verquickt mit Marx könnte man fragen, wie geht das noch irgendwie zusammen? Nun gibt es auch so einen Linksschmitt-Jahner. Das geht hier aber, glaube ich, darum geht es hier, glaube ich, nicht, sondern was hier viel stärker wichtig ist, dass man eigentlich eine Idee einer sozialistischen gesellschaft bei Karl Marx zwar ausbuchstabiert hat, aber sich schie gar nicht mehr darauf bezieht. Also ich habe ja diese Reden auch mal gelesen, nicht alle, aber doch sehr viele. Und da wird Marx immer nur so aufgerufen. Worum es viel mehr geht, ist, glaube ich, diese marxistische Idee, dass man von einem Entwicklungsland natürlich erst einmal in ein kapitalistisches Land sich umwandeln muss, um vom Kapitalismus zu einem Sozialismus zu kommen. Und das geht nur mit einer starken Parteilinie. deshalb ist auch eine stark marxistisch-lindensitische Rezeption ist, die da erfolgt. Was aber überhaupt nicht heißt, dass China auf dem Wege zu einem sozialistischen Staat ist. Im Gegenteil wird da ja eigentlich bis auf diese Ketten, die Konzern oder so angelegt wird, eigentlich ein sehr kapitalistisches System gepflegt. Aber diese beiden Pöcke gehen da momentan zusammen. Momentan geht es, glaube ich, in erster Linie darum, eine größtmögliche Souveränität herzustellen, um dann eine großtmögliche wirtschaftliche Macht innerhalb dieser Souveränität zu erreichen. Und da wird dann auf merkwürdige Weise Marx mit Schmitt verquickt.
Ja, sehr gutes Referat. Und ich will noch anfügen, wir sind ja aus diesem politischen Denken dann auch herausgewachsen. Ja, also in der Hinsicht besteht ja auch die Möglichkeit. Ich glaube, dass sie einfach weiter lesen, jetzt nachdem sie beim Leviathanischen angekommen sind, dass sie dann so ein paar Jahrhundertsprünge machen und dann sich auch da noch ideologisch modernisieren.
Dabei gibt es ja auch bei den Menschenrechten tatsächlich chinesische Wurzeln, auch darauf wird noch hingewiesen.
Was wir jetzt auch wissen und ich glaube wirklich, das sollte nicht untersteht, ist, wie voll all diese Systeme von Taten aus der europäischen Sphere, der globalen Süden, um die Phrase, die wir vorhin in der gespräche genannt haben, nur ein paar Beispiele, besonders in der Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts, die mit den Themen, die wir gesprochen haben, handeln. Es ist nun well-known, aber ich denke, es ist nur wert, wieder zu sagen, die universelle Declaration der Menschenrechte.
Und es besteht die Möglichkeit hier noch mal mit etwas launigem, künstlerischem. Ich glaube, es ist auch ein Thema, mit dem man sich jetzt auch ein bisschen kulturell prägend zu schließen, nämlich mit dem iPod. Der iPod wurde beendet. Apple hat gesagt, es werden keine iPods mehr hergestellt. Klar, sie sind jetzt auch in die iphones gewandert. Du hast bestimmt davon gelesen, es gibt die große Versteigerung.
Ja, ich wollte gerade drauf zu sprechen kommen.
Karl Lagerfeld hatte 600 iPods. Ja, klar, man kann natürlich ein Kabel anschließen und da Musik drauf spielen, aber man kann ja auch einmal was draufladen, dann einfach mit Klebeband drauf schreiben, was drin ist, das ins Regal stellen und sagen, was, wonach ist mir gerade? Ach so, dann wie in so einer Platten-Sammlung.
Er hat da ZDs daraus gemacht.
Genau. Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt, ist in, es ist so eine besondere Dekadenz auf der einen Seite, die Karl Lagerfeld hier zugestanden ist. Aber in dem Moment, wo er diese verschiedenen iPods hat und sie wie Platten-CD-Sammlung einfach aufreit, kann man natürlich zu ihm gehen und da stöbern und entdecken. Und es ist dieses alte Entdecken in einem Bücherregal, in der Bibliothek und so weiter. So und vor Jahren, 15 Jahren vielleicht, keine Ahnung, hat Johnny Häusler, der heute nicht mehr so viel Spreeblick schreibt, sondern mehr so Republikan, sowas organisiert, einen Text geschrieben bei Spreeblick über seine Erfahrung. Er als Kind konnte in der Plattensammlung seine Eltern stöbern, seine Kinder können das nicht mehr, weil keine Magazine mehr auf dem Küchentisch liegen, in dem man stöbern kann und auch die Plattensammlung eben in die Geräte gewandert ist. Und erstaunlicherweise jetzt so 10, 15 Jahre später, wo der iPod in Rente geschickt wird, reden die bei The Verge Cast so darüber, über den iPod, wie Johnny Häusler über seine Plattensammlung gesprochen hat. Und da hab ich so gedacht, das ist ja krass. Also wie kann das denn passieren? Das ist einfach 15 Jahre später unter eigentlich anderen Voraussetzungen und wir dachten, der Bogen ist schon geschlagen, es ist schon alles ins Gerät gewandert, dass jetzt noch mal gemacht werden kann, das Argument. Also es ist ganz verrückt, wir hören uns mal diese eine Minute an.
Eine der Dinge, die ich dieses Wochen viel über den iPod gedacht habe, war, dass so viel iPod-Ursprung kommunal war.
Du denkst an ein headphones-device, du bist allein, du hast deinen Moment, aber du warst nicht für Leute, die deine Fotos sehen.
iPods waren nicht geschlossen.
Du hattest einfach dein iPod an andere Leute, oder du hast es in ihren Dokumenten geplugt, oder was auch immer.
Das war die Ad-Kampagne.
Es war ein gescheites Device, und sehr wenige unserer devices werden mehr so gescheitert, weil sie den Vergangenen, die presse, und den Zukunft unserer Persönlichkeiten enthalten.
Und jetzt denkst du, du siehst nicht mal mein Handy an.
Dann konnten die einfach mal stöbern. Während wir in diesem Podcast, in diesem Monat, wo wir das thematisieren, dass der iPod jetzt nicht fortgesetzt wird, gleichzeitig darüber reden, dass wir für 100 Milliarden einfach unsere Persönlichkeit verkaufen, weil natürlich in unsere Geräte geschaut wird. Und sich dann nicht dafür interessiert wird, was für Musik, sondern genau das, was wir für uns behalten wollen. weshalb wir die Geräte nicht mehr rausgeben, dadurch unser kulturelles Ich nicht mehr nach außen tragen und präsentieren, also es ist total verdreht und verrückt, ja. Was für ein Zustand der Welt das hier so insgesamt ist. Und welchen Platz wir in der Welt haben. Und wer sich hier so alles an uns vertut.
Und man kann nur Spotify-Listen oder sowas anlegen. Oder wenn man filmen, ist es ja dann so, dass viele bei Letterboxx sind. Das ist dann die Möglichkeit. Aber tatsächlich hat man nicht das dann so in der Hand. Wir kooperieren allerdings weiter mit Apple, auch ohne iPod. Das heißt, man kann unseren Podcast, also den Podcast darüber sowieso hören und auch den Salon buchen. Das haben jetzt auch schon einige getan. Vielen Dank dafür. Und weiterhin ist der Salon natürlich buchbar über Steady nach wie vor unsere präferierte Variante. Da kann man also buchen. Und ich verspreche mal, es wird ein Hammer-Salon. Erst mal werde ich wieder besser bei Stimme sein. Aber ich glaube, wir haben unglaublich interessante Texte. Und zwar werden wir zusammen zwei Bücher besprechen, weil wir uns gedacht haben, die beiden Bücher sind kurz. Also dann nehmen wir doch gleich zwei. Und zwar einmal von Catherine Liu, Virtue Horders, The Case Against the professional Managerial Class und PMC abgekürzt. Das haben wir schon bei Rotshuli und den anderen so gefunden. Es geht darum, dass da eine Elite entstanden ist von Arbeitern, von angestellten, die ja tugendhaft ist, die Tugend geradezu hamstert und die in so einem merkwürdigen, progressiven Heroismus gefangen ist, damit aber den eigentlichen Arbeitskampf überlagert. Das ist, glaube ich, hochinteressant. Sie ist professorin an der Universität von Kalifornien. Und ich bin sehr gespannt auf diesen sehr schmalen Band. Das sind ja nur 80 Seiten, aber ich glaube, die werden es in sich haben.
Es wurde uns empfohlen, als die klügere Version der Selbstgerechten von Wagenknecht.
So, so, dann werden wir das auch unter diesem Sichtpunkt wahrnehmen. Und dann schauen wir uns an, was hier schon aufgeschrieben wurde, was du dann in der Alten Republik nicht noch mal aufschreiben musst. Und zwar von johannes Müller-Salow. Offene Rechnungen, der kalte Konflikt der Generationen. Er ist wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am Institut für Philosophie der Leibniz-Universität. Und er fragt sich, der Konflikt zwischen den Generationen ist längst da. Wo aber bleibt der offene, engagierte und aufrichtige Streit? Also das werden wir uns ansehen und das debattieren. Und dann werde ich die schon vier genannten Autoren vorstellen, Paul Mason antwortet auf Habermas, Cizek antwortet auch auf Habermas, ohne ihn direkt zu erwähnen, Adam Toos setzt sich mit Habermas auseinander und Fukuyama. Und dann habe ich ein Buch gelesen, das sensationell ist. Da möchte ich viel von berichten. Ich hoffe, es wird alles nicht zu lang. Amanda D. Lotz ist professorin für digitale Medien und hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Netflix and Streaming Video, The business of Subscriber Funded Video on Demand. Und man denkt, muss man 180 Seiten einfach nur darüber schreiben, dass man jetzt Video on Demand hat wie Netflix. Und da gibt es so viel zu zu sagen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und ich war sehr skeptisch. Ich wollte es eigentlich nur so professionell zur Kenntnis nehmen. Habe mich aber dann da festgelesen und es sind ganz erstaunliche Überlegungen, die sie da hat. Und wir erleben also auch den Untergang des klassischen Hollywood-Systems. Aber in ganz anderer Weise. Hier geht es auch gar nicht darum, zu sagen, ja, wir besprechen mal einzelne Produktionen von Netflix oder so. Hier steht auch einfach mal drin, ja, Skit Game ist für Netflix erfolgreich. Aber es ist auch gar nicht so wichtig, ob das erfolgreich jetzt bei Netflix war. Wichtig ist was anderes. Und das ist ein Buch mit vielen kontraintuitiven Betrachtungen. Und das Tolle ist auch da, hat sich einfach mal jemand hingesetzt, hat zum einen sehr lange nachgedacht, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Und das ist so erstaunlich, wir haben jetzt das Jahr 2022 und dass das jetzt erst mal so durchdacht wird, wo wir ja diese Anbieter schon länger haben, aber dass man wirklich mal die ganze Tragweite vermessen will. Und das tut sie in diesem Buch.
Sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Wie du das alles raussammelst, während du gleichzeitig noch jeden Abend irgendwo anders in Deutschland bist, um Vorträge zu halten, ist beeindruckend.
Die Bahnverspätungen machen es möglich, da kann man viel lesen.
Genau. Mein eigenes Altenrepublik-Buch ist erst mal vom Tisch. Am Mittwoch ist es in die Korrektur gegangen. Das Lektorat ist absolviert. Im Verlag sind alle zufrieden, ich auch. Und daher kämpfe ich mich gerade wieder raus, in diese Freiheitssachen zu lesen. Mir ist sehr daran gelegen, nachdem wir zwei Bücher gemeinsam lesen. Da du ein großes Programm hast, belasse ich es dann mal bei drei weiteren Texten. Und ich werde mich mal darauf konzentrieren, was da im Silicon Valley mit den Werten, also mit den Börsenwerten gerade los ist. Ich suche noch Texte dazu, aber das würde mich mal interessieren, denn die Einbrüche sind ja wirklich gigantisch. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit echter Wertvernichtung zu tun. Gerade bei Netflix, das ist ja doch Rambazamba. Also vielleicht kann ich deine inhaltliche Argumentation noch mal mit Weltlage, Finanz und so weiter da ergänzen. Aber sehen, vielleicht taucht auch noch irgendwas anderes auf. Dann mache ich das, genau, sehr gut.
Prima, dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten Woche im Salon und wünschen bis dahin eine gute Zeit.
yes, haut rein, bis dahin.